ALAN ARCHULETA AT KINS BASICS
BACKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABRERO CORTESE DALLY DODD THE
RISER EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTS BERG WEST SO HER
TADO. JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED
LLEVA MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN ROADSHOW ABODE
HAN FORTUNE TINO AUTHOR RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WAKE
HOUSEKI WINNER WILL. MEMBERS OF
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT WE WOULD
ASK OUR GUEST IN MEMBERS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY TO
RICE. WE'LL BE LET THIS MORNING
EMPEROR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN PLEDGE. BY SOONER
CALM WATER. SOME TWENTY THREE
FOR BUSY PEOPLE WITH APOLOGIES
TO THE PSALMIST. THE LORD IS MY
PACESETTER I SHALL NOT RUSH GOD
HELPS ME STOP AND REST FOR
QUIET INTERVALS PROVIDING ME
WITH IMAGES OF STILLNESS.
RESTORING MY SERENITY. GOD
LEADS ME IN THE WAY OF
EFFICIENCY THROUGH CALMNESS OF
MIND. THE GUIDANCE IS PEACE
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE MANY THINGS
TO ACCOMPLISH TODAY AND CRISIS
MAY PILE UPON CRISIS I WILL NOT
FALL APART FOR GOD'S PRESENCE
IS HERE GOD TIMELESSNESS WILL
KEEP ME IN BALANCE. SHARES
REFRESHMENT AND RENEWAL IN THE
MIDST OF MY ACTIVITIES. GOT
ANNOYED MY MIND WITH THE OIL OF
INSPIRATION. SURELY HARMONY AND
EFFECTIVENESS WILL BE THE FRUIT
OF MY HOURS AND I SHALL WALK IN
THE PEACE OF THE LORD THIS DAY.
A MAN. YEAH. IT IS POSSIBLE.
THIS CALL. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
FULL DAY SO WE'RE STARTING OFF
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEAN READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BEGIN READ.
REPORTS FROM THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEAN READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. THIS IS THE TIME
MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANT TO BE REMOVED.
FROM THE DAILY FILE OR
CONSECUTIVELY- NOW IT'S TIME.
MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
ITEMS THAT YOU WANT TO REMOVE.
FROM THE FILE TODAY NOW IS THE
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE MOVING ON.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON NOW TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OH FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU NOW
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE FIFTY ITEMS
THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET
THROUGH THE DAY AND I OPE WHEN
WE CALL UPON MEMBERS YOU'RE
READY TO GO SO WE CAN WORK TO
FOLLOW AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
TODAY SO WE'LL SHORTEN OUR DAY
TOMORROW OUR FIRST ITEM UP HIS
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN. BY SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
I DON'T. HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE- BROWSE ON FILE
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM.
TWENTY TWO. FINISH STERN AGAIN
ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FOLLOWING
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR STERN AS
B. TWO EIGHTY FOUR. SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION. SINISTER
IN THE FLOOR'S YOURS. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP TWO
EIGHTY FOUR WITH A DRESS A VERY
SENSITIVE ISSUE OF
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURIES
AMONGST OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
BACK IN- TWENTY NINETEEN. WE
FINALLY BROUGHT SOME JUSTICE TO
THOSE WHO PUT EVERYTHING ON THE
LINE FOR US BY. PRESUMING THAT
IF YOU WERE A FIREFIGHTER OR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHO'S
EXPOSED TO TRAUMA IN YOUR
WORKPLACE THAT WORKERS
COMPENSATION WOULD PRESUME THAT
SHE WOULD. CONTAIN THAT INJURY
AT WORK- SUICIDE RATES ARE AT
AN ALL TIME HIGH AMONGST OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS. AS WE'VE
LEARNED ALL TOO. BRIEFLY THIS
WEEK- BACK IN LA- THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT AFFECTS OUR
FRONTLINE FOLKS- OFTEN AS
HORRIBLE AND HORRIFIC
REPERCUSSIONS THIS BILL WOULD
FIX A GAP IN THAT TWENTY
NINETEEN LAW BY MAKING SURE
THAT ALL THOSE FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS CARE
THAT'S- THAT'S THE NINE ONE ONE
OPERATORS WHO HAVE TO TAKE
THESE CALLS. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN PARKS
AND ELSEWHERE SO- BILL IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
MANNER. MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN C. NINE MEN
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FALLING TWENTY TWO. ALAN
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
BYRON. CORTEZ THREE FIVE DALLY.
DOT TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI
HER TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER
HI LAYERED. I LLEVA FIVE THE
MON. MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN
HI NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW OF
BOTH. PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH I REVERE FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE STERN HI I'M BURGLARY HI
KELSEY FIVE WINNER HI WELK.
SENATOR STERN MOVES A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR ALAN
ARE YOU PREPARED THEM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL SIX
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN AN
ACT RELATING TO HOSPICE.
THROUGHOUT CALLING FOR GEORGE
YES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
THIS BILL IMPOSES A TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM ON NEW HOSPICE
LICENSURE THAT WOULD EXPIRE A
YEAR AFTER THE COMPLETION OF A
STATE AUDIT. TO IDENTIFY
DEFICIENCIES AND RECOMMEND
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE HOSPICE
LICENSURE AND OVERSIGHT PROCESS
IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE OSPICE
MOVEMENT AND ITS INTEGRATION
INTO WESTERN MEDICINE IS AN
UPLIFTING STORY ABOUT
COMPASSION. AND THE BEST
INSTINCTS OF HUMANITY EMBRACING
THE MISSION OF PROVIDING
COMFORT AND SOLACE. TO THOSE
AMONG US WHO ARE DYING. BUT
THERE'S BEEN A- SERIES OF MEDIA
REPORTS AND GOVERNMENT SURVEYS
THAT SUGGEST A LACK OF
OVERSIGHT HAS LED TO AN
UNSCRUPULOUS BUSINESS. A GROUP
OF BUSINESSES ENTERING THE
FIELD I FOCUS MORE ON PROFIT
AND PAIN MANAGEMENT. IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH PROBLEMS APPEAR
Q. FOUR PROFIT HOSPICE
LICENSORS IN OUR STATE HAVE
RISEN DRAMATICALLY IN RECENT
YEARS ESPECIALLY THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY WHICH WHETHER
EXPONENTIALLY MORE HOSPICE
PROVIDERS PER CAPITA. THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE UNITED
STATES I MEAN JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE SEVERAL CITIES IN LA
COUNTY HAVE MORE. HOSPICES
THEN- THE ENTIRE STATE OF
FLORIDA OR NEW YORK. AN EXPOSE
IN THE LA TIMES IS THE END OF
THE YEAR LAST YEAR SUGGESTED
THIS BOOM. HAS QUOTE SPAWNED A
COTTAGE INDUSTRY OF ILLEGAL
PRACTICES IN A TWENTY NINETEEN
INVESTIGATION AT SACRAMENTO BEE
FOUND CALIFORNIA'S HOSPICES
THEM TO BE QUOTE. MARRED BY LAX
OVERSIGHT AND INABILITY OF
REGULATORS TO TAKE MEANINGFUL
ACTION. AGAINST HOSPICES THAT
MAY HAVE VIOLATED RULES AND
JEOPARDIZE THE HEALTH OF
PATIENTS. SO I HAVE SUBMITTED
AN AUDIT REQUESTED PROPOSES AN
EXAMINATION OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS IN AN EXPLORATION.
OF PATHWAYS FOR POSSIBLE REFORM
OF THE HOSPICE LICENSURE AND
OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK. VERY
COMMITTED TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH- THE
MEMBERSHIP AND STAKEHOLDERS. TO
HAD TO PURSUE A COMPREHENSIVE
MEANINGFUL REQUESTED THE STATE
AUDITOR WILL ALSO. PRESSING THE
PAUSE BUTTON ON WHAT APPEARS TO
BE A PROFIT MOTIVE THAT AT
LEAST IN SOME REGIONS OF OUR
STATE. IS SIGNIFICANTLY
OUTPACING PATIENT DEMAND. AND
WITH THAT I ASK THAT YOU HELP
ME IN THIS EFFORT AND- TO VOTE
FOR THIS BILL. I THINK YOU
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BORDERS. HIS
PRESENT- MAY I POSE A QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR. GENERAL YOU
ACCEPT QUESTIONS YES SIR GOOD
CHEER THANK YOU- WAS THERE A-
REQUESTED J. LOCK. TO CONDUCT
AN AUDIT ON THIS ISSUE YES
WE'VE JUST SUBMITTED A REQUEST.
WOULD IT BE MORE HELPFUL TO-
PUSH THIS LEGISLATION BACK
PENDING THE FINDINGS OF THAT
AUDITING CURRENT. WELL- SO
WE'VE BETTER EFFECTIVELY- THE
IDEA IS THAT WE WANT TO PUT A
PAUSE BUTTON NOW BECAUSE THERE
DOES SEEM TO BE A PROBLEM
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROLIFERATION OF THESE HOSPICES
AS I SAY WE'VE GOT SO MANY MORE
HOSPICES IN ANY OTHER STATE I
MEAN JUST IT IT IT BLOWS THE
NUMBERS BELOW EVERY OTHER STATE
OUT OF THE WATER- SO THAT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO THEY DIDN'T
THEY DIDN'T APPEAR THERE WOULD
BE ANY SIGNIFICANT. IMPACT ON
ON- AND- PATIENT ACCESS- YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU READ THE
REPORTS I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THEY DID DATE THE CURRENT
SITUATION MERITS PAUSING- NEW
LICENSORS UNTIL WE HAVE BETTER
INFORMATION AND BETTER
UNDERSANDING FROM THE AUDITOR
SO I HEAR YOU I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ THE
OTHER I'LL BRING YOU A COPY OF
THE LA TIMES ARTICLE AND- THEY
DID A PRETTY STINGING EXPOSE
THAT HAS LED ME TO THE PLACE
WHERE I BELIEVE THIS IS THE
RIGHT MEASURE TO TAKE NOW-
BEFORE- WE DO GET THE DATA FROM
THE AUDITOR OBVIOUSLY THE
AUDITOR'S. REPORT WELL. WELL
WELL THEN STEER WHERE WE GO
FROM HERE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION BY CENTER
BORDERS. K. NINE SENATOR GRAHAM.
INTERMENT FIGURE MARKS ON THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF. SB SIX SIXTY FOUR-
AS AS SOMEBODY WHO SPENT A
LARGE PART OF MY CAREER WORKING
AND STUDYING IN THE IN THE
HOSPICE BASE IT IS A FANTASTIC.
ORGANIZATION I SAY WITH PRIDE
THAT MY MOM WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST SPANISH SPEAKING
VOLUNTEERS- IN IN HOSPICE- WAY
BACK. IN THE EARLY DAYS AND SHE
LOST A FRIEND IN A AND THAT WAS
HER DEDICATION TO GO IN. AND
WORK WITH LATINO COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY WHO OFTENTIMES IN
HAVE ACCESS- BUT WHAT WE HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN SINCE THE ADVENT
OF HOSPICES THE PROLIFERATION.
OF FOR PROFIT HOSPICES COMING
IN WHEN HOSPICE FIRST STARTED
IT WAS JUST FREE FOR EVERYBODY
BASED ON ON ON DONATIONS BUT
AFTER THE AFTER WEEK BECAUSE-
AS A SOCIETY DECIDED IT WAS A
REIMBURSABLE- A SERVICE. AND
THEN HAD A PER DIEM RATE BOTH
WITH MEDICARE AND MEDICAID AL
AND THEN MOST PRIVATE
INSURANCES WE SAW A- HUGE BOOM
AND GROWTH IN HOSPICE YOU HAD
TO SET AN INDUSTRY BUT AN
INDUSTRY. SO WHAT STARTED OUT
AS YOUR LOCAL NONPROFIT
ATTACHED TO YOUR HOSPITAL WHO
WAS DOING THIS FANTASTIC WORK
AND DOING A REALLY PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES AT THE END
OF LIFE PEOPLE WOULD DESCRIBE.
US AS WORKERS AS ANGELS AND IT
BECAME- SOME OF THESE- AND FOR
PROFIT HOUSES THAT COME IN AND
IS FLOOD THE MARKET WITH THEIR
OWN- MARKETING THEY HAVE- MOST
MOST OF THE TRADITIONAL HOUSES
ARE MORE NON PROFIT- BASED AND
THESE CAME IN WITH A- BIG
BANKROLLS FOR. MARKETING AND
WENT OUT VERY VIGOROUSLY INTO
PATIENTS HOMES INTO FACILITIES
TO. GET AS MANY CLIENTS AS THEY
COULD WHICH THEN AT THE SAME
TIME HURTS THE MORE TRADITIONAL
HOSPICE HAS BEEN OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY DOING THIS WORK FOR
EVER. AND SO I WOULD RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THAT TO PUT A
PAUSE ON ALL THESE NEW ONES
JUST POPPING UP EVERYWHERE- IT
IT IT IT I FEEL LIKE IT IT
DIMINISHES CARE AND CAN EVEN
THEN DIMINISH. I THINK
PEOPLE'S. PERCEPTION OF A
HOSPICE IN AND THAT REPUTATION.
AS IT HAS COME INTO THIS THE
SPACE OF JUST SOMETIMES FEELING
LIKE A TRYING TO GET THAT
REIMBURSEMENT AND MAYBE THE
WHOLE PLETHORA OF CARE AND
AFTER CARE AND BEREAVEMENT
SUPPORT. AND THE VOLUNTEER BASE
THAT IS A HUGE PART OF THE
HOSPICE I HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO
DEVELOP. A SO I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON SB SIX SIXTY FOUR. AND THEN
I'M SURE AFTER THE HOUSE REPORT
WILL HAVE EVEN MORE CHANGES BUT
TO PUT A PAUSE. ON NEW ONES
COMING IN RIGHT NOW I THINK.
IT'S A GOOD IDEA AND I WOULD
FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON ESPYS.
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SOONER AND
SOONER ALL OF WHICH ARE CLOSE
WELL THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
THEM MY COLLEAGUE THANK YOU
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON FOR THE
FOR THAT- I THINK YOU MADE
BILL I WOULD SAY TO MY FRIEND
FROM FRESNO. ON THE CENTER FOR
JUST YOU KNOW I I'M JUST TO
KIND OF FOLLOW UP A LITTLE MORE
ON YOUR ON YOUR QUESTION AND I
THINK WE ARE CERTAINLY IF IT'S
A VISIT INTERESSE WORKED WE'RE
OPEN TO MORE TARGETED
MORATORIUM PERHAPS ON REGIONAL
GROUNDS IT'S ACTUALLY THE CASE.
THAT THE REAL PROBLEMS IN THIS
SPACE ARE IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE STATE AND SO IF THERE'S
SOME WAY THAT WE CAN CRAFT- THE
MORATORIUM IN A WAY THAT WOULD
WOULD REALLY FOCUS ON THE AREAS
OF THE CITY WE HAVE MOST
CONCERNED- THE OLD REALLY THE
YOU KNOW THE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT THAT THERE
NOT BE ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS AS
A RESULT OF THIS BILL THAT
MIGHT. IMPINGE UPONACCESS TO
THE HOT TO GOOD QUALITY HOSPICE
CARE AND WORK MORE RURAL PARTS
OF THE STATES I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
WITH OTHER MEMBERS TO- TOOK TO
CRAFT TO CRAFT THIS IN A WAY
THAT WILL BE REALLY THOUGHTFUL
CAREFUL- BUT IN THE END OF THE
DAY THERE THERE REALLY IS.
SERIOUS FRAUD TARGETING OLDER
AMERICANS AS A MENTION THE LA
TIMES IS DONE EXTENSIVE
JOURNALISM ON THIS TOPIC I
THINK AND IT MERITS THIS THIS
PAUSE BUTTON TO BE PRESSED
UNTIL WE HAVE MORE DATA FROM
THE AUDITOR AND WITHOUT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON FILE.
I DON'T. FOUR ALAN HI ARCHULETA
HI AT KENS FIVE BASE. BACKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI CABRERA
HI COURTESY HI DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO HI AIKMAN HI GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NOPE CAN'T LONGER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA. I LIVE
ALONE I REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S.
MAN HI NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. A
SHOW OF BOTH NO PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI ROTH I REVERE. HI
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER ALL
RIGHT I LIKE ASKING FIVE WINNER.
FIVE WELL NO. GENERAL MOVED TO
CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOWING TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR GLAZER. AND SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. SENATOR FOR GEORGE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SP
SIX EIGHTY SIX SIX TO PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY. AND
DISCLOSURE FOR LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES THAT MAKE
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS. L. L.
C.'S HAVE LIMITED EXISTING
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
ANOTHER EXISTING LAWS. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
IN THEIR ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
EXAMINE LLC'S AND FOUND IT WAS
RELATIVELY EASY TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT AN L. L. C.'S
TYPE. OF BUSINESS IT'S A DRESS
IT'S AGENTS FIRST OF PROCESS
HOWEVER. IT WAS EXTREME
DIFFICULT AND MANY TIME IN PAST
TO. AN L. L. C. OWNER OR THE
TRUTH OF FOR AN L. L. C.
POLITICAL. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH THE
DISH AND- ON LLCS THAT MAKE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO KNOW
WHO'S TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE
POLITICAL PROCESS. THIS BILL IS
A SIMPLE YET MEANINGFUL
APPROACH TO PROVIDE CLARITY
REGARDING POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS. AND AIMS TO
DISCLOSE THE TRUE SOURCE OF
FUNDS USED BY L. L. C.'S. THE
BILL SPONSORED BY THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
AND I RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOU TO
VOTE THANK YOU. MEMBERS ANY.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. NINETEEN NINETY
MINUTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. HI
AT KINS. HI FAITH. BECKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD HI BYRON HI
COURTESY HI DALLY NO DONT. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
BY JONES NOPE CAN LONGER HI
LAYERED. HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
VOGUE. PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBER FIVE BY CASTING
HI WINNER. FIVE WELL NOW.
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FALL I'M TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR
GONZALES ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR POLLUTION
CLEANER GONZALEZ THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AS THE SEVEN
TO SIX WHICH MAKES THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MORE
EQUITY FOCUSED AND WILL CREATE
A PLAN TO REDUCE EMISSIONS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AS A
WHOLE THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM CURRENTLY ALLOCATES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ASKING SEVEN TO SIX TO
MODERNIZE ITS PROGRAM. AND
FOCUSED ON ADVANCING EQUITY
INCLUDING GETTING THE DIRTIEST
DIESEL POWERED TRUCKS OFF THE
ROAD AS B. TWO SEVEN TWO SIX
ALSO CREATES A SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY WHICH
WILL DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
TARGETS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR REQUIRES THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A LEAD
AGENCYTO OVERSEE THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FOCUS CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS IN
EQUITY AND DEVELOP TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION THAT WOULD
CREATE A BRIGHTER AND HEALTHIER
FUTURE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. ON SB SEVEN TWO
SIX. THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION
DEBATE ON THIS SIDE OF. IN
CHINO AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAIT.
BACKER FIVE PORGES NO BRADFORD
I COULD BUY A- HI CORTEZ HE HI
SALLY NO DODD HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN. HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NELSON. A CHILL OF
BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER.
FIVE STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT
HI WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER
FIVE WELL. NOW. THIRTEEN
DOLLARS MOVES A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FOLLOWING TWENTY SEVEN SOONER
FAN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
ITEM I SEE THAT HE IS FROM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
PAN AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMES
IN DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR BROWN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE TO
PRESENT SP FOUR SEVEN FORTY TWO
BILL THAT BALANCES OUR RIGHT TO
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE PRIVACY
AND FREEDOM OF SPEECH. FOR OVER
A YEAR WE'VE WORKED TO SAVE AS
MANY LIVES AS POSSIBLE DURING
COVERT NINETEEN FACTOR
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW OF ALMOST
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CASES. OF IT AND OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND KNOWN DEATHS.
FORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF DECADES
OF RESEARCH AND SCIENCE AROUND
IMMUNOLOGY WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
BRING THIS PANDEMIC TO A CLOSE.
AND WE'RE FINALLY STARTING TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER THAT OPPORTUNITY MAY BE
LOST IF WE DON'T GET ENOUGH
PEOPLE VACCINATED. AND WHILE
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE DOING BETTER EACH DAY
DISTRIBUTING THESE COVER
VACCINES AND EDUCATING PEOPLE
ABOUT THE NEED FOR THE VACCINE
ANTI VACCINE EXTREMISTS. THAT
WE'RE ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH IN
THIS VERY CHAMBER ARE
ESCALATING THEIR TACTICS TO
DISRUPT AND PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
GETTING THE VACCINE. AND THAT'S
WHY I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN FORTY TWO TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRACTICE FREE SPEECH. AND BE
SURE THAT PUBLIC OFFICIALS HAVE
THE TOOLS TO ENSURE PATIENTS IN
FRONT LINE WORKERS AT VACCINE
CLINICS ARE SAFE FROM
INTIMIDATION HARASSMENT. AND
PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTIONS INCLUDING
THE PRIVACY. MANY OF YOU ARE
AWARE OF THE SHUTDOWN OF THE
VACCINE CLINIC IN JANUARY AT
DODGER STADIUM WHERE A MOB OF
ANTI VACCINE EXTREMISTS STOP
THE CLINIC FROM OPERATING
JEOPARDIZING THE SAFETY
PATIENTS PHONE LINE WORKERS.
BUT THESE EXTREMISTS ARE
CONDUCTING SIMILAR OPERATIONS
ALL OVER THE STATE OFTEN TRYING
TO BLEND IN AS FRONT LINE
WORKERS. AND DISRUPTING
OPERATIONS EVEN RESORTING TO
TACTICS LIKE TARGETING FARM
WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES THAT
MOST. ARE MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED
BY COVERT NINETEEN AND NEED THE
VACCINE THE MOST. OFTEN DURING
THESE DRILLS THE ANTI VACCINE
EXTREMISTS ARE RECORDING
HARASSMENT. TO PUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND OUT PERSONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING THE VACCINE AS WELL AS
VIOLATING THE PRIVACY OF THE
PATIENTS AS WELL. CONDITIONALLY
WHILE WE'RE DISTRIBUTING
VACCINES AND ADDITIONAL
HEALTHCARE SPACES LIKE
HOSPITALS DOCTORS OFFICES AND
PHARMACIES WERE ALSO USING
NONTRADITIONAL LOCATIONS LIKE
STADIUMS SCHOOL CAMPUSES
PARKING LOTS. AND OTHER PLACES
WE'RE CREATING NEW LOGISTICAL
SITUATIONS THAT MY BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS IN FACT JUST LAST
WEEK A WOMAN PLOWED THROUGH A
TENT IN THE CAR. IN OUR EFFORT
TO DISRUPT VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
NARROWLY MISSING HEALTHCARE
WORKERS NATIONAL GUARDSMEN WHO
WERE THERE TO GIVE THE VACCINE.
WE NEED TO BE CLEAR THAT WE
STAND WITH PATIENCE AND
FRONTLINE WORKERS AS THEY TRY
TO BRING AN END TO THE
PANDEMIC. FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND OFFICIALS PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY. DOING
THEIR JOB BUT IT SHOULD NOT
EXTEND TO FEAR OF HARASSMENT
ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE IN THE
GUISE OF PROTEST. OPPONENTS OF
THIS BILL ARGUE THEY WERE TAKEN
AWAY FREE SPEECH BUT THIS IS A
FALSE CHOICE. WE CAN CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FREE SPEECH
PROTECTED FOR PRIVACY AND
ACCESS TO VACCINES THERE'S AN
URGENCY CLAUSE SO THAT LOCAL
OFFICIALS CAN. PROTECT
VACCINATION CLINICS
IMMEDIATELY. I APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED SO FAR RESPECT THE
OSCAR NIGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS OF THE VERY ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR WARNER. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FORTY TWO
AND I WANT TO REALLY DEEPLY
THANK THE SENATOR FROM-
SACRAMENTO FOR HIS ONGOING AND
TENACIOUS- EFFORTS TO- TAKE A
REALLY A SCIENCE BASED APPROACH
AROUND VACCINES AND UNDERSTAND
THE VACCINES ARE SO BENEFICIAL.
FOR THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND HE'S DONE SO- PARTICULARLY-
DESPITE PERSONAL ATTACKS AND
EVEN PHYSICAL ASSAULTS OF THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL WE KNOW THAT
VACCINES ARE OUR PATH OUT OF
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
WE'RE SEEING. AROUND THE WORLD
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN COUNTRIES
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE PEOPLE ARE DYING AROUND
THE WORLD BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE VACCINE HERE
IN THE US WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO
HAVE THAT ACCESS- AND YET WE
SEE CONCERTED EFFORTS TO TRY TO
DISSUADE PEOPLE FROM TAKING THE
VACCINE. AND WE'RE SEEING
HIGHER CODE RATES IN THOSE
AREAS PEOPLE STILL DYING- AND
EVEN HERE AS WE SAW IN LOS
ANGELES PHYSICALLY OBSTRUCT
PEOPLE. FROM RECEIVING THE
VACCINE VACCINE IS THIS IS US
IS SO CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND
AMERICA- AND WE WILL HAVE
FUTURE PANDEMICS- AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE
PROTECTING ACCESS TO
VACCINATION. THANK YOU CENTER
GORGEOUS- I THINK. WHEN YOU
HAVE PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTION AND
INTIMIDATION THAT CANNOT BE
TOLERATED- FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS OBVIOUSLY MOST OBVIOUS
IS YOU WANT TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS-
TO GET VACCINATED BY MYSELF
WITH WAS VACCINATED. I THINK
MOST EVERYBODY IN HERE PROBABLY
HAS AT THIS POINT. HAS AS WELL
MY CONCERN HERE HOWEVER IS. THE
TICKETS. IT CONTAINS. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A RECESS MEMBERS.
YOU TAKE A RECESS.
THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THE. I'M NOT CERTAIN
I REMEMBER EXACTLY WHERE
EVERYTHING WAS EXCEPT FOR THE-
I WAS MAKING SOME COMMENTS TO
THE AUTHOR THAT. PHYSICAL
OBSTRUCTION INTIMIDATION CAN
NEVER BE TOLERATED AND
ESPECIALLY IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS. MY CONCERN IS ON-
PICKETING. PICKETING- A LOT OF
US WITHIN HER PRECIADO
PICKETING IS PART OF OUR FIRST
AMENDMENT- PACKAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND I KNOW
THERE'S TIME. PLACE AND MANNER
RESTRICTIONS OFTEN RESERVED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL FOUR WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE. BUT PICKETING IS
NOT INTIMIDATION. IN PICKETING
IS NOT- PHYSICALLY OBSTRUCTIVE
IF IT'S DONE APPROPRIATELY SO I
GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN IS I WANT
TO SUPPORT THIS EXCEPT THAT
PICKETING COMPONENT I THINK
MIGHT CREATE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL AND LEGAL
CHALLENGES THAT MAY BE BEST
LEFT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHETHER
INDIVIDUALS GET A PERMIT. TO
HAVE AN EVENT IN FRONT OF A
FACILITY BUT I SUPPORT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL BUT THAT
JUST GIVES ME A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF PAUSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN C. NINE DOCTOR
CAN WE TALK TO CLOSE THANK YOU
I JUST POINT OUT THAT THIS-
ONLY ACQUIRES A BUFFER ZONE- I
THINK WE SUSPECT RIGHT NOW JUST
EXPERIENCED WHY WE NEED THE
SPELLER STRICTLY ASPEN I MET.
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON FILE I'M TWENTY SEVEN.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AND CAN I
LIVE BAIT. I BECKER. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI CORTEZ
HE HI DOLLY NO DODD HI THE
RISING HI A COMMON HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
I WAS SO. HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED. HI LLEVA
HI THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MIN FIVE NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
MY FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERN. HI
AMBERG HI KELSEY HI WINNER HI
WILKE. SENATOR BEN MOVED TO
CALL. MEMBERS NOW I'M GOING TO
RELINQUISH THE GAVEL TO SENATOR
LEVEL AND I WILL PRESENT FALL
I'M. TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR
BRADFORD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION SENATOR BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS A WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUSTICE ACT THIS
BILL SIMPLY PUT. VENTS AND
PROHIBITS MEMBERS FROM GETTING
THEIR WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS REDUCED SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF RACE GENDER OR GENETIC MAKE
UP ODDS IN RESPONSE TO A COURT
DECISION THAT REDUCED A
INDIVIDUALS- WORKERS COMP
COMPENSATION BENEFIT BY FORTY
NINE PERCENT. BASED ON A
GENETIC DISPOSITION THIS IS
UNFAIR IT'S BIASED IN ITS
APPLICATION THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE NECESSARY PROTECTION TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE TREATED
EQUALLY AND FAIRLY WHEN IT
COMES TO RECEIVING THEIR
BENEFITS. ARE WE PASSED A
SIMILAR BILL TWO YEARS AGO AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORDMEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. HI BASE HI BACKER
FIVE FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I
KERR BY OTHER. HI COURTESY HI
DALLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO BY
ADMIN FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG HI WITH SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES. CAMCORDER
I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A
VOGUE HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI AMBERG HI WHY CASKEY
HI WINNER HI WELL. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
SO THE SENATOR BRADFORD CAN
PRESENT A FEW OF HIS BILLS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FIVE AND FIFTY SEVEN. SENATE
BILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURES
PRESENTED BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE OUR STATE'S FELL ONLY
DETERMINATE SENTENCING PROCESS
OUR CURRENT LAW SPECIFIES THAT
IF A STATUTE SPECIFIES THREE
POSSIBLE SENTENCING TERMS FOR
FELONY OFFENSE LOW MIDDLE HIGH
WITH VARIATIONS. OF THE TIME TO
BE SERVED THE CHOICE. OF THE
APPROPRIATE TERM WHICH RESTS
WITH THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT EXISTING LAW SUNSETS IN
JANUARY FOR FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY. AND SO- THIS
MEASURE IS A GOOD REPLACEMENT
THAT MAKES THE SYNCING PROCESS
A LITTLE BIT MORE FAIR SP FIVE
SIX SEVEN CREATES A PRESUMPTION
OF SENTENCING JUDGMENT. NOT TO
EXCEED THE MIDDLE TERM UNLESS
THERE IS AGGRAVATED
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT JUSTIFIED
THE IMPOSITION OF A HIGHER
TERM- SP FIVE SIX SIX THREE
FIVE SIX SEVEN PROVIDES. THAT
WHEN A HIGHER RETURN IS IMPOSED
AFFECTS SUPPOSED SUPPORTING
THAT AGGREGATION- AGGRAVATION
I'M SORRY MUST BE STIPULATED BY
THE DEFENDANT OR SUBSTITUTED BY
THE JURY AND PROVEN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT OR FOUND BY
THE COURT IN THE BENCH TRIAL.
IN INSTANCES WHERE THERE ARE NO
JURIES INVOLVED. SP FIVE BY
FIVE SIX SEVEN ALLOWS THE
PARTIES TO DISPUTE THE FACTS IN
THE RECORD OR PRESENT
ADDITIONAL FACTS. OCT SP FIVE
SEVEN FIVE SIX SEVEN PERMITS
DEFENDANTS TO REQUEST
BIFURCATED HEARINGS OF TRIAL
CHARGES TO BE SEPARATED FROM
ENHANCEMENTS UNLESS THE FACTS
AT. AT ISSUE IS ALREADY AN
ELEMENT OF THE CHARGE A
CHARGEABLE OFFENSE- IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM WHILE IT IS APPROPRIATE
TO PUNISH PEOPLE FOR COMMITTING
CRIMES. WEHAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE- IMPACTED PEOPLE
PROPER DUE PROCESS THAT WAS
BUILT ON FAIRNESS AND FACTS.
AND BASED ON THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENT ABROAD FOR
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KENS FIVE BASE NO BECKER ON
FIVE FORTUS NO BRADFORD BYE BYE
UNDER EYE CORTESE FIVE DALLY.
NO DODD HI TORONTO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS
NO HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LABOUR I LIVE MY OWN.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S MAN BY
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A SHOW OF A-
NO PANTS HI FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
HI AMBERG HI MY CAR SEATS FIVE
WINNER HI WELK. SEN REMOVES THE
CALL NUMBER FOR ME TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE SENATOR BRADFORD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF THIS IS TRUE
FOR MEASURE WHICH WILL ADDRESS
THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST EXISTS
BETWEEN PROSECUTORS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO HAVE
COMMITTED MISCONDUCT THIS BILL
REQUIRED THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
HAS RECEIVED A MONETARY BENEFIT
FROM ASSOCIATION THAT SOLELY
REPRESENT LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
RECUSE HIMSELF FROM THE
INVESTIGATION CHARGING OR PUT
THE PROSECUTION OF OFFICER WHO
IS A MEMBER OF THAT ASSOCIATION
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES IF THAT ASSOCIATION
ALSO PROVIDES REPRESENTATION TO
THE OFFICER OF THE CRIMINAL
CASE. AFTER RECUSING THEMSELVES
THEIR TOURNEY GENERAL SHALL
ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE CASE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THEN THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR SHALL BE ASSIGNED TO
THE CASE. AMENDMENTS WERE MADE
AND SENATE APPROPRIATIONS TO
CLARIFY THAT THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST COULD EXIST BETWEEN
THE ABOUT THE TIME THAT TENDED
TO INDIVIDUAL FILES TO RUN FOR
OFFICE FOR DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
ATTORNEY GENERAL- TO THE
CONCLUSION OF THEIR TERM
PROSECUTORS ARE SOME OF THE
MOST POWERFUL ACTORS IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THEIR ROLE
IS UNIQUE. AND UNLIKE MOST
ELECTED OFFICIALS THEIR DUTY IS
FOR IS TO BE FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND NOT
SIMPLY MAKE POLICY CHOICES
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
US. AND THEM- THIS IS CLEAR
ETHICAL ISSUE AND OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL BENEFIT
GREATLY FROM ADDRESSING THIS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IS BUILT
DOES NOT PREVENT AN OFFICER
FROM RECEIVING A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL TRIAL OR PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNIONS FROM
DONATING TO CANDIDATES NOR DOES
IT FOR A BIT- DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS FROM ACCEPTING THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS. IT ONLY REQUIRES
THOSE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
RECUSE THEMSELVES FROM A
CRIMINAL CASE REMOVING ANY
OPPORTUNITY FOR BUYERS ARE
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AT CENTER MORICHES.
CLARIFICATION QUESTION TO THE-
AUTOGRAPH MAY TAKE A QUESTION
YES I WILL PLEASE PROCEED
FURTHER BORDERS. WE REFERRED TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE
REFERRING TO THE INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY ON A COUNTY
BASIS OR THE ASSISTANT DA'S
THAT COMPRISE THE PROSECUTORIAL
TEAM. THROUGH THE JOURNEY
SPECIFICALLY. OKAY SURE. I
GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT ONLY IN THE
SITUATION WHERE THE ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. HERE SHE IF
HE OR SHE WERE TO DECIDE TO
PROSECUTE THE CASE FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE STANDPOINT. IF
THEY GIVE THE GREEN LIGHT FOR
THEIR- PROSECUTION DIVISIONS
DIVISION HAS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE CASE. THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO GIVE THAT
INSTRUCTION THAT'S CORRECT IT'S
A COMPLEX DATA WOULD BE
ASSIGNED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD BE IN A VERY
SIMILAR SITUATION ESSENTIALLY-
NOT WISHING TO GET ANY
FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE THE ENTIRE STATE
SYSTEM PROSECUTORS ALSO-
DISQUALIFIED IS THAT CORRECT.
OKAY I HAVE A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR ASSIGNED TO JUST
GOES TO THE THIRD THING NOT YET
A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR. AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO BE
APPOINTED BY THE COURT. OR Y
A. B. AG OR THE T. EIGHT
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
EXACTLY. ARE THE DOES THAT TAKE
THE FORM OF ESSENTIALLY A-
PUBLIC DEFENDER- BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF THE SITUATION THEY
BECOME A PUBLIC PROSECUTOR. I
WOULD NECESSARY TO DESCRIBE IT
AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER BUT A-
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO BE
ASSIGNED TO I GUESS YOU WOULD
MERIT SOMEWHAT OF A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR BORJAS MEMBERS
FURTHER QUESTIONS. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENT ABROAD FOR
YOU MY CLOTHES ARE MEMBERS THIS
IS A STRAIGHT FORWARD- MEASURE
AS WE DISCUSSED IT OFF LAST
WEEK WHEN WE DEALT WITH S. P.
TWO WE KNOW THE PROSECUTION OF
POLICE OFFICERS OR SOMETHING
VERY EARLY THAT TAKES PLACE AND
THEIR ROGUE WRONGLY CHARGED FOR
THE MOST SERIOUS SICK- CASES
WE'VE FOUND OUT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE INVESTIGATORS
IN THE DA'S OFFICE ARE. FORMER
POLICE ALL CHANNELS HAVE AN
INCESTUOUS RELATIONSHIP BY
CONTRIBUTING TO THOSE THE ACE
THAT SOMETIME CONFLICT AMOUNT
SO WE ASKED FOR THEM TO REMOVE
THEMSELVES FROM THAT PROCESS SO
WE REMOVE ANY QUESTION OF DOUBT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU CENTER.
BRADFORD MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. I AT KINS. I BASE.
NO BACKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD
HI COULD ADAM HI CORTESE. I
DALLY NO DOG HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG HI WEST SO
HI HER TADO. JONES NO CAMCORDER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI LOU MOANS.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN NO
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN OCHO A BOAT
NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH NO RUBIO. SKINNER HI
STERN HI AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE
SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND I ACTUALLY
NEED TO TAXATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE SIR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY AND THE
GOVERNOR TAKE ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- CHALLENGES
THAT WERE CREATED BY THIS
PANDEMIC- THIS BILL BUILDS UPON
THE WORK. THAT WE HAVE DONE BY
INVESTING THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION- WITH THE GROWTH
OF SMALL BUSINESSES LOCATED IN
SPECIFICALLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IT'S REFERRED TO AS
A JUMPSTART ACT AND HOPES TO
CREATE A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP BY FINDING THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IN TAX CREDITS
FRED OVER FOUR YEAR. FIXED OVER
FOUR FISCAL YEARS THIS PROGRAM%
WILL BE OVERSEEN BY OURS
SECRETARY ARMY OUR STATE
TREASURER PHIL IN A MALL WHO IS
THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE-
ELIGIBLE INVESTMENT AREAS ARE
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN HIGHLY
IMPACTED BY WITH RATES OF
POVERTY UNEMPLOYMENT AND LOW
MEDIAN INCOME THIS BILL ALSO
FOCUS ON OUR REACH A MINORITY
WOMEN OWNED DISABLED VETERAN
OWNED. BUSINESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD MEMBERS. DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. CENTREBOARD JUST.
JUST LIKE TO SUPPORTERS OF THE
CENTER FOR MARTINEZ- SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI
BASE I BACKER HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD HI BYRON HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. FIVE DODD I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER FIVE
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH HI
HERZ BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER HI
LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE WOMEN
OWNED. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A TRIO
OF BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO
FIVE ROCK FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER
HI STERN HI NUMBER HI KELSEY
FIVE WINNER. HI WELL HI SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBER FOR MOVING THE
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR
BRADFORD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY
SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATED CRIMINAL FEES. SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I SP FIVE EIGHT SIX
ELIMINATES CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES- WE'VE
KNOWN. THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
WHAT IMPACT IT'S HAD ON PEOPLE
AND MUCH OF WHAT IS- HAPPENS IN
COURT THOSE COSTS ARE PASSED ON
TO MANY TIMES THE DEFENDANTS-
MANY OF THOSE FOLKS WHO CANNOT.
AFFORD THE COSTS SIMILAR TO
BAIL IT CREATES A DEBTORS
PRISON- THIS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS LOW INCOME FOLKS PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND 80% OF THEM
QUALIFY FOR INDIGENT AND INTENT
INDIGENT JET SERVICES. ARE FROM
OUR PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND WE
NEED TO GIVE PEOPLE A FAIR-
OPPORTUNITY AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES A CHANCE TO CLEAN I
HAVE A CLEAN START WITHOUT
TRAPPING HIM WELL WITH THAT. OF
THESE FEES ARE REGRESSIVE TAXES
THAT DO THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT IT
WAS INTENDED TO DO AND WE CAN.
DO THIS STILL WHILE HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE SP FIVE
EIGHT SIX WOULD ELIMINATE OR
MODIFY TWENTY SIX
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM- AND
THIS IS NOT NEW- LAST YEAR A.
B. EIGHT SIX NINE A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL ELIMINATED TWENTY
SIX PIECE OF FACTLY STARTING ON
JULY ONE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION. AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT I'M
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
BASE NO BECKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
COURTESY HI DALLY. NO DODD. HI
TERRAZZA HI ADNAN HI GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON.
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN. HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A SHOW OF
BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER.
HI STERN I AM BERG HI WHITE
HOUSE SKIING. HI WINNER HI WELL.
NO THEN REMOVE THE CALL WE'RE
GOING TO BE THE FINAL ITEM ONE
OH EIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD'S
LAST BILL MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE PARKS
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY OF
ARABS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
CYNDER BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I STAND BEFORE
YOU TODAY AS A PROUD AUTHOR OF
SB SEVEN NINE SIX. AND MY TEN
PLUS YEARS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A MORE IMPACTFUL
BILL. THAT I CAN BE INVOLVED
WITH- IN RECOGNIZING THE IMPACT
THAT THIS WILL HAVE. ON NOT
JUST ONE PARTICULAR AFRICAN
AMERICAN FAMILY. BUT IT'S GOING
TO SET AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT.
REPARATIONS SHOULD AND COULD
LOOK LIKE. NOT HERE NOT ONLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT- IN THE
NATION AS A WHOLE YESTERDAY WE
HAD OUR FIRST. REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE AND I'M HONORED TO SERVE
ON AND I THINK OUR PROTEIN FOR
POINTING ME. TO THIS TASK
FORCE. FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW.
AND TWO THOUSAND I MEAN I'M
SORRY IN NINETEEN TWELVE.
AFRICAN AMERICAN COUPLE BY THE
NAME OF CHARLES AND WILL OF
BRUCE. BOUGHT A PIECE OF LAND
IN MANHATTAN BEACH. THEY BOUGHT
IT WITH INTENTIONS OF LIVING
OUT THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
OWNING A BUSINESS BUT ALSO
ADHERING TO THOSE RULES THAT
EXISTED AT THAT TIME. SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL. THEY STARTED A
RESORT A BATHHOUSE A DANCEHALL
A RESTAURANT TO CATER TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN POPULATION AND
FROM THE DATE THAT BUSINESS WAS
ESTABLISHED. IT WAS SUCCESSFUL.
BUT THAT SUCCESS IN PUREDATA
MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEIR WHITE
NEIGHBORS AND THE BRUCE FAMILY
AS WELL AS THE OTHER SIX
FAMILIES TO ACQUIRE LAND ALONG
MANHATTAN BEACH WERE HARASSED
CONTINUOUSLY. NOT ONLY BY THE
KKK BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY
HAD THEIR TIRES SLASHED. THEY
HAD THEIR FACILITIES BURN THEIR
HOUSES SET AFIRE BUT DESPITE
ALL THIS. THE BRUISES AND THOSE
NEIGHBORS REMAIN CONSISTENT. IT
SHOULDN'T BE LOST ON A SET JUST
DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY WE
RECOGNIZED THE ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE TULSA
MASSACRE. AND MANY FOLKS AS
WELL WHAT IS THE SIMILARITY
BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENED TOLD THEM
WHAT HAPPENED IN MANHATTAN
BEACH THE DIFFERENCE IS NO ONE
LOST THEIR LIFE TO MAN AND
BEACH BUT THEY DID MURDER THE
DREAM OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILIES. WHO BELIEVE IN DOING
THE RIGHT THING AS I STATED
THEY PURCHASED THIS PROPERTY IN
NINETEEN TWELVE. FOR TWELVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
AND AGAIN THEY WERE HARASSED
CONSTANTLY AND IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR WHEN THE K. CLAN
COULD NOT FINALLY RIGHT AROUND
THE BRUCE IS OFF. AND THE OTHER
SIX CITIES S. R. SIX FAMILIES.
THE CITY OF MANHATTAN BEACH
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO USE.
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH EMINENT DOMAIN.
THE TAKE THEIR PROPERTY AND AS
WE'VE SEEN ALSO AND WHAT'S
CALLED THE BLACK WALL STREET IN
TULSA THEY USE EMINENT DOMAIN
AFTER BURNING DOWN THAT TOWN.
TO PREVENT THOSE COMMUNITIES
FROM REBUILDING. THEY TOOK THIS
PROPERTY IN TWO THOUSAND I MEAN
NINETEEN. TWENTY FOUR. AND
FINALLY REMOVE THEM FROM THEIR
PLAN IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
NEVER TO BUILD A PARK. THE
LANDS SET BACON UNTIL NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT AT THAT TIME IT WAS
TRANSFERRED. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEEDED THE LAND TO THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES.AND FROM THERE
THEY BUILT. A LIFEGUARD
TRAINING SESSION THE US STATION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY BEGINS THE
TRANSFER OF RETURNING THIS
PROPERTY TO THE RIGHTFUL OWNERS
AND I WANT TO THANK. THE
COURAGE OF SUPERVISOR JANICE
HAHN AND THE FOUR OTHER AMAZING
WOMEN ON LA COUNTY SUPERVISORS
THAT HAD TO. COURAGE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND HELP CORRECT
THIS HORRIBLE WRONG THAT
HAPPENED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN I INTRODUCED THIS BILL THE
PEOPLE OUT WAS IT UNIQUE AND AS
WE'VE SEEN THIS IS NOT UNIQUE
THERE'S HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF STORIES LIKE THIS
THIS IS JUST ONE WORD IT'S
STILL. THIS LAND OTHER THAN THE
LIFEGUARD STATION STILL SITS AS
IT WAS IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
WHEN THEY RAISE THE FACILITIES
FROM THEIR PROPERTY. THIS BILL
WILL NOT PROVIDE JUSTICE. BUT
IT IS A SMALL MEASURE TO RETURN
AND RECOGNIZE THE WRONG THAT
THIS FAMILY WE ELIMINATED
GENERATIONAL WEALTH. FROM THIS
FAMILY AND THE SURROUNDING
FOLKS WHO LIVED ON THIS LAND.
THIS BILL IS A MODEL WHAT
ECONOMIC JUSTICE SHOULD LOOK
LIKE IN THIS COUNTRY THIS BILL
WILL NOT A RACE AS I STATED
BOTH HORRIBLE ACTS BUT IT
REPRESENTS A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE AND A CLEAR STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. YES SANDERS CAN-
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND IT'S A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ACT AND I WONDER HOW
MANY MORE WE KNOW. THAT THERE
WERE MANY MORE INCIDENCES
PERHAPS NOT AS- AS OBVIOUS AS
BRUCE'S BEACH BUT WE KNOW THERE
WERE MANY OTHER INCIDENCES
WHERE. AFRICAN AMERICANS. MRS
WERE TAKEN OR THEY WERE DRIVEN
OUT. AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE WE WILL NEVER KNOW THE
EXTENT OF GENERATIONAL WEALTH
THAT MAY HAVE RESULTED FROM THE
LONG TERM OPERATION OF BRIDGET
BRUCE'S SPEECH NOT ONLY FOR THE
BRUCE FAMILY BUT FOR ALL THEIR
EMPLOYEES ALL OF WHOM OF COURSE
NO LONGER HAD JOBS ONCE
MANHATTAN BEACH. TOOK THE
PROPERTY. AND WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT. D. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE WEALTH OF AN
AVERAGE AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
OUR COUNTRY AND THE WEALTH OF
AN AVERAGE WHITE PERSON. YOU
KNOW WHY DO MANY OF US HAVE
THAT WEALTH AND I'M TALKING NOW
ABOUT MYSELF AS A WHITE PERSON
WE HAPPENED BECAUSE OUR
FAMILIES WERE ABLE TO RETAIN
THEIR BUSINESSES RETAIN THEIR
PROPERTIES OWNED THEIR HOMES.
AND THOSE THINGS INCREASED IN
VALUE AND FOR ME FOR EXAMPLE I
WAS ABLE TO PUT MY DAUGHTER
THROUGH COLLEGE PART REFINE MY
HOUSE. IF I HAD BEEN UNABLE TO
OWN A HOUSE AND WE KNOW THAT
KEEPS YOU KNOW NOT THATMANY
YEARS AGO WITH COVENANTS AND
REDLINING AND OTHER PRACTICES.
A BLACK FAMILY COULDN'T OWN THE
HOUSE THEN OF COURSE THAT
COMPLETELY IMPACTED THEIR
GENERATIONAL WEALTH I WAS
STRUCK WELL I HAD KNOWN ABOUT
THE TULSA MASSACRE. I WAS
STRUCK IN THE REAR WITH
RECENTLY WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MEDIA ATTENTION THE SIXTY
MINUTES- SPECIAL ON IT AND THEN
MY OWN CONGRESSWOMAN BARBARA
LEE GOING AND TALKING ABOUT.
THE JUST HORRIFIC EVENTS THERE
AND HOW IT WAS COMPLETELY
BURIED FROM THE PUBLIC AND THAT
EVEN BLACK RESIDENTS OF TULSA
DID NOT KNOW THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
HAPPENED NOW BACK TO BRUCE'S
BEACH. THIS IS ONE. ALL TO
CORRECT A WRONG IN CALIFORNIA
WE I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
MANY MORE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GUARDIAN TO BRING IT FORWARD TO
US. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED
TO BRIEFLY SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- MY BROTHER ACTUALLY
HAPPENS TO LIVE IN MANHATTAN
BEACH INSTANT AND ACTUALLY SAID
THAT IF THIS DID NOT MOVE
FORWARD HE WOULD BE MOVING OUT
BECAUSE HE DOES. CERTAINLY
BELIEVE IN AND ENSURING THAT-
ARE. THAT OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE- THIS
SORT OF CORRECTION TO WHAT WAS
AN EGREGIOUS AN AWFUL- THE
ISSUE THAT HAD HAPPENED TO THEM
AND SO I. WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT AND I HOPE
THAT. AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS A
STATE IN LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL- REPARATIONS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THAT
WE CAN FIND. OPPORTUNITIES TO
CORRECT THE WRONGS FROM THE
PAST AND SO FOR THAT I URGE AND
I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ CENTERMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I HAD A QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR THAT'S
AFFIRMATIVE. CENTER BREVARD WE
TAKE A QUESTION FROM SENATOR
MAN THROUGH PLEASE PROCEED
SENATOR MAN SO I'M READING THE
BILL DESCRIPTION AND IT SAYS
THAT THE BILLS PERMISSIVE. BUT
THAT THERE IS AN EXPECTATION
THAT THE- BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AVENGERS COUNTY WILL TRANSFER
THE LAND. IS IT MAYBE YOU CAN
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT FOR ME IS
IT PERMISSIVE. IT IS A MATTER
OF LOCAL CONTROL OR WE
DICTATING RESULTS TO LA COUNTY.
THE LAND WILL BE TRANSFERRED
BACK TO THE BRUCE FAMILY THERE
ANTHONY BRUCE- THROUGH THE
ACTIONS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN BY
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES'S
MANAGER- HERE TODAY REMOVES
THOSE RESTRICTIONS THAT WE
PLACE ON THE PROPERTY BACK IN
NINETEEN. NINETY FIVE WHEN WE
NEEDED IT TO THE COUNTER. AND
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR FOR MY OWN
EDIFICATION THAT MEANS THAT THE
COUNTY'S ULTIMATELY MAKING
DECISION NOT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. WE'RE THOSE
RESTRICTIONS SO THE COUNTY CAN
DO WHAT THEY DEEM IS RIGHT IN
RETURN PROBABLY TO THE BRUCE
FAMILY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND THEN I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT.
PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR BEACHES
AND COASTLINES AND I ASSUME
THAT THERE ARE GOING TO BE
MEASURES TAKEN BY THE LA.
COUNTY TO ENSURE THAT- THE
TRANSFER OF THIS WHOLE- NOT
DIMINISH PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO
ACCESS THE BEACH. I WOULD HOPE
NO MORE THAN THEY DIMINISH THE
BRUCE'S FAMILY FROM ACCESSING
THEBEACH FRONT PROPERTY THAT
THEY OWN FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS
SO- I THINK- WE CAN FIGURE THIS
OUT. I APPRECIATE THAT- AND I
WOULD JUST SAY AS WE HEAD
TOWARDS JUNETEENTH. I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES IN
GARDENA BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND- LOOKING TO RECTIFY
THE WRONGS OF THE PAST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT. AND I WANT TO JUST SAY
PROPERTY AND IT'S BEEN
GENERATIONAL IN OUR FAMILY AND
MY FAMILY MANY OF YOU KNOW
HOMESTEADED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND EMINENT DOMAIN IS SOMETHING
THAT IS- USED AS A TOOL FOR THE
GOOD OF THE PUBLIC THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE BUILD ROADS
AND SCHOOLS. THINGS THAT ARE
GOOD FOR ALL THE PUBLIC. IN
THIS CASE IT WASN'T GOOD FOR
ALL THE PUBLIC IT WAS GOOD FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. MUNA GENDER.
AND THAT'S WRONG THAT'S NOT A
PUBLIC THAT'S NOT WHAT EMINENT
DOMAIN WAS SET FOR. AND I WANT
TO SHARE THAT YOU KNOW. THIS
COUNTRY IS IN A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE NOT RIGHT. AND IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO. FIX THOSE
WRONGS BECAUSE A LOT OF THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED IN THE COURSE OF
HISTORY THAT DON'T REALLY
ALWAYS ALLOW US THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. IN THIS
CASE. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WRONG RIGHT
WHERE SOMEBODY'S LAYING. WHICH
I GUARANTEE YOU AND IT DIDN'T
BEING A PERSON OF COLOR OWNING
LAND AND NAP TIME. IT'S NOT
LIKE IT IS TODAY. SO FOR ME
PERSONALLY AS A LANDOWNER AND
SOMEBODY WHO. RESPECTS ATLANTA
AND KNOWS WHAT IT IS TO TEND TO
IT AND RUN A BUSINESS AND HOW
DIFFICULT THAT IS. THIS IS A
SUPER GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO GIVE BACK TO LOCAL CONTROL
WHICH THE STATE THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING BUT GIVE THE CONTROL
BACK TO. THE LOCALS TO MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE HEARD THE HISTORY. ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON
THIS PIECE OF LAND. AND WHAT
HAPPENED TO THOSE FOLKS SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I WILL SHARE THAT
MAYBE IT MIGHT NOT BE THAT IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE- THIS IS A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHAT WE CAN DO.
SOMETHING THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT SO I ENCOURAGE MY VOTE ON
SB SEVEN NINETY SIX AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE AND I
THOUGHT TO BE WORTH JUST
CLARIFYING FOR THE MEMBERS.
VOTING ON THIS THAT. THE
LOCATION ALSO THIS PROPERTY IS
NOT DIRECTLY ON THE BEACH THE
STRAND RUNS ALONG MANHATTAN
BEACH THERE- BUT- PUBLIC
ACCESS. IS ALREADY MAINTAINS-
THE ISSUE IS THAT. WE'VE GOT AN-
CAN INGEST IS EMBEDDED IN OUR
LAW HERE AN S. AND THEIR THEFT
OF PROPERTY THAT DATES BACK.
DECADES THAT NEEDS TO BE
RECTIFIED MY ONLY CONCERN IS
WITH. AT THE CITY COUNCIL LEVEL
IS MANHATTAN BEACH IMPOSES
UNDUE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
BREEZE FAMILIES RESUMPTION OF
THEIR PRIVATE PROPERTY
INTERESTS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ISSUES. AND SO I'M HOPING WITH
THE PASSAGES OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND ALL YOUR VOICES
HERE THAT WE HAVE A EXPEDITED
PROCESS FOR GETTING THIS WORK
DONE. BUT THAT WE DON'T JUST
STOP WITH THIS WORK THE FREEDOM
SURF CAMP IS LITERALLY A BLOCK
AWAY FROM THIS SITE. AND RIGHT
NOW THEY SERVE KIDS IN
MANHATTAN BEACH BUT NOT A FEW
MILES INLAND- AND RIGHT NOW THE
LA COUNTY LIFEGUARDS ARE GOING
THROUGH JUNIOR GUARD AND FOUR
THOUSAND KIDS ACROSS LA YOU'RE-
GOING TO BE COME JUNIOR GUARDS.
THOSE ARE MOSTLY WHITE KIDS. AT
THE CULTURE AROUND THE BEACH
ITSELF AND SHARING THESE
RESOURCES HAS TO CHANGE AND- I
HOPE THAT- THE CENTER FROM
GUARDIAN IS LEGISLATION IS.
JUST A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION-
MUCH BROADER COMMITMENT- THIS
IS FOR EVERYBODY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
STARRING MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
ALAN. I JUST WANNA RASO ADD MY
VOICE IN SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND OBVIOUSLY IT INTO CLIFF I
LOVE IT FOR MY OUR FRIEND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY- MOVING FORWARD
AS YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY THE- THE
STRUCTURES OF THE COASTAL ACT
IN THE COASTAL COMMISSION. HAD
THEIR WORK WHILST WILL
CERTAINLY NOT BE NOT BE
INFRINGED UPON- I ALSO I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT THIS BILL ALSO
POINTS OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COURAGEOUS INCISIVE. JOURNALISM
AND THE LOS ANGELES TIMES AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER- I'VE YOU KNOW
I'VE JOURNALISTS AND NEWSPAPERS
AND JOURNALISTIC OUTLETS THAT.
ARE MORE ABLE TO AMPLIFY THIS
IMPORTANT STORY RESEARCH IT.
AND COME UP WITH A VERY
COMPELLING NARRATIVE TO HELP.
ILLUSTRATING AND SHED LIGHT ON
SOME OF THE INCREDIBLE
INJUSTICES THE PASS IT'S NOT
THAT THIS WAS NOT A STORY THAT
WASN'T KNOWN. BY FOLKS BUT JUST
LIKE WITH THE TULSA MASSACRE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT. PEOPLE KNEW
ABOUT AND YET. IT REALLY WASN'T
SOMETHING I GOTTEN PICKED UP-
YOU KNOW BYE BYE AND MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND BY JOURNALISTS IN OUR
TEXTBOOKS. THIS IS A SIMILAR
SITUATION WE'VE GOT- SOME SOME
REPORTERS WHO REALLY STEPPED UP
AND PRODUCED SOME INCREDIBLE. I
RESEARCH AND I JUST I RECOMMEND
THAT EVERYONE WANTS TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THIS ISSUE. TO GO
READ THE LA TIMES ARTICLES
ABOUT THIS AD ABOUT THE STORY.
AND IT'S A DISTRESSING STORY
IT'S A STORY- THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS ALL TOO COMMON
IN AMERICAN HISTORY. AND IT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
RECTIFY THIS BILL BY
AUTHORIZING THE COUNTY. TO TO
TRANSFER THIS LAND SO THAT I
RESPECT FAST RIVAL. THE CENTRE
ALAN. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING.
SENT ABROAD FOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE THE LINK TO YOUR VOICE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY YOUR SUPPORT
TO THIS IMPORTANT. MEASURE I
COULD BE HERE ALL DAY SPEAKING
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT BUT I THINK. OUR
ACTIONS HERE TODAY WILL SEND A
MESSAGE CLEAR ACROSS THE STATE
CLEAR ACROSS THIS NATION. THAT
WE CAN RIGHT A WRONG. TELL ME
YOUR RACE HISTORY NO. BUT I
THINK IT SPEAKS VOLUMES ON WHY
ETHNIC STUDIES IS SOLD
IMPORTANT. IT SPEAKS TO WHY WE
NEED TO TELL THE TRUTH OF
AMERICAN HISTORY IN QUICK
WHITEWASHING IT. IT'S A AFRICAN
PROVERB THAT EXISTED STATES
UNTIL THE HIGH. AS TOLD BY THE
LION. THE STORY WILL ALWAYS
FAVOR THE HUNTER. AND THAT'S
WHAT AMERICAN HISTORY HAS BEEN
ABOUT. AND AFTER AN AMERICAN'S
MEXICAN AMERICANS AND NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED HERE
ASIAN AMERICANS WHO HAVE TOILED
THE FIELDS WORKED HERE MANY
TIMES OUR STORES ARE UNTIL.
THEY WERE PREVENTED FROM OWNING
PROPERTY THEY WERE PREVENTED
FROM LIVING IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBOURHOODS AND WHEN THEY
DID. ACQUIRE PROPERTY AND TRY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AGAIN OUR
GOVERNMENT FOUND THE WAY MANY
TIMES TO TAKE THAT PRIVILEGE
AWAY. THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THAT
IF YOU CAN INHERIT GENERATIONAL
WEALTH. YOU CAN INHERIT
GENERATIONAL DEBT THE CITY OF
MANHATTAN BEACH. OWES A DEBT TO
THE BRUCE FAMILY. THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES ALL THE DEBT TO THE
BRUCE FAMILY. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL THAT DEBT AS
WELL TO THE BRUCE FAMILY AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
SUPERVISOR JANICE HAHN
SUPERVISOR HOLLY MITCHELL.
SUPERVISOR HILDA SOLUTION
SUPERVISOR BARBER. AND
SUPERVISOR- JACKIE GOLDBERG FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FIVE AMAZING WOMEN
WHO SAID WE HAVE TO CORRECT
THIS AGAIN THE BRUCE'S ACQUIRED
THIS PROPERTY IN NINETEEN
TWELVE FOR. ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED. OUR JOBS ARE SHE'LL
KILL I'M SORRY SHEILA KO. I
STAND CORRECTED SUPERVISORS TO
LOOK THROUGH THE KILL. FOR UP
TO TWELVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TODAY THE PROPERTY
IS ESTIMATED AT A VALUE OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. THE BRUCE
FAMILY AGAIN WITH ROB THAT
THEIR LAND THEY WERE ROBBED OF
THEIR BUSINESS THEY WERE MOBBED
UP THEIR ECONOMIC FREEDOM. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY WERE
ROBBED A GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
THEY WERE FORCED TO MOVE OFF
THIS LAND AND GO TO WORK FOR
OTHER FOLKS. THEY SPENT THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE. BEING IN
EMPLOYMENT OF OTHER PEOPLE
VERSUS BEING EMPLOYMENT FOR
THEMSELVES. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK AVAN WARD AN AMAZING
RESIDENT AND MAN AND BEACH WHO
LETTHE STORY BE TOLD. AS A
PERSON WHO GREW UP IN THE SOUTH
BAY WE HAD HEARD ABOUT. BRUCE'S
BEACH BUT NOT TO THAT DEGREE.
AS A KID GROWING UP AND RIDING
MY BIKE TO THE BEACH TO PLAY IN
THE WATER AND TRY TO LEARN HOW
TO SURF. WE'RE HEARD RUMORS
ABOUT. NOT ONLY MEN AND BEACH
BUT THE INK WELL IN SANTA
MONICA. AND VAL VERDE UP THE
FIVE FREEWAY WHERE THESE WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN RESORTS THAT
ONCE EXISTED BUT NO LONGER DO
IT TODAY. BUT I ALSO WANNA GIVE
A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE
FORMER MAYOR MITCH WARD THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN AND ONLY
AFTER AMERICAN TO BE ELECTED TO
THAT CITY. WHO HAD THE COURAGE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. THEY ASKED
HIS COUNSEL OR HIS COUNSEL TO
TAKE A STANCE ON RECOGNIZING.
THE BRUCE FAMILY. I WILL CLOSE
ON THIS. I SAW A YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN YOUNG LADY STANDING ON
A CORNER LAST FRIDAY AND SHE
HAD A T. SHIRT ON THE SIMPLY
STATED THE STOLEN MORE THAN WAS
EVER LOOTED. AND THAT'S THE
STORY OF AMERICA AMERICA'S
STOLEN MORE FROM. FAMILIES OF
COLOR. THAN WE HAVE EVER TAKEN.
AND ON THAT NOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVACY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS. I BASE HI BRECHER HI
FORTUS FIVE BRADFORD. I COULD
BUY A HI CORTESE HI DALLY I
DONT HI TORONTO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES I
GROWTH FIVE HERZ BERG. I WISH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES HI CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. FIVE LLEVA HI
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. A
SHOW OF BOTH MY HANDS HI
FORCING TINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI AMBERG
HI WHAT KASKY FIVE WINNER I
WILL HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS NOW WILL GO
BACK TO OUR GENDER WERE NOW
MOVING TO FALL ITEM THIRTY TWO
SENATOR ON BURGER YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT MEASURE. HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR TWENTY BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
SENATOR UMBERG FAMOUS PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR TWENTY DEALS
WITH UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FRAUDS COULD BUILD OUT I. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. HEARING SEEING NONE
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
FIVE BASED. BACKER HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY HI TODD HI
DERISIVE HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WHERE SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED LISA HI WE MOAN.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN A SHOW A BOKE
I PAN FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE
STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER HI WELL I. YOUR
NUMBER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT. FILE I'M THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR SCANNER.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU PREPARED
SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO PEACE OFFICERS. SINNERS
CANADA FOR JURORS THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. S.
B. SIXTEEN IS A REINTRODUCTION
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
WITH BIPARTISAN VOTE BUT- DUE
TO THAT LAST DAY OF SESSION IN
THE TIME DEADLINE WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO VOTE FOR IT ON OUR
FLOOR. S. B. SIXTEEN IS A
MODEST EXPANSION TO MY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BILL SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH GAVE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN FORTY YEARS
PUBLIC ACCESS TO A LIMITED SET
OF POLICE RECORDS WHAT IS B.
SIXTEEN DOES IT EXPANDS ACCESS
TO RECORDS WHEN OFFICERS WHO
ENGAGE IN RACIST OR BIASED
BEHAVIOR USED EXCESSIVE FORCE
OR HAVE A HISTORY OF UNLAWFUL
ARRESTS AND SEARCHES. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT OFFICERS WITH THE
HISTORY OF MISCONDUCT CANNOT
QUIT THEIR JOBS KEEP RECORDS
SECRET AND MOVE TO ANOTHER
JURISDICTION WITH THE PAST
ACTIONS NOT DISCLOSED SO WHAT
IS THE NET RESULT OF THAT IT IS
GIVING SUNSHINE TO OUR POLICE.
AGENCIES ALLOWINGOUR
COMMUNITIES TO HOLD OFFICERS
AND AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE AND
RESTORING TRUST. AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NINE MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I. AT. HI BASED.
BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD.
FIVE ZERO FIVE COURTESY. DALLY
DODD. FIVE TORONTO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES. GROSS.
HER HI WEST SO- FIVE HER TADO.
JONES CAN LONGER HI LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. OCHO VOGUE I PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
AMBERG HI FI CASKEY. HI WINNER
I WILL. SINNERS SKINNER MY THE
CALL. NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
FOLLOW ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATOR
PAN HE'S PREPARED MADAM SIR
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
SEVENTEEN BISA PAT AND ACT
RELATING TO STATE GOVERNMENT
SENATOR PENN FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU- AS PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS SIGNED PLEASE PRESENT
SP SEVENTEEN WHICH ESTABLISHES
AN OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY AND
RACIAL EQUITY ADVISORY
ACCOUNTABILITY COUNCIL NOR TO
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM THERE'S
SALTED IN POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
DISPARITIES IN THE STATE. WE
SENT THE RESEARCHERS IDENTIFIED
BASED. ON THE RACISM AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO SING
HEALTH TO SPARE. CLEAN IF IN MY
BUT MORE CHRONIC DISEASE
PREVALENCE BUT EXPECTED AND
CORP MOTEL- SB SEVEN. IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD RANGE OF
SIZE- OF SUPPORTERS IT'S-
PLEASE OUR BUDGET COMMITTEES
INCLUDE SOME FUNDING IN OUR
CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT OF
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REACH FINAL
AGREEMENT I RESPECT THE ASPIRIN
I PUT. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SCENE NO ONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD MICROBIOTA
HI CORTESE HI DALLY. NO DODD BY
TERRORISM HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI- TIDO HI
JONES NO CAN LONGER. HI LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. MCGUIRE
BYE MELINDA'S MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW VOGUE. NO PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG ALL RIGHT FIVE BY CASSIDY
I WINNER HI WELL. THEN REMOVE
THE CALL MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FORTY
FIVE A SENATOR WIENER SOONER
WINNERS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO M. ANIMAL TESTING. CENTER
WINNER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY
TWO- WHICH WILL BAN THE
UNNECESSARY USE OF DOGS AND
CATS AND TOXICITY TESTS.
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA WITH SOME
EXEMPTIONS TOXICITY TESTING
INCLUDES FOR EXAMPLE FORCE
FEEDING OR INJECTING ANIMALS
WITH HARMFUL CHEMICALS.
PESTICIDE OR OTHERWISE- TO SEE
HOW SICK ANIMAL GUTS AND
WHETHER THE ANIMAL- DICE SOME
OF THESE TESTS INVOLVED
OVERDOSING DOGS AND
ADMINISTERING CHEMICALS OVER A
PROLONGED PERIOD OF TIME
CAUSING HORRIFIC PAIN FOR
EXAMPLE- SHOVING PESTICIDE DOWN
THE DOG'S THROAT EVERY DAY FOR
A YEAR. TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE DOG. DOGS AND CATS. SUFFER
GREATLY FROM THIS TYPE OF
TESTING WHICH WE NOW KNOW IS
LARGELY INEFFECTIVE AND NOT
SUPPORTED BY CURRENT SCIENCE
AND YET IT IS STILL HAPPEING.
WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT A
BILL THAT BANS ALL ANIMAL
TESTING IT DOES NOT PREVENT THE
SALE OR MANUFACTURE OF DRUGS.
DOES NOT STOP ANY CUTTING EDGE
RESEARCH A REVOLUTIONARY DRUG
DISCOVERY THIS BILL IS WRITTEN
SPECIFICALLY TO PROHIBIT TYPE
SINCE CITY TESTING. CARRIED OUT
ON DOGS AND CATS THAT SERVES NO
REGULATORY REQUIREMENT OR EVEN
A REGULATORY RECOMMENDATION IN
FACT WE HAVE- PROVISION AND
THAT IF THE FDA RECOMMENDS
TOXICITY DOG TOXICITY TESTING
FOR DRUGS- THE COMPANY CAN DO
IT. SO THE BILLS FLEXIBLE IT'S
SCIENCE BASED AND IT DESERVES
YOUR SUPPORT- WE HAVE HAD
NUMEROUS PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH- SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS- WHO'VE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL WE'VE
ACCEPTED VARIOUS AMENDMENTS IS
A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS. BUT IN
THE END COLLEAGUES- WE SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWING- THESE HORRIFIC
TOXICITY TESTS WHICH ARE. JUST
NOT SUPPORTED BY SCIENCE WE
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWING THEM ON
DOGS AND CATS. AND I RESPECT
WAREHOUSE FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR COM LONGER. RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO FIVE TWO
I WANT TO SAY IN TWENTY TWENTY
BEFORE THE SESSION WAS IMPACTED
BY KOBE I INTRODUCED THE
PREDECESSOR TO THIS BILL AB
TWENTY FIFTY NINE IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHERE IT WAS
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED IN ITS
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE. S. B.
TWO FIVE TWO IT'S A MORE
DEVELOPED VERSION OF LAST
YEAR'S LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
REFLECTS ALL OF THE WORK. THE
SPONSORS HAVE DONE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION.
AND TO REFINE THE BILL'S
NUMEROUS EXEMPTIONS. AND ALSO I
WANT TO POINT OUT IT BANS THE
USE OF TESTING ON DGS AND CATS
AND WHEN I BROUGHT THIS UP TO
MY CAT KISI GIRL SHE WAS VERY
EXCITED. I WAS COMPELLED TO
INTRODUCE THIS LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR WHEN I LEARNED THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TOXICITY TESTING
ON DOGS. WAS STILL HAPPENING IN
LABORATORIES INCLUDING SEVERAL
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I HOPE THAT
I AM NOT ALONE IN BEING ALARMED
BY THIS FACT. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER WAYS THAT WE
CAN CONDUCT THIS KIND OF
TESTING ON OTHER ANIMALS IF YOU
CHOOSE WHO ARE YOU KNOW LIKE
MICE AND ALL OF THAT AND ALSO
ON COMPUTER GENERATED
COMPARABLE IS THAT GIVE YOU THE
SAME KIND OF RESULTS. THE
EFFICACY WITH THOSE KINDS OF
TESTS IS AS HIGH AS TESTING ON
DOGS AND CATS SO WHY KILL THEM.
JUST FOR TEST I AM ENCOURAGING
MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE HI ONE S.
B. TWO FIVE TWO. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SAINT JOHN
CENTER WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. BUT RESPECT WESTERN IOWA
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. I AT KINS I BASE.
BECKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM. CORTESE HI DALLY.
DODD. DERISIVE BYE EGGMAN HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE WAYS SO. HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI LYNN MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN. NIELSEN BUT SHOW BOTH.
PAM HI WATSON TINA HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE KASKY. HI WINNER HI
WELK HI. SENATOR WIENER MOVES A
CALL NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
THE FALL ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR LEYVA SHE IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING
TO VICTIM COMPENSATION AND
MAKING IT A PERFECT PREPARATION
THEREFORE. CENTER LEVEL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO NINE
NINE REMOVES BARRIERS FACED BY
VICTIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE AND
OTHER VIOLENT CRIMES AND
GETTING HELP FROM THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD. PROGRAM CURRENTLY THE
BOARD KELBY C. B. CANNOT
APPROVE AN APPLICATION FOR
ASSISTANCE WITHOUT A POLICE
REPORT WHICH OFTEN IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN CASES OF POLICE
VIOLENCE. TELL B. C. B. CAN
ALREADY USE OTHER EVIDENCE TO
ESTABLISH THAT A CRIME OCCURRED
FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT OTHER VICTIMS
SUCH AS THOSE WHO WERE INJURED
RESULTING FROM POLICE VIOLENCE
ARE NOT AFFORDED THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY. IN ADDITION CALVIN
C. B. CAN DENY APPLICATIONS IF
IT DETERMINES THAT THE VICTIM'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE EVENT GAVE
RISE TO THE APPLICATION THAT
SURVIVORS MAY BE DENIED FOR NON
COOPERATION WITH POLICE. GIVING
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT TO THE
OPINION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEMBERS SP TWO NINE NINE WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO VITAL
RESOURCES FOR VICTIMS OF POLICE
VIOLENCE AS THEY RECOVER FROM
THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
INJURIES CAUSED. DUE TO THE
ACTIONS OF POLICE OR IN THE
CASES OF PEOPLE KILLED BY
POLICE TO BE ABLE TO BURY THEIR
LOVED ONES WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE A
COUPLE CLARIFICATIONS RECENT
AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED THE SP TWO
NINE NINE EXCLUDES PEOPLE AND
FAMILY MEMBERS IF THE PERSON
INJURED OR KILLED FIVE. BECAUSE
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY OR DEATH
TO ANOTHER PERSON IN THOSE
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES POLICE
ARE OF COURSE ALLOWED TO USE
DEADLY FORCE UNDER AB. THREE
NINETY TWO. PERSON WHO IS IN
HER. OR IS ON PROBATION OR
PAROLE FOR SERIOUS OFFENSE
CANNOT RECEIVE ASSISTANCE FROM
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
PROGRAM. THE CURRENT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR FILING A CLAIM
WITH THE B. C. B. S. SEVEN
YEARS CONTENT THIS BILL IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT IF ENACTED
WILL MAKE AN IMPORTANT IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF VICTIMS OF
POLICE VIOLENCE. AFTER ALL IT
IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
VICTIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE FAR
AS DESERVING. AND AS MUCH A
VICTIM AS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. MEMBERS
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS NOT A POT OF MONEY. FOR
PEOPLE TO WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED
BY POLICE VIOLENCE TO GET THIS
IS A REIMBURSEMENT FUND AND IT
IS THE PAYER OF LAST RESORT. SO
THIS IS FOR BASICALLY THREE
THINGS IF I AM HARMED BY POLICE
I CAN RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MY HOSPITAL BILLS I CAN SEE
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
COUNSELING I MAY HAVE HAD. I
CAN SEE MY FAMILY CAN RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR FUNERAL COSTS
IF I WERE KILLED BY POLICE THIS
IS NOT A POT OF MONEY AND KILL
THE C. B. STILL HAS TO APPROVE
THIS. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'LL VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR WORLD. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. YOUR LIVER WILL YOU
TAKE A QUESTION FROM WELL OF
COURSE THANK YOU MAN AND
MEDICINE- I JUST- I APPRECIATE
YOUR INTENT AND WHERE YOU'RE
GOING ON THIS BUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION- AND I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TOOK TO
NARROW THE BILL SIGNIFICANTLY.
I HAVE A QUESTION- DOES THIS
ACTUALLY EXPAND- RESTITUTION TO
INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE INITIATED
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OR WERE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. DURING AN ARREST
WHERE SOMETHING HAPPENS TIME
WILL TELL HOWEVER THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AT THE TIME
KNOW IF YOU WERE COMMITTING A
CRIME DURING THE TIME. THIS IS
NOT APPLY TO YOU DOES NOT APPLY
TO YOUR FAMILY. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT ON MY OWN TIME.
YOU KNOW IN RETURN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THE REASON WHY I
BRING THAT UP IS JUST RECENTLY
MY COLLEAGUE- THAT I SURE
SAMBAR TO DINO COUNTY FOR WE
HAVE A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THAT WAS SHOT AND KILLED AND HE
WAS ACTUALLY- IN PURSUIT OF A
MOTORCYCLE INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
SAM VIOLATING THE LAW. AND THE
MOTORCYCLE INDIVIDUAL DROPPED
HIS BIKE TOOK OFF RUNNING OVER
A SAND DUNE. AND WHEN THE
OFFICER AND WHEN THE OFFICERS
LAID CHASE HE WENT OVER THE TOP
OF A SAND DUNE IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS LAYING IN WAIT
AND SHOT IT. AND SO HIS END OF
WATCH WAS JUST THE DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY. SO MY CONCERN IS-
JUST SHARING THAT STORY OF JUST
EVERY DAY A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER THE PUTS ON THEIR
UNIFORM HAS NO IDEA WHAT THEIR
DAY IS GOING TO ENTAIL. AND I
THINK I APPLAUD THE OTHER FOR
MAKING SURE THAT. INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN THE- IN THE- IN THE-
OF- IN THE- IN THE PROCESS OF.
COMMITTING A CRIME. AND THE
OFFICER ENGAGES THAT PERSON-
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL IF
SOMETHING DID HAPPEN THAT WAS
UNFORESEEN. FOR WHATEVER REASON
THAT THE OFFICER WOULD NOT BE.
A THERE WOULD NOT BE
RESTITUTION AND AVAILABLE TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF COMMITTING. A
CRIME. AND SO I DIDN'T SEE
THOSE AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL
AND I JUST WANTED TO ASK THAT
OF THE AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE
THE RESPONSE. THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DRESS FITTING YOUR
CLOTHES YEAH. OKAY ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS ON THIS MEASURE.
TURNING TO A NINE CENT EARLIER
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT IT IS NOT AN
AMENDMENT- THAT YOU WOULD SEE
IT IN IT IS PART OF THE BILL
THAT IF YOU ARE ACTIVELY.
SHOOTING SOMEONE OR INJURING
SOMEONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
YOURSELF WOULD NOT BE ENTITLED
TO ANY COMPENSATION NOR WOULD
YOUR FAMILY SO UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCE OR THE- THE-
EXAMPLE THAT MY COLLEAGUE GAVE
OF COURSE THAT PERSON WOULD NOT
BE ENTITLED TO ANYTHING FROM
THE VICTIM'S COMPENSATION PORT.
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE VERY CLEAR WE DON'T
CONVOLUTED THE ISSUE. CLEARLY
WE DON'T EVER WANT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE SHOT AT OR
KILLED AS WHAT HAPPENED BUT WE
ALSO DON'T WANT VICTIMS OF
POLICE VIOLENCE DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS BOARD SO MEMBERS
IT IS A FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE IT WOULD ALLOW FOR
MEMBER FOR VICTIMS OF POLICE
VIOLENCE TO BE REIMBURSED AGAIN
IT IS NOT A POT OF MONEY. IF
THERE WERE ANY CIVIL ACTION AND
THAT VICTIM RECEIVE SOME SORT
OF COMPENSATION THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE TO PAY BACK THE
ACCOUNT BCB BOARD CALVI C. B.
AS A PAYER OF LAST RESORT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON. FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN.
ALAN ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
BASICS NO BACKER. HI PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
COURTESY I DALLY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN. HI GROWTH
NO HURTS FOR HI WEST SO. HER
TADO HI JONES. NO KAMMERER HI
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI THE MON BY
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN
NEWMAN. NIELSEN OCHO A VOGUE.
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL KNOW. SIMILARLY
THE MOVES CALL MEMBERS NOW
MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ITEM FIFTY
SENATORS OR PREPARE FOR THAT I
DON'T. AND AFTER WHICH WILL
MOVE TO. SENATOR STERN ARE YOU
PREPARED VOLUME FIFTY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FOUR OH SIX BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS. SURE CERN FOR SHORT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- MEMBERS THIS BILL
WOULD. TIGHTEN UP OPERATIONS AT
THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC ENERGY
MANAGEMENT DIVISION OR CAL JAM
THE STATE AGENCY THAT OVERSEES
OIL AND GAS WELL OPERATIONS-
JUST JUST TODAY ACTUALLY AN
ARTICLE WAS RELEASED IN
PROPUBLICA. DOCUMENTING. A
SPATE OF VIOLATIONS FROM. ONE
OPERATOR THAT TELLS THE STORY
OF SO MANY OPERATORS IN THE
STATE- SMALL OPERATIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT CAPITAL
RESOURCES TO MAITAIN THEIR
SAFETY OR THEIR WELL OPERATIONS
IN THE COMMUNITY LIVING RIGHT
BEHIND SOMEBODY'S HOUSE. SERGIO
AGUILAR LIVES IN PORTSMOUTH
HOTEL THAT'S RIGHT NEXT TO THE
NASCO PETROLEUM SITE DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES SERGIO UNDER
CURRENT LAW HAS NO VOICE IN THE
COUNT HIM PROCESS. TO RAISE
ISSUES OF SAFETY VIOLATIONS
JUST LIKE SO MANY OTHER NON
HOMEOWNER RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE TO BE
ACTUALLY A HOMEOWNER IN AN
ESTABLISHED RESIDENTS FEEL THE
RAISE COMPLAINTS OR HAVE A
VOICE IN THE COMMUNITY OUTREACH
PROCESS RIGHT NOW. THIS BILL
WOULD RESTORE COMMUNITY VOICE
FOR ALL THOSE FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES LIVING WITH THE OIL
AND GAS WELLS IN THEIR
BACKYARDS BUT IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE INSPECTION REPORTS AND
ENFORCEMENT MATTERS TO ME MADE
PUBLIC WE KNOW THAT- FROM-
TWENTY NINETEEN INVESTIGATION.
THAT A NUMBER OF SPILLS AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WERE NOT
UNDERTAKEN IN THE PENALTIES
ASSESSED CONNECTION NOT BEEN
COLLECTED. BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY CAL
JAM ISSUED SIXTY SIX
ENFORCEMENT ORDERS AND JUST
ELEVEN OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
COMPLIED WITH BUT THE VAST.
MAJORITY REMAINING OUTSTANDING-
THE IS WELL CAL PUB- THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT EACH AND
WELL- THAN ME BEING OUR OR MAY
NOT- CURRENTLY- NOT TRANSPARENT
AND NEED SIGNIFICANT ATTENTION.
BOTH IN I. T. ISSUE A PAPER
DOCUMENTATION ISSUE- AND IN A
MATTER OF WILL SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THISLACK OF TRANSPARENCY
WILL WILL BE RECTIFIED FOR ALL
THE RESIDENTS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INSTITUTION
AS WE- SEEK TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S OIL AND GAS WELL
REGULATION OPERATION THE BEST
IN THE COUNTRY WE ARE NOT THERE
YET BUT THIS THIS TAKES US IN
THAT DIRECTION. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER THE- OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M SORRY I'M SORRY HI
THE REFLECTION RIGHT INTO IT
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH SIX I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
NOT LESS. WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I HAD THE LSO CANYON-
FACILITY IN MY DISTRICT WHICH
HAS YOU KNOW HAD A MAJOR GAS
LEAKS FOR MANY MONTHS- MY OWN
PERSONAL VIEW IS IF THAT WAS
NECESSARY TO GAS THAT CAUSE
PEOPLE BEING ILL. BUT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A REPURPOSED OIL
FIELD IT WASALL THE CHEMICALS
THAT FELL INTO THE GROUND. FROM
THAT- WHEN THAT HAPPENED I
STARTED AROUND THE ROOM MIGHT
JUST AND I LIVE FOUR MILE OF
ANOTHER OFFICER VERY MUCH LIKE.
AND WHEN IT WAS FIRST. BUILT
THERE'S NOTHING AROUND IT NOW
IT'S SURROUNDED BY HOMES IS
SURROUNDED BY A CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I JUST THINK- ARE. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW. AND I THINK THIS IS AN A
PRUDENT MEASURE TO INFORM THEM
SO THEY CAN MAKE THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEST FOR THEM SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR NO VOTE ON SP
FOUR OH SIX. THANK YOU. BREAUX
CAN MR PRESIDENT I RAISING
CAUTIOUS SUPPORTED THIS BILL- I
BELIEVE THAT TRANSPARENCY IS
VERY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY WITH
COMES FROM THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY IN TRANSPARENCY
SPECIFICALLY IN KERN COUNTY
WHERE WE HAVE 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL- THAT IS CONSUMED
BY ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THINK THAT TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD
AND WE REALLY HAVE NOTHING TO
HIDE I APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUES
FROM FREMONT A FEW YEARS AGO
THE TRANSPARENCY BILL ON
FRACKING AND- DATA DATA THAT
HAS BEEN COLLECTED SHOWS THAT
IT IS DONE VERY SAFELY AND IT
IS- PROTECTS THE ENVIRONMENT
AND IT IS ONE OF THE SAFEST
PROCEDURES ESPECIALLY THE WAY
THAT WE OPERATE IN THE
REGULATORY CLIMATE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I THINK DATA
IS GOOD AND TRANSPARENCY IS
GOOD- I THINK THE BEAST THAT
PEOPLE HAVE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS THAT IT'S GOING TO BE FUNDED
AGAIN BY INDUSTRY. WHERE THE
CALCIUM ORGANIZATION OF THE CAL
JAM DEPARTMENT IS FUNDED
COMPLETELY BY INDUSTRY THE
OUTRAGE WILL BE FUNDED BY
INDUSTRY- AND SO- AGAIN IN
TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD I JUST
THINK THAT AS WE- REQUEST WE
REQUEST STUFF TO BE DONE TO
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC AND E
REQUEST AS LEGISLATORS FOR
OTHER ITEMS SO THAT PEOPLE ARE
ARE MADE AWARE AND MAKES ME
THINK OF A SCRIPTURE JOSE FOR
SIX IS MY PEOPLE PERISH FOR
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE KNOWLEDGEABLE.
ABOUT THE OIL INDUSTRY
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THINGS THAT WE
CARE ABOUT- BUT WE ALWAYS
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THOSE
RESEARCH PROJECTS AND THOSE
TRANSPARENCY PROJECTS BUT IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT WE
ARE REQUIRING THE INDUSTRY TO
PAY FOR THIS OUT REACH- I
REALIZE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THIS DATA BUT- I THINK
FUNDING COULD BE PROVIDED SO- A
CAUTIOUSLY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITION DISK OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. IN CHINO
SOONER DURING WHICH A LOT. YES
THANK MISTER PRIME. TO MY
COLLEGE OF SENT THREE AND BIG.
APPRECIATE INPUT AND ENGAGE
HERE- I TOO SHARED THAT.
THAT'LL BE SO CAN'T AREA TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS SIMPLY DON'T
KNOW THAT THEY'RE LIVING. ON
OIL AND GAS SITES ON BURIED
WELLS- THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR MY
FAMILY IN THE PICO AREA. WITH-
RIGHT BEHIND THE SYNAGOGUE IT.
BY IN LAWS GO TO- THERE'S A-
BIG BUILDING AND YOU CAN'T
REALLY TELL WHAT'S IN THE
BUILDING BUT THEY REALIZE
ACTUALLY IT'S- A BUNCH OF OIL
WELLS IN THAT BUILDING THAT
HAVE BEEN LEAKING BENZENE AND
OTHER ITEMS OVER THE YEARS AND-
WASN'T EVEN SHOWING UP ON THE
MAPS IN THE COMMUNITY. LACKS
THAT BASIC INFORMATION ON POWER
THEMSELVES TO GO OUT AND LOOK
AFTER THEIR FAMILIES SO WE OWE
THEM AT LEAST THAT AND I
BELIEVE THAT- THE BILLS
DESIGNED RIGHT THAT THE PUBLIC
SHOULDN'T. PAY FOR THE ACCESS-TO THAT INFORMATION- THAT
TRANSPARENCY OUGHT TO COME AS A
RESPONSIBILITY OF. MAKING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM OIL
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA- SO I
THINK IT'S THE LEAST WE CAN DO
WONDERS. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FOR FIFTY WITH ALAN. I
ARCHULETA HI AT CAN I BASE I
BECKER I FORGES. BRADFORD. HI
BY ADAM HI COURTESY HI DALLY.
DODD FIVE TORONTO I THANK
HEAVEN HI GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH HI HURTS BERG HI
WEST SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S MAN HI I. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A VOGUE HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH
HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE CASTING
FIVE WINNER I WILL FIVE. MMHM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. PORGES DALLY.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY
SIX KNOWS IT IS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FIFTY
FOUR FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE CENTER ALLEN HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR ALAN AN
ACT RELATING THIS RESENTENCING
CENTER ALLEN THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS YOU MAY RECALL WE
ALL PASSED A COUPLE BILLS OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS. THAT
REPEALED THE CRIMINAL
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS THAT
ADDED THREE YEARS OF
INCARCERATION TO DEFENDANTS FOR
EACH PRIOR DRUG OFFENSE THAT
WAS. CENTER MITCHELL'S BILL
MINUTES AND WE KNOW HOW TO
BUILD. THAT- ADDED WHEN- ONE
YEAR IN CARS FOR EACH PRIOR
PRISON OR FELONY JAIL TERM. NOW
LET'S JUST REMEMBER FOLKS THAT
WHEN YOU ARE COMEDIAN WHEN YOU
ARE CONVICTED OF A CRIME YOU
ALREADY HAVE A ROBUST-
PUNISHMENT JAIL TIME ASSOCIATED
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS ANOTHER. ADDED ON-
MITIGATING AND PUNISHMENTS- BUT
BUT THEY WE TOOK A LONG HARD
LOOK AT THESE TWO PARTICULAR
pFOR PRIOR IS ASSOCIATED WITH- A
PRIVATE PRISON IN PRIOR DRUG
OFFENSES AND DECIDED THAT THEY
JUST DO IT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA. IT JUST DOESN'T SHOW THAT
THEY DO ANYTHING TO HELP WITH
THE GUARDS TO. RECIDIVISM IT
SECTOR. SO CALIFORNIA COMEDIAN
REVISION THE PENAL CODE. AND
CAME OUT WITH A COUPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS. THIS
IS A BUILDING DIRECTLY-
DESCENDS FROM THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND IT WILL
RETROACTIVELY APPLY. THESE
REPEAL PENALTY ENHANCEMENTS TO
PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
JAILS AND PRISONS AND PRISONS
WERE CONVICTED PRIOR TO THEIR
APPEAL. THE IDEA BEING THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE. A SIGNIFICANTLY
LONGER SENTENCE BECAUSE YOU'RE
CONVICTED. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
RATHER THAN HI TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THAT'S IT THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW. AND AS I SAY RECENT
STUDIES BY THE US SENTENCING
COMMISSION FOUND THE
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION OF
SENTENCE REDUCTIONS IN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM HAVE HAD NO
MEASURABLE IMPACT. ON
RECIDIVISM RATES THERE'S BEEN
SIMILAR STUDIES DONE IN
MARYLAND MICHIGAN FLORIDA. THAT
HAVE COME TO SIMILAR
CONCLUSIONS AND SOME LIGHT IN
THIS RESEARCH AND FOLLOWING THE
GUIDANCE OF A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS WE- EFFECTIVELY
CREATE PARITY. TEMP WORLD
PARITY APPLYING TO LIKE A LOT
USUALLY BY RETROACTIVELY
REPEALING WHAT. EVIDENCE SHOWS
ARE INEFFECTIVE THREE YEAR. AND
ONE YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCERS
THOSE PARTICULAR SENSE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE DID AWAY
WITH SB. FIFTY AN SP ONE THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU. ANY DESCRIPTION
OF THE- MANSARD- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ACTIONS BY BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD RIGHT HI
COME BY ADAM HI COURTESY. HI
DALLY NO DODD HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN. GLAZER. NO GUNS ALLAH'S
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER. LAYERED HI LLEVA HI WE
MOAN I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN.
NEWMAN I NELSON. OTOBO NO PAN
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW. ROTH
FIVE RUBIO FIVE SCANNER I STERN
I AM BERG. WHY IT WHY CASKEY
FIVE WINNER. FIVE WELL NO. MMHM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. EGGMAN. GROVE NO. CAM
LONGER. I DON'T KNOW HER TADO I
DON'T KNOW. YEAH. CAN LONGER
I'D- NINE. HEY MAN I. MELINDA'S
MEN. NIELSEN FORTUNE TINO.
AMBERG. PRICE TWENTY SIX MILLS
NINE MEASURE PASSES NO MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR STERN AS
HE PREPARED. HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY MINISTER IN
FLOORS YOURS. THANK YOU MEMBER
THIS BILLS RELATED TO AN
ONGOING ISSUE MANY OF US IN THE
SENATE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON-
FOR. RELATED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. ON THIS ISN'T
JUST- NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ISSUE
IT'S ALSO BEEN A MAJOR. ISSUE
IN THE LOS ANGELES VENTURA
COUNTY AREAS THAT I REPRESENT
AND ALL THE WAY AND KERN COUNTY
AND EVERYWHERE BASE AT THE
SANTA ANA WINDS BLOW. AND THE
WILDFIRES MOVE OF WE'VE SEEN
POWER TAKEN DOWN AFFECTING
AVERAGE OF FIFTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS AT A TIME- AVERAGE
AVERAGES OF THIRTY HOURS IN
DURATION WAS SOME LASTING AS
LONG AS SEVEN DAYS- OCCURRING
DURING HOLIDAYS DURING THE
PANDEMIC DURING TIMES AND
PEOPLE ARE. ZOOMING THERE HAVE
BEEN A FALSE ALARMS AND KEPT
PENDING POWER OUTAGES CAUSING
STRESS AND TRAUMA ANXIETY. THE
ELDERLY BEING IMPACTED LOSS OF
MEDICATION FOOD AND THE LIST
GOES ON. I'M FOR MOST
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY P. S.
P. S. KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON- IS
NOT JUST A FREEZE IT'S A- IT'S
A MANDATE IT HAS TO HAPPEN THIS
IS SUPPOSED TO BE A LAST RESORT
OPTION- BUT- YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN IS. BEING USED TOO
LIBERALLY AND- WITHOUT ENOUGH
MITIGATION IN PLACE SO THIS
BILL WOULD. REQUIRE OUR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
REPORT IN THEIR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS. THE ENERGY
CIRCUITS THAT ARE FREQUENTLY
BEING DE ENERGIZED FROM PS PS
EVENTS. AND THE MEASURES THAT
THEY'RE TAKING OR PLANNING TO
TAKE TO FIX THESE ENERGY
CIRCUIT SO THAT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND COMMUNITIES CAN
REALLY PLAN AROUND THIS WORK
AND GET PREPARED- WE'VE BEEN
HEARTENED TO SEE THE WORK FOR
MEDICINE LOCALLY AND THE HEADS
UP NOW BEING GIVEN ABOUT THEIR
RESTORATION PLANS USING THE
HELICOPTERS GOING OVERHEAD.
LOOKING AT THE WIRE LINES AND-
GETTING AUTO RECLOSERS IN PLACE
AND HARDENING THEIR
TRANSMISSION CIRCUITS- BUT IT'S
FRANKLY NOT ENOUGH- WE CANNOT
HAVE A REPEAT OF WHAT WE HAD
LAST YEAR AND THE YEAR BEFORE
THAT- SO. WITH THIS- SP NINETY
NINE WHICH IS ALSO BEING CURED
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA.AND
CRUCIAL FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
HOPEFULLY WE CAN START TO TURN
THE CORNER HERE AND- KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON. FOR CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THIS NEW THREAT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ONE OF FIRE. AND
WITH INTEREST ASK. ANY
ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION OF
DEBATE ON THE ITEM SIR OUT. MY
THANK YOU MR MEMBERS I. WANT TO
DO THIS CLICK I VOTED AGAINST
IN THE ENERGY BUT IT'S BEEN
HE'S THAT THE DOG TAKEN IN- I'D
I KNOW THAT- MANY OF- IN THE
NORTH HAVE BEEN. FACED WITH THE
THESE PS PS AND- IT'S REALLY
IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITIES IN
SPECIALLY THOSE WHO OWN
BUSINESSES- FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
OWN A STORE IN YOUR
REFRIGERATION IS OUT FOR A
WHILE YOU LOSE ALL THE PRODUCTS
IN THERE AND THEN YOU TURN IT
BACK YOU GET BACK GOING IN AND
THAT COMES AGAIN AND SO
TRANSPARENCY IS KEY. RIGHT NOW
FOR- THOSE AREAS AND WE KNOW
THAT IN CERTAIN AREAS WE HAVE
WINDOW VENTS WHERE IT'S JUST
BECAUSE OF THE TOPOGRAPHY AND
THE WAY THAT THE WINDS COME IN
SO- THIS IS A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO BE ABLE TO
HELP GET THOSE FOLKS EDUCATED
ON WHEN IT'S GOING TO BE HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE. AND- SO I
SUPPORTED PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU FOR READING. ME
MR FOR. I USED TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SP FIVE THIRTY THREE
AS MENTIONED BY MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES THIS PROVIDES
GREATER TRANSFER TRANSPARENCY.
WHICH PLEASE CHECKOUT ABILITY
WHICH ULTIMATELY LEADS TO TRUST.
THE P. S. P. S. EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS ARE COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. I HAD SITUATIONS
IN MY DISTRICT WERE COMMUNITIES
WHOLE COMMUNITIES ARE SHUT DOWN
FOR UP TO FIVE DAYS I BELIEVE I
SHARED A STORY WHERE A
CONSTITUENT EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD
VETERAN WHEELCHAIR BOUND. HE
HAD HIS POWER CUT OFF CALL THE
UTILITY THE CHILI SAID CALL
NINE ONE ONE. FORTUNATELY HE
CALLED- SIMPLY MEAN TIME
LACKEY'S OFFICE AND AS SOMEONE
LACKING MYSELF WENT AND RENTED
A GENERATOR TOOK IT OUT TO HIS
HOUSE AND PUT IT UP AND GAVE IT
TO ME FOR FIVE DAYS THESE
SITUATIONS ARE UNACCEPTABLE. I
ALSO CONCUR WITH MY CALL A
COLLEAGUE. THAT LISA MARY
ADDISON HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATE. IT AND I THINK IT
IS IT IS GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT BUT WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO MORE AND I
THINK THIS BILL IS A PROPER
STEP FORWARD AND WITH THAT. I
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO VOTE I.
THANK YOU SENATOR GIRL. BECAUSE
OF ANY ADDITION DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE THE SIDE. HEARING SHE
NINE CENTER ST WOULD YOU LIKE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER TO MY CALL
FROM A BIEBER FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH US AND STAY ON THIS
ISSUE AS WE AMENDED THE BILL
GOING FORWARD IN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA CLARITA AND WE SHARE
THAT SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH- THIS AREA THIS
YEAR- SORT OF- POORLY
ADMINISTERED PS PS WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT MITIGATION OR
TRANSPARENCY HAS GOT IT AND- SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RIGHT ALAN. HI ARCHULETA I AT
KINS BY BAIT I BACKER HI FORGES.
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI CORTESE
I DALLY. I DON HI DURAZO BY
ADMIN HI GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG HI
WEST SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I. LEIVA.
HI THE MON BY LOCAL FIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
FIVE PORTS AND TINA HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. BY SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI I WINNER.
I WILL I AM SICK TO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. GORGEOUS
JONES. MELINDA'S NIELSEN. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS REMOVED ON
THE FOLLOWING FIFTY NINE SOONER
OR LATER HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. THIS
BILL WOULD IMPROVE INDEPENDENT
AUDITS OF NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL SOMETIMES CALLED
INDEPENDENT STUDY. TO GIVE US A
BETTER CHANCE OF CATCHING FRAUD
BEFORE IT GETS OUT OF CONTROL
THIS BILL IS BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. WHICH
UNCOVERED AND PROSECUTED IN
NATURE SCHOOL FRAUD CASE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY- SP FIVE NINE
THREE WOULD REQUIRE AUDITORS TO
BE SPECIALLY TRAINED TO SPOT
RED FLAGS FOR FRAUD. VERIFY
RANDOM SAMPLES OF ENROLLMENT.
FLAG QUESTIONABLE EXPENDITURES
AND CALL OUT LARGE FINANCIAL
TRANSFERS. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ADD NEW TRANSPARENCY AND
RESTRICTIONS ON THE HIRING OF
PRIVATE VENDORS WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS. NO NO SAFEGUARD CAN
NEVER STOP EVERY CRIMINAL
DETERMINED TO CHEAT THE SYSTEM
AND STEAL PUBLIC FUNDS. BUT WE
CAN DO MORE TO TRY TO PREVENT
THESE CRIMES AND WE CAN DO IT
IN A STRATEGIC WAY THAT DOES
NOT PUNISH THE MANY ETHICAL
CHARTER SCHOOL MANAGERS AND
pINTERESTS OF THEIR STUDENTS AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES AT HEART.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY THREE
DOES JUST THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AND I BOTH. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SCENE NINE MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BY BAIT HI
BECKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
COURTESY HI DALLY. NOT HI TODD
HI THERE ALSO. EGGMAN HI
PLEASER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW.
HI HURTS BERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI LYNN MON HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN. NIELSEN A SHOW VOGUE HI
PAM I PERSON TINA HI RALPH. HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
I'M BERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WINNER I WILL. HI DR PLEASE
CALL THEM UP TO MEMBERS.
TORONTO MELINDA'S. NEWMAN
NIELSEN WHITE HOUSE SKI. HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING A FALL ITEM SIXTY
SOONER GONZALEZ MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX OH
SIX BY SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY.
SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
SIX OH SIX WHICH DIRECTLY
RESPONDS TO SOME OF THE WORST
EMPLOYER ABUSES SEEN DURING THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
EVEN AFTERWARDS BUT THAT WILL
REMAIN JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
PAIN DEMOCRATS ONES DOWN. SB
SIX OH SIX WILL CODIFY PARTS OF
THE FEDERAL OSHA POLICY FOR
EGREGIOUS EMPLOYERS WHICH
ALREADY EXISTS GIVING CAL OSHA
THE AUTHORITY THOUGH- TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYERS FOR
WILLFUL VIOLATIONS WERE WORKERS
HAVE BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED BY A
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS. THAT BUILD OFF
FEDERAL OSHA'S CORPORATE WIDE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT POLICY BY
PROVIDING CAL OSHA WITHIN
THIRTY TO ISSUE AN ENTERPRISE
WIDE CITATION THAT WOULD APPLY
TO ALL CLICK LOCATIONS UNDER
COMMON OWNERSHIP WHEN AN
EMPLOYER'S POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES DIRECTLY VIOLATE
LABOR AND HEALTH AND- SAFETY
STANDARDS. WE PROPOSE POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE OPPOSITION
AND ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
THEM THAT WOULD CLARIFY THE
ABATEMENT PROVISIONS USING
EXISTING EXPEDITED HEARING
PROCESS UNDER CAL OSHA AND LOOK
FOR THE CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AGAIN AS B. SIX
OH SIX PROVIDES COLLISION WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF THEIR LIMITED
RESOURCES SO THEY'RE ABLE TO
RESPOND MORE EFFECTIVELY TO
VARIOUS HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE THE MOST
EGREGIOUS BY LARGE EMPLOYERS
THAT CONTINUE TO PUT WORKERS
LIVES AT RISK. WITH THAT I
THINK YOU AND ASK.
FOR A VOTE ON SB SIX OF SIX.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY THIS ABOUT
ON AS. SIX OH SIX. HEARING INTO
A NINE SIX PLEASE GO THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI
BABY NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM. HI
CORTESE HI DALLY NO DOT.
THEY'RE AWESOME HI EGGMAN I
BLAZER. CONSOL IS HIGH GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I WEAR SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I LIVE MY OWN.
HI MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. BEEN
NEWMAN. NIELSEN ATTILA BOTH. NO
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN I
AM BERG HI BY CAL SKI I WINNER.
I WILL NO M. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THAT TO MEMBERS. DODD
GLAZER. HER TADO. MELINDA'S MAN
I. NEWMAN I. NIELSEN. HIGHS
TWENTY EIGHT NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FALL ITEM SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR LOW MOAN SHE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE RE FORCE SENATE BILL
SEVEN OH TWO BY SENATOR LEE MON
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT CENTER TOMORROW
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SP SEVEN OH TWO
ESTABLISHES A WORKING GROUP TO
DISCUSS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ENSURE THE
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE. THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
BY AUGUST FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND ANNUALLY THERE
AFTER A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH I REGRET
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP REFLECTS ITS GREATER
POPULATION THE COLLECTION OF
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS A CRITICAL
STEP IN ACHIEVING GENDER RACIAL
ETHNIC EQUITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. THE ANNUAL REPORT
WILL SERVE AS A TOOL TO
IDENTIFY GAPS IN REPRESENTATION
INCREASE AVERAGE TO COMMUNITIES
AND ADDRESS BARRIERS TO SEEKING
APPOINTMENTS S. B. SEVEN OH TWO
IS CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUS
EFFORTS BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE DIVERSITY REPRESENTATION
AT ALL LEVELS OF DECISION
MAKING THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
LISTED OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I BUT- THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER JUST OR DEBATE ON
FOLLOW ITEMS. TWO HERE IN CHINO
MONTH AGO- PLEASE CALL ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. I AT KINS.
HI BASE I BECKER. I PORCHES.
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM. HI TORONTO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ.
GROVE HERTZBERG I WAS SO. FIVE
HER TADO HI JONES FIVE KM
LONGER. I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN BUT SHOW BOTH. PAN FIVE
PORTS IN CHINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER FIVE STERN I AM BERG
ALL RIGHT HI MY CASKEY I WINNER
I WILL. TEN THIRTY PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. FOR JEFF. DALLY.
GONZALEZ I. GROVE MELINDA'S.
MAN I. NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH.
WELK. HIGHS THIRTY THREE KNOWS
IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE FALL
I'M SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
PORTENT TINO HE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR PART AND TINO AND
ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL LAW.
CLEANER PORN TOO YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS- SP FIVE SEVEN
FIFTEEN- REQUIRED APARTMENT A
JUSTICE COULD VERIFY THE
VALIDITY OF A HUNTING LICENSE
WHEN A PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. HE'S USING THE
LICENSE TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN
TRANSFERRING OR PURCHASING A
FIREARM WITH A HUNTING LICENSE
THERE'S NO A VERIFICATION
PROCESS DURING THE TEN DAY
BACKGROUND CHECK PROCESS. TO
ENSURE THAT THE HUNTING LICENSE
IS VALID IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A NINETEEN YEAR OLD A
LEGALLY PURCHASED A SEMI
AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE RIFLE FROM
A DEALER WITH AN INVALID
HUNTING LICENSE. AND TRAGICALLY
OPENED FIRE AT A SYNAGOGUE IN
POWAY CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE
GUN STORE FAILED TO ADEQUATELY
CHECK THE VALIDITY OF THE
HUNTING LICENSE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CLEARED
THE BACKGROUND CHECK. THAT
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY OCCURRED. THIS
BILL ALSO DEALS WITH AN
UNRESOLVED ISSUE IN A PREVIOUS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
INVESTIGATE AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING THAT RESULTS IN THE
DEATH OF AN UNARMED CIVILIAN.
OR IF THERE IS A REASONABLE
DISPUTE THAT THE CIVILIAN WAS
UNARMED THIS RECENTLY PLAYED
OUT IN MY DISTRICT. WHERE A MAN
GOT OUT OF A CAR CHASE BY
POLICE OFFICERS AND WAS SHOT.
AND THEY'RE ARGUING ABOUT
WHETHER THERE WAS A PRESENCE OF
A GUN. THIS WOULD DEAL WITH
THAT SITUATION BECAUSE IT'S A
DISPUTE THEREFORE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN INVESTIGATE LASTLY
THE BAIL CONTAIN SOME CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE. AND HOPEFULLY IT
ADDRESSES THESE OUTSTANDING
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
ANY FOR DISCUSSION OR- ON THE
SIDE. HERE IN CHINO AND MANAGE
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BASE NO BACKER HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T.
COURTESY HI DALLY NO DODD HI
DURAZO I A COMMON I. GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. FIVE HER
TADO HI JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED FIVE LLEVA I WILL MOAN
FIVE THE CHOIR HI MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A TRIO
OF BOTH. NO PAN FIVE PORTS AND
TINA FIVE ROCK HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE CASKEY I WINNER HI WILL
KNOW MMHM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. COME ADAM.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. HIGHS THIRTY
KNOWS SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS REMOVED ON THE FALL
ITEM SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR MAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETEEN BY
SENATOR MAN AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE. AND FOR GEORGE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SB SEVEN
NINETEEN PROVIDES THE TUSTIN
LEGACY PROJECT A MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN ON A FORMER-MILITARY BASE FLEXIBILITY UNDER
THE REVISED SURPLUS LAND ACT
WHILE SETTING AGGRESSIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TARGETS. AS
WE SEVEN NINETEEN RECOGNIZES
THE NEED TO BALANCE JOBS AND
HOUSING AT THE TUSTIN LEGACY
PROJECT WHILE HOLDING THE CITY
TO AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANDATE THAT IN THE AGGREGATE
IS ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN THE
SLA. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT IN THE AGGREGATE
AT LEAST 20% OF NEW RESIDENTIAL
UNITS BUILT ON THE SITE THE
RESERVE FOR FORMAL HOUSING WITH
THE MINIMUM 15% RESTRICTED TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- THE WAY
THIS IS A PRODUCT OF A LOT OF
HARD WORK IN DISCUSSION WITH
THE CITY OF TUSTIN. AND I KNOW
THEY'RE MOTIVATED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
HAS REACHED OUT TO MY OFFICE
REQUESTING LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
FAIR PAY AND PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS. AND I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THESE CONCERNS OF MY
OFFICES HAD A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WITH THE BUILT IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
I WANT TO ALSO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ENGAGED ON THIS
MEASURE AND REITERATE MY
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON SB SEVEN NINETEEN.
THIS BILL IS A MATTER OF LOCAL
CONTROL AND WILL FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOUSANDS OF
HOUSING UNITS AND HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN MY
DISTRICT WHILE EXPEDITING
HOUSING PRODUCTION BRINGING
JOBS INCREASING ACCESS TO OPEN
SPACE AND BUILDING NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY ON A LOT
THAT IS CURRENTLY. NOT BEING
DEVELOPED. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU ANY FOR THIS. OF DEBATE ON
AS SEVEN. SENATOR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT RISE OF THIS
LEGISLATION IT JUST LIKE OUR
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR INTRODUCED
AT A COMMONSENSE HOUSING BILLS
TO USE BIG BOX STORES TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE HOUSING AND
BUILD HOUSING WHERE- PROPERTIES
ARE GOING TO BE AN OCCUPIED
THIS MILITARY BASE CAN PROVIDE
THE SAME TYPE OF- A HOUSE IN A
SOLUTION THAT WE NEED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF THE RATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN C. NOW OWNS
CENTER MANY YOU LIKE TO. I LIKE
TO THINK MY COLOR FROM BIG FOR
HER- SUPPORT- KIND IN OUR ASK
DR. THANK YOU MEDITECH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI-
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE HI
BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DALLY I DONT. I
TORONTO BY ADMIN I PLEASE SIR
EYE CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE. HI
HERTZBERG FIVE WESTERN. HI HER
TADO BY JONES. I CAN LONGER
FIVE LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE WE
MOAN. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT
SHOW BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO HI ROB HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
I STERN I AM BERG HI WE CASKEY
I WINNER I WILL I. M. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE COPS MEMBERS
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN MEMBERS ARE
EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP THIS
FALL I AM SIXTY SIX SENATOR
ALTHOUGH YOU'RE PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR DURAZO AN AXE A RELATED
CRIMINAL RECORDS SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I'M
PROUD TO STAND HERE TO PRESENT
IS B. SEVEN THIRTY ONE ON
SUNSET IN CONVICTIONS RECORDS.
THERE ARE EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA LIVING WITH UNDER
ARREST OR CONVICTION ON THEIR
RECORD. THEY ARE SIBLINGS OUR
PARENTS OUR NEIGHBORS CO
WORKERS AND FELLOW CHURCH
GOERS. WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
COMPLETES THEIR SENTENCE THERE
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY
THEY'VE ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEIR ACTIONS WHILE THEY
ARE INCARCERATED MANY OF THEM
TOOK CLASSES OR IN ROLDAN
COUNSELING. THEY PURSUE THE
REHABILITATION AND WORKED HARD
TO BE PREPARED FOR THE RE ENTRY
INTO OUR COMMUNITY. BUT AFTER
THE RELEASE INSTEAD OF BEING
ABLE TO PUT THEIR NEW SKILLS TO
USE AND BEGIN TO BUILD A NEW
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES. THEY ARE
HIT WITH LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
RESTRICTIONS AND LIMITATIONS
THAT KEEP THEM FROM BUILDING A
NEW LIFE. CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS
AN INDIVIDUAL'S CONVICTION
RECORDS UNTIL THEY REACH A
HUNDRED YEARS OF AGE. WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE DENIED ACCESS
TO STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING BECAUSE OF A PAST
ARREST OR CONVICTION THEY ARE
PUSHED INTO THE MARGINS OF
SOCIETY. WHERE THEY ARE LEFT
WITH FEWER LEGITIMATE OPTIONS
TO PROVIDE FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THIS BILL WILL
EXTEND CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
SYSTEM FOR ARREST AND
CONVICTION RECORD RELIEF IN
THREE WAYS ONE. WILL EXTEND
ARREST RECORD SEALING TO FELONY
ARRESTS BUT ONLY IF THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS NEITHER CHARGED
NOR CONVICTED SIX YEARS AFTER
THE ARREST SECOND. IT WILL
EXTEND AUTOMATIC CONVICTION
RECORD RELIEF. TO NON SERIOUS
AND NON VIOLENT FELONIES AFTER
AN INDIVIDUAL COMPLETES ALL
TERMS OF INCARCERATION
PROBATION SUPERVISION. POST
RELEASE. SUPERVISION PAROLE AND
A FURTHER PERIOD OF FOUR YEARS
WITHOUT ANY NEW CONVICTIONS. IT
WILL THREE ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF A SERIOUS OR
VIOLENT FELONY TO PETITION THE
COURT. FOR STEALING RELIEF
THESE PETITIONS ARE DONE ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND THE
COURTS MAKE THE FINAL DECISION.
AS MANY AS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN DENIED
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF PAST.
RECORDS IN THIS LAST YEAR ALONE.
MANY PEOPLE WITH THE CONVICTION
FROM PAS CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES IS THE LEADING
DRIVER OR RECIDIVISM IT
DESTABILIZES FAMILIES
UNDERMINES OUR ECONOMY AND
MAKES OUR COMMUNITIES LESS
SAFE. A PAST RECORD DENIES A
FAMILY FROM MOVING INTO A NEW
HOUSE IT DENIES MOTHERS THE
CHANCE TO PURSUE A NEW CREER.
THROUGH EDUCATION AND IT DENIES
FATHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COACH THEIR CHILDREN. WE WANT
TO GIVE INDIVIDUALS THE MEANS
TO OVERCOME THE SPECIFIC
EXCLUSIONS THAT A PAST RECORD
BRINGS BUT INSTEAD LET'S PUT
THEM ON THE PATH TOWARDS
STABILITY AN OPPORTUNITY. NOT
ONLY FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
CHILDREN BUT FOR OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
DOES NOT CHANGE HOW EXPUNGEMENT
RELIEF INTERACTS WITH
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING AND IT
DOES NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
EXISTING LICENSING DISCLOSURE
OBLIGATIONS. THERE ARE HIGH
SENSITIVITY LICENSING AGENCIES
EMPLOYERS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE FULL ACCESS TO ALL RECORDS
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT-
REGULATED HEALTH WORK-
INVOLVING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS- HUMAN SERVICES
WORK INVOLVING CARE OF CHILDREN
THE ELDERLY OR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. SECURITY BANKING
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SEVEN THIRTY ONE
INCLUDES STRINGENT OVERSIGHT
AND STRICT SCRUTINY AT EVERY
SINGLE STAGE. IN EVERY INSTANCE
IT PROVIDES AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WEIGH IN
ON ANY POTENTIAL RELIEF
GRANTED. IT IS SUPPORTED BY A
VERY VERY BROAD COALITION OF.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ECONOMIC
JUSTICE BUSINESS GROUPS
COMMERCIAL GROUPS. RELIGIOUS
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE THIS MODEST STEP TO
GIVE SOME INDIVIDUALS THE TOOLS
TO TURN THE PAGE ON THE PAST
AND GIVE HIM AT LEAST THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BUILD A NEW
BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I URGE
AND I'VE- THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION OR DEBATE SENATOR
HER. MR PRESIDENT SAID FOR
MEASURE PRESS TO THIS ON THE
SPOT VOTER TODAY. A DEEP MORAL.
WHEN SOMEONE MAKES A MISTAKE IN
SOCIETY. IS CONVICTED BY A JURY
OF THEIR PEERS. THEY PAY THAT
DEBT TO SOCIETY THROUGH A
PRISON TERM OF PROBATION ALL
SORTS OF OTHER MATTERS. THE
QUESTION IS IT A LIFE SENTENCE.
BECAUSE IN FACT WHEN YOUR
CRIMINAL RECORD. TRAILS YOU IT
BECOMES A LIFE SENTENCE IT
BECOMES A SCAR ON WHO YOU ARE.
DON'T WE AS A SOCIETY DON'T WE
IS A MORAL PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO BOTH ON
THE ONE HAND EXTRACT PENALTIES
FOR PEOPLE THAT VIOLATE DEEP
SOCIETAL RULES BUT DON'T WE
HAVE COMPASSION IN OUR HEARTS
TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE THEIR LIVES
WITHOUT A LIFETIME SCAR. SO I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL BASIS IN TERMS OF
OUR VALUES. THE RIGHT THING TO
DO I ASKED FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THINK CENTRE HERZBERG SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY- AND APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES MOST ENGINES FOR
THIS BILL. IF WE BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION AS A PURPOSE OF
INCARCERATION- WE NEED
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
DENIED TO. CONVICTS EX CONVICTS
IT'S JUST REMARKABLE AND NEED
OF REDRESS AND I ALSO WANT TO
PLUG MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAME
GOES FOR THE THOUGHTFUL MOMENTS
THAT SHE TOOK THAT SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDES SERIOUS VIOLENT AND
SEX FELONIES FROM AUTOMATIC
RELIEF- THESE ARE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE. THAT THERE'S A RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE NEED TO TRY
TO CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EX CONVICTS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I URGE NIVEAU. THANK
YOU ANY FOR DISCUSS OR TO. ON
SB SEVEN ONE. HEARING CENA AND
SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU LOOK
CLOSE. SURGEON I VOTE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASE NO
BACKER. HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
HI BY ADAM I COURTESY HI DALLY
NO DODD HI TORONTO HI ADMIN I.
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO. JONES O CAN
WALKER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
RAMON HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN OCHO
ABODE NO CAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROSS. HI RUBIO I SCAN. I STERN
I AM BERG HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WINNER I WILL KNOW MA'AM SIR
TERRY PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. GROW NO. HER TADO.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. PRICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS. PRICE THIRTY I'M
SORRY HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO CALL WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS WERE
GONNA LOOK TO CALL IN AFTER
WHICH WE WILL BREAK FOR LUNCH
SO WERE READY MEMBERS IF YOU
CAN GET BACK TO THE FLOOR YOU
WERE ABSENT WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FALL ITEM TWENTY TWO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE. LET THE
CALL. ALAN I. PORGES. CABRERO I
DALLY. DODD. GROVE. HER TADO I.
LIMO OWNED BY MELINDA'S NIELSEN
A SHOW OF BOTH. I WILKE. GROVE
HI MINISTER TURTLE THAT THE
MEMBERS. FOR JUST FIVE. DALLY I.
GOD I. MELINDA'S NIELSEN. WELL
I. MEMBERS. FIVE THIRTY SIX. WE
HAVE WE HAVE A BOAT CHANGING
BAITS NO THE I. EIGHT NOTE I'D-
MEMBERS NOW FOR FALL I'M TWENTY
TWO S. B. TWO EIGHT PRICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOT MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FILE I'M TWENTY
FOUR S. B. SIX SIX FOUR MEN
CENTER PLEASE LOOK TO CALL.
BASICS GORGEOUS. DALLY NO.
GROVE I. MELINDA'S NIELSEN.
FIVE THIRTY TWO NOTES FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS FALL
ITEM TWENTY FIVE SP SIX EIGHT
SIX MADAM SECRETARY LIVE CALL.
BASICS NO GROVE NO MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN A SHOW ABOUT. HI RIGHT
MEMBERS STATS. FIVE THIRTY TWO
NOTES SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. TWENTY FIVE. I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY WE JUST SHOULD TWENTY
FIVE MOVING FILING TWENTY SIX
SP SEVEN TO SIX MINUTES
CENTERED PLEASE LOOK TO CALL.
BASICS GROVE NO MELINDA'S
NIELSEN. PRICE THIRTY ONE WHO
KNOWS SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WOMEN ON THE FALL ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE LOOK CALL. BACKER. HI
FORGES. WEST SO I. BLUE MOON I
MELINDA'S NIELSEN WILKE NO.
MARCH THIRTY THREE MILLS FOR ON
THE URGENCY AUGUST THIRTY THREE
MILLS FOR ON THE MEASURE. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM
TWENTY NINE. INSPECTOR LOOKED
CALL. TALLY JONES. LIMONEIRA I
MELINDA'S NIELSEN WELL I. DALLY
I. PRICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY OF ICE THIRTY
SEVEN. DOES IT ZERO ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS WILL BE ON THE FALL
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. WELL LOOK THE
CALL. HER TADO. WE MOAN I
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN SKINNER I
WELL. NO. PRICE THIRTY NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM SIXTY
THREE. MADAM SECRETARY WHEN
YOU'RE READY LIVE CALL. GLAZER
HER TADO. LIMONIUM. FIVE
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN. RUBIO I
UMBERG WON'T KNOW. WELL NO.
PRICE TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON THE FALL ITEM SEVENTY ONE.
INSPECTOR YOU MAY LOOK TO CALL.
BLUEMOUNTAIN I MELINDA'S
NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. MADAM
SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
CAN LOOK TO CALL. GROVE. HER
TADO. LIMONEIRA I MELINDA'S
NIELSEN. GROVE NO. HIGHS THIRTY
NOTE THIS SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM ONE OH EIGHT. MADAM
SECRETARY LOOKED CALL.
LIMONEIRA I MELINDA'S. NIELSEN.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE. NOW
MOVING ON THE FALL ITEM THIRTY
TWO. CONCERTS ARE YOU CAN LOOK
CALL. BAIT. LIMONIUM I
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. BATES HI.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO THAT IS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOMINUM SECRETARY WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. YOU
CAN LOOK TO CALL. BASICS.
PORGES NO. CORTESE I DALLY.
GONZALEZ I. GROVE NO. HER TADO.
JONES. LIVE MON I MELINDA'S
NIELSEN WELL NO. PRICE THIRTY
ONE KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FALL ITEM THIRTY NINE.
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY LOOK TO
CALL. BLUEMOUNTAIN I MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN RUBIO HI I WILKE.
CURRENT MEMBERSHIP PRICE THIRTY
ONE NO SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE. MADAM
SECRETARY MAY LOOK TO CALL.
FAITH. GORGEOUS. BY ADAM. SALLY.
GOD I GLAZER. GROWTH. WAY SO I
MELINDA'S. NEWMAN I. NIELSEN A
SHOW OF BOTH I. RUBIO. FIVE
THIRTY NO ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE ON OUR
FINAL ITEM ON CALL FALL ITEM
FORTY SEVEN. M. SECRETARY YOU
MAY LOOK TO CALL. ALAN I. WEST
SO. HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN BUT SHOW A VOGUE. RUBIO
I AMBERG HI. BYE A CHOKE HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN I. HIGHS TWO NO
SIX THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO BREAK
FOR LUNCH WE'RE HEARING TO A
TWENTY MINUTE LUNCH SO THAT
BEING THE CASE WE'RE GOING TO
ASK EVERYBODY TO RETURN BACK TO
YOUR DESK AT TWELVE TWENTY
THREE WE HAVE A TWENTY MINUTE
BREAK IF WE WANT TO STAY ON
TIME SO WE'LL SEE YOU BACK AT
TWELVE TWENTY THREE ON THE
FLOOR PROPERLY.
MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WILL CONVENE AND SIXTY
SECONDS.
OUR MEMBERS WE WANT TO
GET BACK TO WORK WE NEED TO GET
BACK TO BUSINESS WE NEED ALL
THE MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR. THAT
PARTY MEMBERS WERE STARTING
BACK. WE HAVE THIRTY ONE
MEASURES W WANT TO GET THROUGH
BY THREE O'CLOCK SO THAT MEAS
WE HAVE TO BE ON TIME TO BE
READY AND SENATOR BLAZERS HE'S
READY WERE WHAT PAUL ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR PROPOSES
MODEST CHANGES THAT WILL BEGIN
CLOSING THE DATA GAP. THAT HAS
KEPT US FROM FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE IT WILL ADD
DETAILS TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ASK THOSE
WHO DO TEST POSITIVE. S THAT
THE INFORMATION GATHERED WILL
BE MORE USEFUL. THE BILL ALSO
CHANGES IN EXISTING SYSTEM FOR
SHARING DATA WITH BONAFIDE
RESEARCHERS SO THAT OUR BEST
SCIENTISTS CAN STUDY THE SPREAD
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN REAL
TIME. AND PROVIDE US WITH THE
TIMELY INFORMATION WE NEED TO
MAKE INTELLIGENT DECISIONS.
MEMBERS IT'S TOO LATE TO SAVE
THOSE WHO HAVE PERISHED DURING
THIS TERRIBLE PANDEMIC. BUT
IT'S NEVER TOO EARLY TO PREPARE
FOR THE NEXT ONE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FOLLOWING HIM SIXTY
SEVEN. HEARING CENA AND MANN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KENS
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER. I
PORCHES. BRADFORD HI CABRERA.
CORTESE I DALLY HI TODD. THERE
ARE SO HI EGGMAN I LASER EYE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. BY HERTZ
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI LYNN MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN
BUT SHOW BOTH HI PAM. FORTUNE
TINO. BROCK HI RUBIO HI HI
SKINNER. STERN HI AMBERG HI
WHAT KASKY. FIVE WINNER I WILL
HI. SENATOR GLAZER MOVES CALL.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR
BECKER HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY MARY. SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
BACKER AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY CENTER
BECKER. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
A STEP TOWARDS CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS IT MEANS THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND SCHOOLS
WILL BE EQUIPPED EQUITABLY TO
USE AND IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY.
IN THE CLASSROOM. WE ALSO
DURING THE TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE LEARNING DURING CODED.
HOW EXPOSED AND EXACERBATED THE
STARK NAKED IN EQUITIES AMONG
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL DIRECTS
REGIONAL OFFICES TO CREATE
TECHNOLOGY RELATED PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING PROGRAMS AND TECH
SUPPORT AND ALLOWS THEM TO USE
ELSE YET THE FUNDING TO DO SO.
AND IN CONCERT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR EDUCATION WILL
DEVELOP ANNUAL TECHNOLOGY PLANS
TO SUPPORT DISTURBANCE IN THIS
ENDEAVOR. IS SUPPORTED BY
COUNTY BOARDS OF EDUCATION I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE FOR THE BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT THAT'S FAR AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON ITEM
FILE I'M SIXTY EIGHT. NOON SINA
AND MOUNT SECTOR YOU MAY CALL
THE WORLD. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS HI BATES I BECKER FIVE
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD FIVE
CABRERA HI COURTESY I DALLY. I
DONT I TORONTO I HAD BEEN I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH HIGH HURTS BERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
WATER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE
MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN
FIVE NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW
BOTH HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER.
STERN FIVE AMBERG HI FI CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL LOOK. HI.
TURNER'S BECKER MOVES THE CALL
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATOR ROTH
ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY BY SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ZERO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES YOU
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE ATTORNEYS
APPEARING IN CASES. IN OUR
COURT ROOMS IN THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE JUDGES HEARING THOSE
CASES ARE OFTEN QUITE DIFFERENT
THAN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THOSE
APPEARING IN FRONT OF THEM THIS
LACK OF DIVERSITY SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTS EQUITABLE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED AN ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE REPRESENTATION
AT LEAST THE PERCEPTION OF THAT
THROUGHOUT OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION THIS
BILL SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO WILL HELP CLOSE THE
DIVERSITY GAP BY PRINT PROCESS
BY EXPANDING A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE THAT EXISTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SEEKING TO BUILD A DIVERSE
EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO LAW SCHOOL. THE
CALIFORNIA LAW PATHWAYS PROGRAM.
NOW WHILE THIS BILL CERTAINLY
SPEAKS TO IMPROVING DIVERSITY
IN THE LAW PROFESSION AND IN
OUR COURT ROOMS AND THE BILL IN
FACT DOES THAT AT ITS CORE THE
BILL ADVANCES A PROGRAM THAT
REACHES DOWN INTO OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SCHOOLS WITHIN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. TO PIQUE THE
CURIOSITY OF STUDENTS IN A
CAREER IN THE LAW AND TO
PROVIDE A COORDINATED PATHWAY
FOR THOSE STUDENTS FROM HIGH
SCHOOL THROUGH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND COLLEGE TO LAW
SCHOOL AND ULTIMATELY A GOOD
PAYING JOB. AND A CAREER IN THE
LAW. FOR SOME THIS IS BEEN A
LIFE CHANGING AND BOTH HELP
FROM THIS BILL IT CAN BE SOLD
FOR SO MANY MANY MORE. ACTUALLY
YES FREERIDE VOTE THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR MAN I JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE- AS A FORMER LAW
PROFESSOR. I KNOW FIRSTHAND THE
DIFFICULTIES OF GETTING FIRST
TIME COLLEGE STUDENTS IN THE
LAW SCHOOL GETTING- PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE LAW SCHOOL SO THAT
WE HAVE DIVERSITY ON THE BENCH
IN OUR COURT ROOMS IN OUR LAW
FIRMS- IN IT THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE EMPHASIZE IS
THAT THERE AS A MATTER OF
EQUITY- WE TRY TO LIFT FOLKS UP
INTO THIS PROFESSION SO I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE AGAIN
AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ERNESTINA AND SENATOR RALPH
WHICH ARE CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE MR
PRESIDENT CUTE MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KANSAS FIVE
BASS FIVE BECKER HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I KERR BY.
HYPERTENSIVE HI DALLY I DONT HI
THERE AWESOME HI ADNAN I.
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO FIVE JONES. CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN A SHOW
OF BOTH. HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. I ROTH RIGHT HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER. STERN I AM BERG
HI MIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL. THE MEMBER MOVES A CALL
WE'RE MOVING THEM ON TO FALL
ITEM SEVENTY SENATOR BECKER ARE
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BACKER IN ACTS RELATING
TO MURDER. SENATOR BOOKER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS BODY
PASSED SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
AUTHORED BY SENATOR SKINNER
WITH BI PARTISAN SUPPORT. AT
THAT BILL CHANGED CALIFORNIA'S
LONG HELD UNJUST FELONY MURDER
LAW THAT WAS OVERLY PUNITIVE TO
THOSE WHO DID NOT KILL OR
INTEND TO KILL. A LOT OF
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE WHO TOOK
PLEA DEALS TO LESSER CHARGES
SUCH AS MANSLAUGHTER TO APPLY
FOR RESENTENCING. IT WAS A
LANDMARK PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT TRANSFORMED OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO BE ONE THAT
LIVES UP TO OUR IDEALS OF
FAIRNESS. JUSTICE AND EQUITY.
HOWEVER WHAT HAS OCCURRED SINCE
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
THAT SOME COURTS IN CORRECTLY
REASONED THAT ONLY APPLIED TO
MURDER AND NOT ATTEMPTED MURDER.
THESE COURTS HAVE BARRED PEOPLE
FROM APPLYING FOR RESENTENCING
WHICH IS LED TO AN ABSURD AND
UNFAIR SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING.
IF THE VICTIM DIED BUT ARE
INELIGIBLE WITH THE VICTIM DID
NOT DIE. THIS MEANS AT LEAST
CULPABLE PEOPLE ARE STILL
SERVING DECADES. IN PRISON EVEN
THOUGH THEY SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR RELIEF. AT B. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE BILLS ON SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY CLARIFYING
EXISTING LAW TO CLUE
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AND
ATTEMPTED MURDER CONVICTIONS AS
ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF UNDER S.
PEEN SP FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR COUNSEL TO
BE APPOINTED IN PETITIONS FOR
RESENTENCING ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS FOR THOSE WHOSE MURDER
ATTEMPTED MURDER OR
MANSLAUGHTER CONVICTIONS IT'S
FINAL TO APPEAL. THE SIMPLE
REFORM WHICH HAS HUNDREDS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE THAT THE
POWER CHORDS TEAMS HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED BY THE TECHNICAL
LANGUAGE IS LANGUAGE OF SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AND THE
THOUSANDS OF SIMILAR PEOPLE WHO
DID NOT FILE PETITIONS YET
BECAUSE OF THE COURT RULINGS.
THE BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I THOUGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. EARNINGS SEEN NO MEMBERS.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM SEVEN. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE NO
BACKER HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I HAVE A- CORTESE I DALLY. GOD
I- ALSO BY ADMIN I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
NO JONES. NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED FIVE LLEVA HI THE MON.
HI MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER STERN
HI AMBERG HI WE CASKEY I WINNER
I WILL KNOW. SENATOR BOOKER
MOVED CALL. NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ON ITEM SEVENTY TWO
SENATOR CORTESE ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR CORTEZ
SEE AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
INTERPRETED. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS PIECE
OF NINETY ONE WHICH CREATES A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT UNIT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON LOCAL
SURPLUS LAND THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
ON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO. ALAN. ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
I BASE. BECKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
HI DALLY. DOT THERE ARE SO BY
ADMIN. I GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI RAMON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN NEWMAN
I NIELSEN- SHOW VOGUE. HI PAM.
HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN HI
AMBERG RIGHT HI FORECASTING I
WINNER I WILL LOOK FINE.
SENATOR CORTESE MOVES A CALL
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR GLAZIER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION CENTER
GLAZIER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
WOULD REQUIRE RETAILERS WITH
ONLINE SALES TOTALING MORE THAN
A MILLION DOLLARS. TO REPORT TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION THE
CITY OR THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
THE PURCHASERS FOR ALL TAXABLE
SALES. TRANSACTION TRANSACTED
ONLINE. THIS BILL IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE DESIGNED
TO SHED LIGHT ON THE BRADLEY
BURNS UNIFORM LOCAL SALES TAX
LAW. UNDER BRADLEY BYRNE SALES
TAX REVENUE IS ALLOCATED TO THE
POINT OF SALE. FOR BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES THIS MEANS
ALLOCATING THE REVENUE TO THE
JURISDICTION THE STORES LOCATED
IN. ONLINE RETAILERS HOWEVER
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHERE THEY ALLOCATE SALES TAX
REVENUE. BE THAT A WAREHOUSE
AND DISTRIBUTION CENTER OR
SALES OFFICE. THIS ALLOWS
CORPORATIONS TO DIRECT REVENUE
TO A SINGLE JURISDICTION IN THE
STATE. AND NOW CORPORATIONS
HAVE USE THIS AS LEVERAGE WHEN
NEGOTIATING WHERE TO LOCATE
WITHIN THE STATE. THAT RESULTS-IN A RIGGED PROCESS DRIVING
CITIES TO ACCEPT INCREASINGLY
ONEROUS TAX SHARING AGREEMENTS
IN EXCHANGE FOR ONLINE
RETAILERS SENDING ALL THE SALES
TAX THEY COLLECT IN CALIFORNIA.
TO THAT SINGLE JURISDICTION.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO KNOW
HOW MUCH REVENUE THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS ARE SIPHONING FROM
THEIR CITY AND IT'S ESTIMATED
TO BE OVER A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. FOR THESE REASONS SB
SEVEN NINETY TWO WOULD REQUIRE
RETAILERS TO REPORT THE
DESTINATION DATA FOR ALL
TAXABLE SALES TRANSACTED
ONLINE. THE BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AS WELL
AS CITIES ACROSS THE STATE THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THOSE
EXISTING AGREEMENTS. NOW OR IN
THE FUTURE THAT SIMPLY LETS GET
TRANSPARENCY ON THE DATA SO WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THE REAL IMPACTS
OF- THE BRADLEY BURNS- SCHEME
THAT IS CURRENTLY IN PLACE
TODAY WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
BORDERS. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
AUTHOR- HAS BEEN DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE FOR SOME TIME OR
VARIATIONS OF IT YOU KNOW POINT
OF ENTRY POINT OF SALE AND HE'S
A HE'S A HE'S VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE I'VE HAD OCCASION
TO CHAT WITH HIM ON THIS I
THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN- THERE'S A SIMILAR
ISSUE. FROM MY STANDPOINT IS
REPRESENTED THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE LACK THE ECONOMIC DIVERSITY
THAT A LOT OF PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE. WERE
PREDOMINANTLY IN AGRICULTURE WE
HAVE- MEDICAL SERVICES- BUT
LARGELY IT'S A SERVICE INDUSTRY
SO WHEN WE USE OUR GEOGRAPHY
TOWARD VANTAGE TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES SOMETIMES WE HAVE
TO HAVE THESE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS LOCATED IN THE SPINE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT FOLKS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD HAVE ABOUT THIS IS
THAT SOME OF THESE SOME OF
THESE CITIES. LEVERAGE THEIR
GENERAL FUND IN THEIR TAX BASE
TO OFFER INCENTIVES FOR. AMAZON
OR- IN A KIA OTHER MAJOR
OUTLETS TO COME TO THEIR AREA
TO PROVIDE OBS. LARGELY OUT OF
NECESSITY BUT ALSO OF COURSE
YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO COME TO
THE VALLEY BECAUSE OF ITS
PROXIMITY AND IT'S-
TRANSPORTATION HUB. SO ONE OF
THE CONCERNS AND THAT I WOULD-
THROW TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE SENATE IS THAT NOT EVERY
COMMUNITY. HAS THE SAME SET OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHEN YOU HAVE
A SYSTEM LIKE THIS WHERE. IT
DISALLOWS A DISTRIBUTION CENTER
OR SOME OTHER ENTITY THAT IS
SIMILARLY SITUATED FROM
NEGOTIATING WITH THE CITY AND
THE CITY EXPECTING TO BE ABLE
TO- TO CAPITALIZE ON THESE
DOLLARS. IT CREATES FURTHER
INEQUITY IN AN AREA THAT NEEDS
ITS ADVANTAGES SO I WOULD I
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THIS TO MY
FRIEND- IN TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE SENATE. THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS- YOU HAVE TO
APPRECIATE WHAT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS LIKE YOU KNOW THE
TWELVE COUNTIES- UP AND DOWN
THE SPINE OF CALIFORNIA IN FOR
TALKING ABOUT. EMPOWERING THE
REGION AND. LOOKING AT FOLKS.
THAT NEED TO DIVERSE
ECONOMICALLY. DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS AND TRANSPORTATION HUBS
ON IS ONE OF THE REASONS IS ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS. HOW WE CAN
ATTRACT TALENT TO OUR TO OUR
COMMUNITIES SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY DECLINED TO
SUPPORT THIS. BUT I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I WILL I'M
GOING TO JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FRESNO. IN HIS
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
BILL YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S FURTHER
INLAND PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT. HAVE BEEN
UNDERSERVED AND DISADVANTAGED
FOR DECADES AND DECADES FOR A
WHOLE VARIETY OF REASONS. AND
WHEN WE USE OUR GEOGRAPHY IS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO. REFERS
TO IT TO BENEFIT. OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES FRANKLY AND TO
BENEFIT THOSE WHO PURCHASE FROM
THE CONVENIENCE OF THEIR HOMES
IN THEIR OFFICES IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. USING THESE-
FACILITIES IN OUR GEOGRAPHY WE
ENCOURAGE CERTAIN BURDENS. IN
TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS
IN SOME CASES THAT ARE ALMOST
OVERWHELMING IN THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS IN THESE
BURDENS NEED TO BE OVERCOME AND
FRANKLY SALES TAX REVENUE HELPS
US DO JUST THAT SO. FOR THIS
BILL FOR THIS DAY I
UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
IN REGARDS TO THIS MEASURE
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I'M BEING I ALSO
OFFER A QUESTION PLEASE.
SENATOR GORE DO YOU ACCEPT
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
HOW DOES THIS BILL DIFFER
DIFFER FROM YOUR FIVE THIRTY
ONE THAT THE GOVERNOR VETOED.
THANK YOU SENATOR- THE PREVIOUS
BILL THAT YOU MENTIONED WOULD
HAVE BANNED ANY FUTURE DEALS
GOING FORWARD- TO TAKE PUBLIC
MONEY AND GO **** THE SIGHTING
OF- WHERE THAT INTERNET
TRANSACTION MAY HAVE OCCURRED.
IT WOULD HAVE PREVENTED ANY NEW
DEALS THIS BILL IS COMPLETELY
SILENT ON EXISTING DEALS AND
ANY FUTURE DEALS IT DOESN'T
SPEAK TO ANY AGREEMENT THAT A
CITY OR COUNTY COULD. UNDERTAKE
GOING FORWARD THIS BILL ONLY
DEALS WITH DATA THE RELEASE OF
DATA WHERE TAXES BEING
COLLECTED IN THE STATE. AND
THAT'S IT IT IS COMPLETELY
SILENT ON ANY OF THESE EXISTING
ARRANGEMENTS OR FUTURE
ARRANGEMENTS WHICH IS WAS THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILL YOU
MENTIONED VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ONE MORE QUESTION IF I MAY.
IT'S AS THE SENATOR WHO
REPRESENTS MORE OF A DISTRICT
WITH MORE WAREHOUSES ANY PLACE
ELSE IN THE STATE OR THE
COUNTRY. THIS YOUR CURRENT BILL
WOULD NOT TAKE AWAY THE SALES
TAX THAT WE ARE RECEIVING IN
THOSE CITIES AND ALLOCATED TO
THE CITIES WHERE THE ITEMS ARE
PURCHASE LET'S SAY YOU KNOW. WE
HAVE. A PLETHORA OF WAREHOUSES
WILL JUST USE AMAZON AS AN
EXAMPLE AND I PURCHASED AN ITEM
FROM AMAZON AND I LIVE IN
HILLSBORO. WITH THE SALES TAX
GO TO HILLSBOROUGH OR WOULD IT
STAY IN MY DISTRICT. THE BILL
IS COMPLETELY SILENT ON ANY
CHANGES ANY EXISTING IN A
RELATIONSHIP THAT A CITY OR A
CITY AND COUNTY HAS NEGOTIATED
WITH ANY PRIVATE COMPANY. THAT
WOULDN'T AFFECT ANY THERE WOULD
BE NO EFFECT- IN EXAMPLE THAT
YOU HAVE CITED THIS IS ONLY A
DATA- DISCLOSURE BILL NOT
AFFECTING THOSE EXISTING DEALS
OR ANY FUTURE DEALS OKAY SO
JUST COLLECTS DATA. AND IF I
WANTED TO RENEGOTIATE IF AMAZON
WANTED TO RENEGOTIATE WITH
SOMEONE COULD YOUR WHAT YOUR
BILL ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT AND
THEN ALLOW THE SALES TAX TO GO
SOMEPLACE ELSE YES IT DOESN'T
AFFECT ANY ANY FUTURE DEAL THAT
MIGHT BE NEGOTIATED. PLEASE
SILENT ON THIS BILL THIS BILL
SAYS THERE'S A DISPUTE ABOUT
WHO ARE THE WINNERS AND LOSERS
UNDER THE EXISTING
ARRANGEMENTS. AND SO THIS BILL
WOULD SAY RELEASE THE DATA ON
SALES TAX COLLECTION SO THESE
WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE FACTUAL.
ISSUES SO THERE COULD BE
DISAGREEMENTS ON FUTURE BILLS
OR NOT BUT AT LEAST THAT THE
DATA WOULD BE RELEASED BUT IT
WOULDN'T AFFECT ANY FUTURE
ARRANGEMENT AS YOU SO INDICATE.
OKAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPLANATION AND- I'M A LITTLE
LEERY I THINK I'M GONNA LAY OFF
TODAY AND IF IT GETS OFF THE
FLOOR COMES BACK TO US I MIGHT
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. THAT THANK
YOU FOR HELPING WITH THE
ANSWERS. THANK YOU. SENATOR ROB.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR SERVER LOCATION
WERE YOU TRIP TO QUESTION AT
YES- THE JUROR THANK YOU-
CENTER I THINK WE KNOW FROM
YOUR PRIOR EFFORTS YOUR VIEW ON
WINNERS AND LOSERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR SUBJECT BUT
TYPICALLY WE DO NOT DO BILLS
WITHOUT AN OBJECTIVE IN MIND SO.
WHAT IS YOUR OBJECTIVE WITH
RESPECT TO. THIS DATA ONCE IT
IS DISCLOSED CLEARLY. WE KNOW
WHICH CITIES COLLECT SALES TAX
SALES AND USE TAX AND- IN THE
AMOUNTS THAT THOSE. ITEMS ARE
COLLECTED THIS IS VERY
PARTICULAR EYES STATUS SO. WHAT
IS YOUR GOAL WITH RESPECT TO
THE USE OF THIS DATA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR. DURING
PREVIOUS DEBATES IN THIS
SUBJECT AREA THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF- OF A- DISPUTE AS TO
REALLY THE IMPACT OF THESE
BRADLEY BURNS AGREEMENTS
WHETHER THEY'RE UP AT ANY
IMPACT AT ANY SCALE TO BE ABOUT
SUCH GREAT CONCERN OR NOT. AND
THERE'S ALSO BEEN DISPUTES AS
TO WHO GAINS AND WHO LOSES WE
HEARD FROM THE SENATOR. FROM
FRESNO A MOMENT AGO WE TALKED
ABOUT THE ARRANGEMENTS THAT HAD
BEEN MADE IN HIS CITY BUT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE EFFECTS ON
NEIGHBORING CITIES AROUND
FRESNO AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND THE EFFECTS. OF THAT
BRADLEY BURNS- TAX SITE PUTTING
OFF OR NOT THAT MAY BE IN
EFFECT SO. IT'S REALLY TRYING
TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A DEBATE GOING FORWARD
IN THE SENATE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE GOVERNOR
AT LEAST WE CAN HAVE THE DEBATE
WITH THE FACTS BEING CLEARLY
NOW. WE COLLECT SALES TAX DATA
BUT IT'S NOT SEGMENTED IN A WAY
IN WHICH WE CAN AT LEAST HAVE
TRUTH BE TOLD ON WHO ARE THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN THE
STATE. IF ANY. THANK YOU ON MY
OWN TIME AS PRESIDENT ONE MORE
TIME YOUR OWN TIME. YOU KNOW
THE DIFFICULTY WITH THIS IT'S
ONE SIDED DATA. THE DATA IS NOT
COLLECTED IS THE IMPACT ON THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THE COST
TO OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THE COST
OF ROAD REPAIR. COSTS TO A
VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE HOUSING BRINGS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES MANY OF THEM
DISADVANTAGED AND SO THE TITLE
YOU WILL COLLECT WILL BE SALES
AND USE TAX. TAX DATA ON THE
IDENTITY OF PURCHASERS. BUT IT
DOES NOT REFER TO COLLECT DATA
ON THE IMPACT OF THE
PURCHASERS. THE PURCHASING THE
IMPACT OF THE WAREHOUSING. THAT
RESULTS IN THE PURCHASE IS
BEING MADE ON LOCAL COMMUNITIES
IN THESE DISADVANTAGED AREAS.
AND IT'S ONE SIDED SO I HOPE IN
ANY FUTURE EFFORTS THAT YOU
ENGAGE IN I HOPE THE AUTHOR.
TAKES THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
AND PERHAPS WE SHOULD COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DATA. ON THOSE-
THOSE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THE IMPACT ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO THE
SENATOR FOR RESPONDING TO MY
QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND I DIDN'T THINK THIS WOULD
BE AS CONTROVERSIAL AS IT IS
BECAUSE- IT IS A BILL SEEKING
MORE DATA. AND ACCORDING THE I.
R. S. AT A FEDERAL LEVEL WE
LOSE ONE TRILLION DOLLARS IN
UNCOLLECTED TAXES EACH YEAR
EACH YEAR. AND THIS PLAYS OUT
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS
WELL. AND SO WHILE I APPRECIATE
THAT WE WANT TO HAVE STRONG
ECONOMIES IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICTS AND THAT IS AN
IMPERATIVE FOR ALL OF US. WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO DO HERE IS GET
RID OF TAX ARBITRAGE. AND MORE
DATA IS HELPFUL THAT WE CAN'T
MAKE GOOD POLICY WE CAN'T MAKE
GOOD TAX POLICY WE CAN HAVE
GOOD TAX ENFORCEMENT. UNLESS WE
HAVE THAT DATA AND SO TO ME
THIS IS A NO BRAINER. THAT WE
SHOULD BE SEEKING MORE DATA TO
BETTER INFORM OUR DECISIONS TO
BETTER INFORM ABILITY TO
COLLECT TAXES. THAT CITIES AND
JURISDICTIONS HAVE LAWFULLY
PASSED SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTERED ALL OVER YOUR
BACK ADDRESS. THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME MR OUR PRESIDENT I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE SAID
ABOUT THE DATA THAT WE'RE GOING
TO COLLECT IN THE DATA THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO COLLECT I
WOULD JUST GIVE ONE EXAMPLE
WHEN AMAZON OPENED IN SAMBAR
DINO. WITHIN FIVE YEARS THE
ROADS HAVE BEEN DESTROYED FROM
ALL THE TRAFFIC GOING IN AND
OUT NOT JUST THE TRUCKS BUT
FRANKLY PEOPLE COMING NTO WORK
EVERY DAY THERE ARE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THE
CITY OF SAMBAR DINO HAD TO CUT
THEIR BUDGET. TO NON PROFITS BY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND I APOLOGIZE I DON'T
HAVE THE YEAR WAS ABOUT FOUR
YEARS AGO HAD TO CUT THE BUDGET
OF THEIR NONPROFIT SO MAYBE
GIVE THE NONPROFIT TURNING
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO REPAIR THE ROADS
THE DAMAGE THAT WAS DONE. SO I
JUST THINK THAT THE POINTS THAT
THE SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE
MAKES FOR INCREDIBLY VALID WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
COLLECTING ALL THE DATA. IS
THIS IS ABOUT TAXES AND MAKING
SURE THEY GO TO THE RIGHT PLACE
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU HAVE
THESE WAREHOUSES IN YOUR
DISTRICT IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
ALL THE TAXES SHOULD STAY THERE
BECAUSE YOU WERE THE ONES
PAYING THE PRICE YOU HAVE THE
AIR POLLUTION YOU HAVE THE
TRAFFIC YOU HAVE THE TRUCKS YOU
HAVE THE NOISE. YOU HAVE IT
TEARING UP YOUR CITIES SO THE
TAX BASE SHOULD STAY THERE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
COLLECTING DATA BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE GET ALL THE DATA
SO WE CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL. DESCRIPTIONS ARE
BASED CENTER FOR INTERNAL. YEAH
THIS IS JUST KIND. A FORMER
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND MAYOR-
WHEN WE LOOK TO ATTRACT
BUSINESSES IN OUR COMMUNITY-
FOR DEVELOPERS WHATEVER WE
OFTEN NEGOTIATE WITH THOSE
DEVELOPERS AND BUSINESSES. ON
CREATING IMPROVEMENTS AND WE
LOOK. DISCERNING AT WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE GOING TO BE TO OUR
ROADS ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER WE HAVE TO MOVE A FIRE
HYDRANT WHATEVER IT IS. AND WE
TIE THAT INTO THE DISCUSSION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NOT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. BY THOSE DEVELOPMENTS
AND SO. YOU KNOW PART OF THE
OWNER SHOULD BE ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. WHEN THEY
NEGOTIATE THOSE DEALS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY LOOK OUT FOR
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND CLEARLY
THE ROADS AND INFRASTRUCTURE IS
IMPORTANT SO. JUST A POINT ON
THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I AGREED WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TINO AS- KERN
COUNTY HAS A THE SAME THING
THAT THEY HAVEN'T SAMBAR DINO
LAND LAND OF THAT- NEEDS TO BE
USED FOR EITHER SOLAR PROJECT-
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS OR PLACES
WHERE- THESE FACILITIES THAT
ARE NEGOTIATED BY AGAIN UNLIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE AND- THE
CHAIR OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SAID A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NEGOTIATES THEM BUT
THERE'S ALSO THINGS LIKE TAX
INCENTIVES- I KNOW THAT THE
FACILITY THAT AMAZON LOCATED IN
KERN COUNTY JUST ACROSS FROM
THE AIRPORT IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
FACILITY. AS A DISTRIBUTION
CENTER- WAS IN YOU KNOW EXCUSED
OR- DIDN'T. HAVE TO PAY TAXES
FOR A CERTAIN LENGTH OF TIME IN
ORDER TO MOVE THAT FACILITY
THERE. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN A CASINO THAT SAYS
THAT YOU KNOW WE DO WE HAVE THE
ERROR MITIGATION ISSUES WE HAVE
THE- TRAFFIC ISSUES WE HAVE- A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT COME WITH
MAKING SURE THESE FACILITIES
HAVE LAND TO OPERATE IN. AND MY
CONCERN IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR TO BE ABLE TO GATHER
THIS DATA THE DATA IS GOOD AND
TRANSPARENT. BUT THEN DO YOU
pKERN COUNTY ONLY 3% OF THE
PURCHASE IS ACTUALLY GO THERE
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY COMING
FROM LOS ANGELES SO THEREFORE
THE TAX REVENUE SHOULD GO TO.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OR SOME
OTHER COUNTY. THE CONCERN I
HAVE THERE AS WELL AS A SET
KERN COUNTY BEING SUCH A LARGE
LAND MASS AREA WHERE WE HAVE
OPEN LAND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE IN
SAMBAR DINO. AND WE'RE WE SHARE
THAT COUNTY- FOR INSTANCE LIKE
THE SOLAR PROJECTS THAT I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE HAVE 51%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND THAT HELPS MEET THE
CLIMATE GOALS THE STATUS PUT
FORTH IN KERN COUNTY BUT WE GET
NO TAX BENEFIT FROM IT. SO WE
CAN'T HIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIXER LIBRARY STICKS ARE
SWIMMING POOLS. DO THE WATER
PARK THINGS FOR OUR KIDS
BECAUSE WE DON'T COLLECT TAX
REVENUE. AND IF THE INTENT OF
THE AUTHOR IS TO REMOVE- THE
TAX COLLECTION REVENUE THAT WE
GET FOR THE PURCHASERS THAT
PURCHASE FROM OUR DISTRICT.
WHERE THESE FACILITIES ARE AT.
AND I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE IT'S- IT IS DEVASTATING
FOR US AS A COMMUNITY. AGAIN IN
DECEMBER TO DINO IN KERN COUNTY
AREA EVEN IN TELERI COUNTY.
WHERE YOU HAVE. THE FACILITIES
THAT ARE LOCATED THERE BUT WE
GET NO BENEFIT FROM IT. IF THIS
BILL- IS THE INTENT TO LEAD TO
THE BILL THAT WOULD THAT DIED
LAST YEAR. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK- FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
IN ADDITION TO SENATOR DALLAS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
WELL I DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE
GOING TO GO DOWN THIS ROAD BUT
I'M GLAD WE ARE SO MOST OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SPEAKING TODAY
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. THE
IMPACTS OF THE COMMUNITY WHAT
DO YOU HAVE A DISTRIBUTION
CENTER AND I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS COMING ON A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN WE FOUGHT OVER
SALES TAX. ON EVERY TURN WITH
BETWEEN THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY'S. WHEN WE COME FROM A
DISTRICT WHERE YOU HAVE VERY
WIDE OPEN SPACES AND VERY FEW
PEOPLE IN MOST PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MY COMMUNITIES SURVIVE ON
A SALES TAX AND THEN. WE'VE
SEEN A TREND NOW WE HAVE THE
AMAZONS OF THE WORLD AND WE
HAVE THE COSCO'S AND WE HAVE
THESE. THE ABILITY TO.
DISTRIBUTE OW WHERE WE DIDN'T
HAVE BEFORE WE USED TO GO TO
THAT STORE BY THE ITEMS THAT
WERE THERE THE SALES TAX WAS
COLLECTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND THAT HELP PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR THOSE CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR STREETS
FOR. ALL THE THINGS THAT THAT
THEY PROVIDE. AND NOW WE SEE
THESE BIG DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
LIKE AMAZON AND THE OTHERS THAT
ARE LOCATED IN ONE AREA THAT
SELLS TAX GOES TO THAT ONE AREA
SO MY QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
IS- WILL THIS STUDY. TAKING A
COW SOME OF THOSE LOST REVENUES
FROM THE TRENDS OF CHANGING TO.
THE DISTRIBUTION WAY THAT WE'RE
DOING BUSINESS. CENTERED
LARGELY STREET. ADDRESS OF
COURSE ANYONE YET IN YOUR
CLOTHES WELL I JUST LIKE TO
HEAR IT A LITTLE MORE CLEARLY
AGAIN IF I COULD FROM THE GOOD
SENATOR MY QUESTION IS THAT
YOU'RE- YOU'RE TRYING TO.
RETAIN DATA AND MOST OF HOWEVER
TODAY'S PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHAT WOULD THE IMPACT BE FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY FOR THEIR BIG
FOR THEIR DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SALES TAX HAS BEEN LOST TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
HAD A STORY FOR THE MERCHANDISE
WAS WAS GOING TO THE STORE YOU
COLLECT THE TAX AT THE STORE
AND THAT HELP SUPPORT. THE SALT
SMALL GREASE IS THAT INCLUDED
IN THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THE FOCUS THANK YOU GET A GOOD
SENATOR THE FOCUS ON THIS BILL
IS- AT THE YOU KNOW WE COLLECT
THE SALES TAX DATA. BUT IT'S
NOT COLLATED IT'S NOT SEGMENTED
IN A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. HOW THE BRADLEY
BURNS TAX. AFFECTS WHERE WHERE
THE MONEY IS END UP GOING. ON
VERSES WHERE THE PEOPLE HAVE
MADE THE ORDERS FROM SELF I
THINK IT WILL AND WHAT I THINK
IT WILL TO SOME DEGREE WILL
ENLIGHTEN THE QUESTION THAT
YOU'RE ASKING- I CAN'T BE
EXACTLY SURE THAT IT WILL BUT-
IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO TAKE THAT
EXISTING TAX DATA THAT WE
COLLECT. AND MAKING SURE WE
CANNOT IDENTIFY THE CITY IN
WHICH- THE FOLKS- ORDERED IT.
FOR COLLECTED IT. AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DISCERN
THE BILL AGAIN IT DOESN'T
AFFECT ANY OF THE ANY EXISTING.
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
BUT IT IS TRYING TO CREATE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ON THAT-
TAX. CONSEQUENCES TO THE
BENEFIT. OR DISADVANTAGE OF
THAT OF ALL OF US. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
ADDITION THE SCRIPTURAL GREAT
SCENE NINE- GLACIER WHICH A LOT
CLOSER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
YOU KNOW I LOVE THE SPIRITED
DEBATE IN THIS SUBJECT AREA AND
THIS IS MY- THIRD TIME WITH
ENGAGING IN IT AS AN AUTHOR OF
A BILL THAT TOUCH A TOUCH THIS
AREA AND IT'S A IT TOUCHES IT
IT'S A SENSITIVE POINT BECAUSE-
WHAT'S BECOME CLEAR WITHOUT
REAL DATA TO RELY UPON IT CLEAR
TO ME AT LEAST IS THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN WINNERS AND LOSERS.
IN THE TAX GAMES CALLED BRADLEY
BURNS AND WHERE IT'S DESIGNATED
AS COLLECTED AND- AND IT'S
ALLOWED SOME OF THE BIGGEST
CORPORATIONS IN THE WORLD TO
MANIPULATE OUR TAX CODE NOW WE
MAY DISAGREE OR AGREE ABOUT THE
EFFECT OF THAT. AND WE'VE HAD
SOME SPIRITED DEBATES FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT THOSE WHO FEEL
THAT THAT THOSE THOSE
ARRANGEMENTS WORK TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
WINNERS AND LOSERS. AND SO I'M
ASKING IN THIS BILL BY THE WAY
IS POLICE HAVE THE DATA SO WE
CAN HAVE A MORE THOROUGH
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD IF
THERE'S ANY PROPOSAL. TO CHANGE
IT. I WANT TO KNOW ONE LAST
THING WHICH IS THAT. WHEN
COMMUNITIES NEGOTIATE WITH
THESE COMPANIES. THEY'RE NOT
NEGOTIATING WITH THEIR MONEY.
THEY'RE ENGAGING WITH OUR MONEY
THE PUBLIC'S MONEY AND WHEN
THEY AGREED TO GIVE MONEY BACK
TO THESE CORPORATIONS THAT
THEY'RE GIVING BACK OUR MONEY.
AND SO IF YOU'RE ORDERING FROM
THE INTERNET. FROM LOS ANGELES
PARTS OF THE BAY AREA MANY
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
YOUR MONEY THAT'S BEING
NEGOTIATED NOT. NOT YOUR
COMMUNITIES BUT LET'S AT LEAST
GET THE DATA OUT THERE. I THINK
WE'LL ALL BENEFIT FROM IT WILL
HAVE MORE THE SPIRITED DEBATE I
FEEL LIKE IT'S BEEN A GREAT
BIPARTISAN DEBATE WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY NICE BUT LET'S DO IT
WITH A BETTER FACTUAL BASIS
THAN WE HAVE TODAY WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I WROTE.
THANK YOU HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE I'M SEVENTY
THREE. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I FACE NO BACKER. HI FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD. CABRERA
CORTESE FIVE DALLY I DONT HI
THERE ALSO HI A COMMON. PLEASE
SIR HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA. THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW A
VOGUE HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH. RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG HI WHAT KIND OF
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI.
PLEASE REMOVE THE CALL. I'M
SUPER. PART CALL THE ABSA
MEMBERS MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE UPS MEMBERS MY BALLS.
INFERRED. BY ADAM. EGGMAN HER
TADO. CAN LONGER. LABOUR
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN ROSS. FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVES
SENATOR. ARE YOU STILL AT BACK
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FOUR BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO RESOURCE CONSERVATION CENTER
GLITTER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
A- A SIMPLER AND PERHAPS A-
MORE EMBRACING MEASURE TO
REPRESENT YOU THIS WOULD THAT
SB EIGHT OH FOUR WOULD CREATE A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CENTER TO
TRAIN FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. IN FORESTRY IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ACCORDING
TO CAL FIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE AN ESTIMATED FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION ACRES BURNED DUE
TO WILDFIRE. THESE FIRES
DAMAGED OVER TEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES BECAUSE THIRTY THREE
FATALITIES. THIS COMES AFTER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASONS THAT WERE THE DEADLIEST
AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN STATE
HISTORY. WITH COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THE CENTER
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL OF
EXPANDING THE WORKFORCE AND
IMPLEMENTING A VEGETATION
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT PLAN- THIS
PROGRAM WOULD NOT ONLY WORK
TOWARDS REDUCING THE TOLL OF
WILDFIRES- BUT IT WOULD DIE.
CREATE A PATHWAY TO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
COMPLETED CONFINEMENT IN JAILS
AND STATE INSTITUTIONS THEREBY
REDUCING RECIDIVISM RATES WHICH
THAT WE KNOW ARE IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO. I WANT TO A CLOSING JUST
THANK MY CO AUTHORS THE CENTERS
FROM MENLO PARK FROM SALINAS
FROM SAN DIEGO FROM HEALDSBURG
BERKELEY AND SAN FRANCISCO. I
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK THE
PRO TEM. AND THE CULTURES OF
OUR WILDFIRE SENATE PACKAGE THE
SENATORS FROM HEALDSBURG IN
BALDWIN PARK FOR THEIR WORK
WITH ME ON THIS LEGISLATION.
AND THEIR INCLUSION OF IT IN
THE SENATE WILDFIRE. PACKAGE
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR OF
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND- SB
EIGHT OH FOUR. IT YOU KNOW AND
A LOT OF US ARE AWAY FROM OUR
FAMILIES AND I RE I REMEMBER A
TEXT I GOT FROM MY HUSBAND IT
SAYS HEADED TO THE RANCH-
THERE'S A FIRE. AND THEN ABOUT
AN HOUR AND A HALF LATER HE
SAID THE RANCH IS ON FIRE. AND
SO AFTER I LEFT HER IMMEDIATELY
WENT THERE IN TO SEE- AS SEVEN
GENERATIONS AND FAMILY RANCH
JUST UP IN FLAMES WAS A
HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE BUT AGAIN
ALL THE WILDFIRES THAT TOOK
PLACE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE JUST AWFUL
THIS PAST YEAR. AND I WENT DOWN
AND TO THE ROAD IT'S ABOUT A
MILE AND HALF OFF THE ROAD TO
THE RANCH AND THERE WERE FIRE
CREWS- THAT WITHIN BECOME THE
INMATE CREWS. IN THESE
INDIVIDUALS WORKED ALL NIGHT-
ON SET WITH FULL GEAR I MEAN
SOME OF THEM ARE LIKE WHEN A
HUNDRED TEN POUNDS CARRYING A
HUNDRED POUNDS OF WEIGHT. AND
WORKING ALL NIGHT LONG TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FIRE DIDN'T
SPREAD ANY FURTHER AND THEN A
LOUD AND THEY WORKED REALLY
REALLY HARD AND SO TO ALLOW
THEM SOME TYPE OF BENEFIT. TO
GETTING GAINFULLY EMPLOYED
AFTER THEIR TIME IN THE
WILDFIRE SECTION AS AN INMATE
IS JUST ADMIRABLE AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR IT BECAUSE I
THINK THE BEST. SOLUTION TO-
COMBATING RECIDIVISM AND PEOPLE
RETURNING TO PRISON IS A JOB.
THAT BENEFITS THEM AND THEIR
FAMILY. DID THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ENGINE NINE CIRCLES
WHICH ARE CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT WANT TO THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR. FROM BAKERSFIELD
HER KIND REMARKS THIS IS A WIN
WIN FOR ALL THAT THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO US THESE DAYS-
PROTECTING OUR FORESTS FROM
FIRE- HELPING THOSE WHO I NEED
OUR HELP. HI EIGHT METERS IN AN
EFFORT THAT MEMBERSTHAT
UNDERTOOK. THAT THEY CREATED A
SIMILAR-CENTER FOR FIRE IN
VENTURA COUNTY THIS WOULD GET
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA A SIMILAR
OPPORTUNITY IN THE AREA FORCE
MAAGEMENT WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS OR ANY OBJECTION
FOR USE IN A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS MEASURE. HEARING
TEAM NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. FALL
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
GONZALO SHE IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. CONSULT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ONE OF MY FAVORITE BILLS SENATE
BILL FOUR WHICH IS A CRITICAL
MEASURING CLOSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE BOTH DURING AND AFTER
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ACROSS THE STATE IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES
OF HOW THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AS
PREVENTING CALIFORNIANS FROM
ENGAGING IN CRITICAL DIGITAL
ACTIVITIES. WHETHER IT'S A
STUDENTS HAVING TO GO TO TACO
BELL TO GET A WIFI CONNECTION
OR OLDER CALIFORNIANS WHO DO
NOT HAVE FAST EOUGH INTERNET
WE ALL KNOW THE STORIES THE
BILL WILL REDEFINE THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA ADVANCE
SERVICES FUND TO ENABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. TO BE
BUILT IN UNSERVED AREAS THIS
CHANGING CRITERIA WILL HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AN
INTERNET SURPRISE SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF ALL SIZES FOR TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS. AT THE SAME
TIME INVEST IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY INTERNET
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'LL ALSO
STABILIZE THE FUNDING SOURCE
FOR THE ADVANCE SERVICES FUND
BY EXTENDING THE SUNSET ON THE
PROGRAM AND SURCHARGE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS WELL
CAPPING THE FORMER PERCENTAGE
BASE FEE TO ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. THIS IS
A FORMULA. SIMILAR TO OUR
EXISTING NINE ONE ONE SURCHARGE
THE BILL WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
PART FUNDING GRANTS TO UNSERVED
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO BUILD
HIGH SPEED FIBRE BROADBAND
NETWORKS AT MINIMUM SPEEDS. OF
ONE HUNDRED MEGABYTES DOWNLOAD
AND TWENTY MEGABYTES PER SECOND
UPLOAD- IT HAS A DIVORCE
DIVERSE COALITION OF SUPPORTERS
OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EDUCATION ADVOCATES
LABOR UNIONS SMALL INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. THAT NEED OUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BY BOAT
N. AS BEFORE TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ONCE IN FROM
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTERED
DOLLAR. THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION AND WHEN I
SAY THAT BECAUSE SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT IT'S VERY
RULE HAS BERRIES LITTLE
BROADBAND AND HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
HAS WORKED IN THIS AREA FOR THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS. THE PRESIDING
OFFICER MISTER SENATOR BRADFORD
HOW TO BUILD A FEW YEARS BACK
TO PUT MONEY INTO GET BROADBAND
TO INNER CITY HOUSING PROJECTS.
NOT DELIVERED HE'S DOING
ANOTHER BILL TO GET THAT TRY TO
GET THAT DONE I WORKED ON A B.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE. BUT
SENATOR COPULAR- AND SME
MEMBERS IN THE OTHER HOUSE WE
GOT THAT DONE WE PUT THE MONEY
THERE. VERY LITTLE THAT MONEY'S
GOT TO THE GROUND OR IT'S BEEN
SPENT AND WE DON'T GET THE
SERVICES THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. IT'S NOT
THAT IT REQUIRES THAT IT THAT
IT IT DOES THE FUNNY PART OF IT
IT DOES ALL THE THINGS WE WANT
TO DO. EXCEPT FOR. FIGURE OUT A
WAY THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
GET IT TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES. THIS
HUGE PIECE THE C. P. U. C. IT
IS NOT FUNCTIONING IN THE
MANNER IT SHOULD. WE SHOULD
HAVE TO RUN TEN BILLS OR EIGHT
BILLS ARE SIX MILLS. OVER THE
YEARS AND NOT GET THE SERVICES
RESCUE FOR. IN IN OUR SUB TWO
COMMITTEE ACT I WANT TO SHARE
THAT TO. THE SENATOR FROM-
HILLSBOROUGH. SHE SAID IT
PERFECTLY THE UTILITIES ARE NOT
GOING TO USE THIS THEY DON'T
USE IT THERE'S BEEN ONE UTILITY
THAT USED. THE PRODUCT THE
FUNDS ONLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
FORCED TO USE IT DURING A
TRANSITION. WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO EEP PUTTING MONEY
INTO THE SYSTEM AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THE SERVICES WE
HAVE TO COME UP WITH A WAY THAT
SAYS. THE UTILITIES ARE GOING
TO. USE THESE FUNDS AND WE WILL
PAY FOR THOSE. CONSTITUENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE SERVICE ARE ARE VERY
LIMITED SERVICE. AND IN MANY
CASES. IN MY AREA THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY SERVICE AT ALL NO CELL
SERVICE MANY OF YOU. ONE OR
FORTY TWO OR A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
AND YOU UNDERSTOOD. WHAT WE'RE
FACING. AND IF YOU'RE IN IT SO
I HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM. BUT
THE SENATOR FROM GARDENING
HOUSE EXCEPT FOR HE ACTUALLY
HAS CELL SERVICE IN HIS AREAS
BUT HIS BUDDIES PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD IT IN MY AREA WE HAVE
ZERO. AND UNTIL WE ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE CPUC AND
UTILITIES THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO HELP US OTHER THAN
PUT A LOT OF MONEY IN THE POT.
IT'LL GO TO NONPROFITS. THAT WE
CAN'T EVEN TRACK THE FUNDING.
TO FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I REGRETFULLY
HAVE TO. OPPOSE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IS NOT
GOING TO GIVE YOU WHAT YOU WANT.
WE WANT SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE DISADVANTAGED. OR DON'T
HAVE IT BECAUSE THE TOPOGRAPHY
AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
THERE THIS WILL NOT GET US
THERE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR BORDERS. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE THOSE BILLS. WHERE YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING. I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO-
BUT THE ACUITY OF THE KNEE OF
OUR NEEDS- IS SO STRONG. IN A
PERFECT WORLD I BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE INVESTED
IS USING ITS ONETIME UNEXPECTED
REVENUE TO BE INVESTING IN
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE- I
DON'T THINK IT'S VERY OFTEN
THEN WE HAVE A SURPLUS WE CALL
IT THAT OF THIS NATURE. AND
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC IS THE INEQUITY AND
THE TECH DIVIDE ACROSS THE
STATE. I REPRESENT- RURAL AREAS
FOOTHILL AND MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES- KIDS COULDN'T GO
TO SCHOOL GO TO CLASS- IN THE
DISTANCE- FORMAT BECAUSE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAD ALL OF
US HAVE SOME EXAMPLE OF THIS.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER WE
SHOULD BE USING THE FUNDING
FORMAT HERE OR BE USING ANOTHER
FUNDING FORMAT. I'LL LEAVE THAT
TO THE LEADER- DISCUSSION IF
SOMEONE WISHES TO EXPLORE IT
FURTHER BUT MAYBE A QUICK
QUESTION OF. IS UNSERVED AREAS.
MY QUESTION IS THAT BASED ON
POPULATION IN THESE UNDERSERVED
AREAS OR IS IT IN A MORE QUAL
DISTRIBUTION ACROSS THE STATE
AND WHAT TYPE OF- FORMAT CAN
YOU EXPLAIN HOW THAT MIGHT BE
SICK BECAUSE WE'VE CHECKED
QUESTION YES I DO OKAY THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- IN FUN SERVED
IS AN EQUAL- TERM SO NOT OVER
GEOGRAPHIC GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION
AS WAS USED BEFORE OR IS
CURRENTLY- BUT IF YOU ARE ON
SERVICE COMPLETELY NO INTERNET.
SERVICE WEATHER REGARDLESS OF
WHERE YOU'RE AT IN THE IN THE-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND UNKNOWN
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD THAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF UNCERTAIN AND
THAT'S WHERE SO IT IS IT HAS A
NEXUS WITH POPULATION HERE IN
YEARS ONE OF MY CONCERNS MAYBE
YOU CAN ALLEVIATE THEM DIRECTS
ONE NATION. IS THAT WE ALL HAVE
UNDERPERFORMING COMMUNITIES IN
OUR DISTRICT IF YOU HAVE A
HIGHER DENSITY POPULATION IN
THE SPECIFIC AREA AND YOU CAN
SERVICE THOSE FOLKS MORE EASILY
WILL THIS ORGANICALLY OR
DELIBERATELY THOSE DOLLARS IN
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
FLOW TO THAT AREA BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA BE SERVICING MORE
PEOPLE ON A ON A POPULATION
BASIS THAN YOU WOULD IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SCENARIO WHERE-
YOU. HAVE- LESS DENSITY.
THROUGH THE- AT MR PRESIDENT TO
YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION AND NO THIS IS
WHAT IS CURRENTLY THE PROBLEM.
IS THAT- THE UNSERVED AREAS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT RECEIVING ANY
FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU
ALL KNOW. AND SO THIS WOULD. BE
ABLE TO. COMPLETELY BLOW THAT
UP AND LOOK AT IT IN A WAY THAT
WE CAN START SERVING THESE
COMMUNITIES BY PROMOTING
COMPETITION SO INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF ALL LEVELS. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHICH CURRENTLY DO
NOT HAVE. A DIRECT ACCESS TO
THESE FUNDS AS WELL SO THIS
CREATES A MORE EQUITABLE
PROCESS I THINK IN AND- YOUR%
POINT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
EVERYONE SERVED- IF THERE AND
SERVE THOSE ARE PRIORITY FIRST
IN THE UNDERSERVED WHICH WE
KNOW. EXIST IN LA COUNTY AS
THEY EXIST IN CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE SIX ONE
SPEEDS WE NEED TO BE AT LEAST
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT THIS
IS ASKING. FOR EVEN MORE AND
IT'S A BIPARTISAN DISCUSSION IN
THE FEDERAL AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THEY WANT A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED WE'RE STILL TALKING
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TO SUPPORT THIS- IBM I HEAR THE
CENTER FROM BIEBER THE IN HIS
COMMENTS I THINK WE'RE WELL
TAKEN. OF WE JUST HAVE TO KEEP
PUSHING AT IT THAT'S THAT'S ALL
I COULD THINK OF AND AS CHAIR
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS WE MADE
THIS A PRIORITY. TO KEEP
INSISTING ON INSISTING ON
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS
ARE HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE
ACCESS- THE PANDEMIC DIDN'T-
CREATE A PROBLEM BUT IT SURE
DID EXPOSE. THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
AMONGST OUR RESIDENTS INCLUDING
AND ESPECIALLY OUR CHILDREN WHO
COULDN'T WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP IN SCHOOL. BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF CONNECTIVITY
BECAUSE OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
SO. WE NEED TO AND WE WILL DO
BETTER AS BEFORE IS A GOOD STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTIONS AND I
THANK THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SCENE
NINE HOURS SENATOR DOLLAR.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SORRY I
JUST WANT TO ADD ONE MORE THING
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I WANTED TO. SHARE
SCENARIO WITH YOU. EIGHTEEN T.
HAS A LINE THAT GOES ALL THE
WAY. TO WASHINGTON UP TO FIVE
AND ALONG THE RAILROAD TRACKS
GOES RIGHT TO THE COMMUNITY OF
DUNSMUIR. AND AM NOT SHASTA.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE I
CAN THROW A ROCK FROM THE TOWN
TO THE RAILROAD TRACK BUT I
DON'T GET TO ACCESS IT BECAUSE
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO. WE TALK
ABOUT. BUILT OUT AREAS. WE WANT
TO EXTEND ON OF THOSE BUILT OR
IS ALREADY BUT THEY'RE OWNED BY
PRIVATE COMPANIES. AND THOSE
PRIVATE COMPANIES CHOOSE NOT TO
USE THESE FUNDS. TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES AND YOU TALK ABOUT.
THE CO THE PANDEMIC AND A
PERSONALLY HAPPENED TO ME IN MY
IN MY OWN FAMILY RIGHT I HAD TO
GET I I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE I
HAVE A DISH. ON THE TOP OF
MINE. SHOP AT MY PROPERTY WHERE
I. PERFORMED THE COMES OFF OF
THE WATER TOWER IN TOWN WHICH
IS SEVEN MILES AWAY TO GET
INTERNET SO MY KIDS CAN BARELY
GET ON AND WORK. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE'S A LOT
OF INFRASTRUCTURE OUT ALREADY
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO TAP INTO IT SO WHAT WE DO IS
WE TAKE THESE FUNDS. AND WE
HAVE TO BUILD AROUND THEM. WE
DON'T GET THE TOP OFF OF WHAT'S
ALREADY THERE AND EXTEND OUT
THAT LAST MILE. OR THAT. DIDN'T
MAKE THE MIDDLE MILE. THAT'S
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS THAT IT DOESN'T.
USE EXISTING STRUCTURE WE HAVE
TO BUILD ALL NEW ND YOU CAN'T
AFFORD TO DO IT. ONE LAST
POINT. DIGITAL THREE NINETY
FIVE WAS A FEDERAL. AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT CAME IN. AND IT DID
THREE NINETY FIVE ALL THE WAY
UP THE BACKSIDE OF THIS YEAR'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
TIME THERE'S ONE PERSON LOOKED
UP TO IT. THAT IS THE PROBLEM
WITH THESE TYPES OF LEGISLATION
THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS
DOING THE SAME THING EXPECTING
A DIFFERENT OUTCOME WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THE SAME OUTCOME. UNTIL WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE SAY
HEY. WE WANT TO GET TO THAT
PERSON THAT'S IN THE MIDDLE
MILE AND LAST MILE. AND
UTILITIES WE'RE GONNA PAY FOR
BUT YOU GOTTA LOVE TOOK IN YOUR
SYSTEM. AS IF WE HAD IF WE GO
THE OTHER ROUTE WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET THERE. THAT'S
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THIS WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO DO WHAT
GOVERNMENT ALWAYS DOES WE HAVE
A PROBLEM WE JUST KEEP THROWING
MORE MONEY AT IT. BUT WE NEED
TO ACTUALLY. SO YOU SEE WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S NOT A IT'S
NOT A PROBLEM MONEY IT'S A
PROBLEM OF THE POLICY. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS I WANT TO I WANT TO GIVE
THE MONEY TO GO DO IT. BUT I
KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THERE. AND WE NEED TO FIX IT WE
NEED TO GO SIT DOWN THE TELCOS
ESSAY. AND THE CPUC AND SAY.
TELL US WHAT WE NEED TO GET
THERE AND WE'LL FIND IT. BUT
WE'RE DOING AT THE BACK WAY
WE'RE GOING WE'RE GIVEN THE
MONEY. AND WE'RE NOT GETTING
WHAT WE DESERVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. I SEE NO MORE MMHM MIKED
UP SENATOR GONZALES WHICH ARE
TOO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST RESPECT ALL
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE BROUGHT
FORWARD ESPECIALLY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIEBER I WAS HAPPY TO BE
IN HIS. BACKYARD ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO AND SAW THE BROADBAND
ISSUES MYSELF AND SPOKE TO MANY
OF HIS CONSTITUENTS AS MINE I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES SO I THINK
WE'RE SEEING THE ISSUE CLEARLY
IN DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIES BUT
IT'S ALL THE SAME YOU'RE EITHER
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED YOU
HAVE TO STOP TALKING ABOUT THE
PAST TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE THIS
IS A DIFFERENT MODEL AGAIN TO
PROMOTE COMPETITION. TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
OPTIONS IN IT AND FINALLY
INCREASE THE SPEEDS FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA FAMILY SO FOR THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FARM THIRTY
SEVEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BASICS NO BACKER. I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE
OR TEN THIRTY FIVE DALLY NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES. NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN OCHO ABODE.
PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA HI ROTH
I RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE V. FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NO FROM SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THEM TO MEMBERS.
PORGES MELINDA'S. NIELSEN
CONTROL OF BOTH. I AMBERG. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE ON THE
URGENCY AUGUST THIRTY ONE NOTE
FIVE ON THE MEASURE NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO FALL I AM
SEVENTY SIX THAT SENATOR DORADO
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM
SOONER. I BELIEVE SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
TORONTO AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDICAL SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A BILL THAT WILL
INCLUDE SENIORS AGES SIXTY AND
UP. IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
MEETING INCOME REQUIREMENTS
REGARDLESS OF STATUS. THESE ARE
CALIFORNIANS OTHERWISE QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM MAKING LESS
THAN SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. BUT ARE CURRENTLY
BARRED FROM ACCESSING THESE
BASIC MEDICAL SERVICES SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR DOCUMENTATION
STATUS. DESPITE THE TREMENDOUS
ADVANCES TO REDUCE THE RATE OF
UNINSURED CALIFORNIANS DOWN TO
HISTORIC LOW SIX POINT EIGHT
PERCENT. SINCE A. B. A. C. H.
THE UNINSURED RATES AMONG
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXCEEDINGLY HIGH. THEY ARE
BARRED EVEN FROM PURCHASING
HEALTHCARE ON THE EXCHANGE AND
THEY HAVE THE SMALLEST
PERCENTAGE OF EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HEALTH CARE. MORE THAN HALF OF
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
PART OF MIXED STATUS FAMILIES.
A PARENT OR GRANDPARENT CAN
TAKE THE CHILD A GRANDCHILD TO
SEE THE DOCTOR WHEN THEY'RE
SICK BUT THE PARENT OR
GRANDPARENT CANNOT DO THE SAME
FOR THEMSELVES. ALMOST TWO
THIRDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LIVED IN THE
U. S. FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW LOW INCOME
ADULTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
EMERGENCIES BUT NOT. DOCTOR
VISITS TO GET PREVENTATIVE CARE
FOR CONDITIONS SUCH AS ASTHMA
DIABETES OR HEART CONDITION.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT- CAN BE TREATED. AND
CANNIBAL IT HIGHER COSTS IN THE
SYSTEM AND AVOID SUFFERING.
THAT MEANS THEY RELY ON
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND LAST RESORT
CARE WHEN THEIR CONDITION
ESCALATES TO A POINT OF CRISIS
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT. ONE
DOCUMENT DOES CONTRIBUTE OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
AND STATE TAXES. TO FUND
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE YET THEY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM ACCESSING THE
LIFESAVING SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THAT THEIR TAX MONIES HELP
FUND. I'VE TALKED TO NUMEROUS
MEN AND WOMEN WERE WORK SO HARD
IN OUR STATE AND OUR MEMBERS OF
THE HEALTH FOR ALL COALITION
MEMBERS LIKE MR VARGAS A
SEVENTY SIX YEAR OLD AFFECTED
COMMUNITY MEMBER. WHO COLLECTS
RECYCLABLES TO PROVIDE FOR
HIMSELF AND HIS WIFE TO
SURVIVE. LET ALONE BE ABLE TO
AFFORD ANY KIND OF HEALTH CARE.
MR GARCIA'S FATHER HELD OFF
FROM OING TO THE DOCTOR WHEN
HE BROKE HIS ARM AT WORK
FEARING THE UNEXPECTED HOSPITAL
COSTS WOULD DEVASTATE THE
FAMILIES ALREADY HARD ECONOMIC
SITUATION. INSTEAD CHOOSING TO
MAKE A HOMEMADE SPLINT IN IN TO
GO BACK TO WORK TO PROVIDE FOR
HIS FAMILY. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED AND
EXACERBATED HOW DEVASTATING THE
LACK OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS IS
AMONGST THE MOST VULNERABLE.
THESE ARE NOT STATISTICS THEY
ARE CALIFORNIANS WE SHOULD
EXTEND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO
ALL UNINSURED CALIFORNIANS. I
PROPOSE THE NEXT STEP SHOULD BE
OUR SENIORS. THIS IS ONE
IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE ACCESS
TO NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
THAT IS LONG OVERDUE ESPECIALLY
IN THE MIDST OF OUR PANDEMIC I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
OF. HEARING TINA AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FALL I'M SEVENTY SIX. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASE NO
BACKER. I PORCHES NO BRADFORD
HI BYRON I CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD I TORONTO HI AIKMAN I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROSS. NO
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI LYNN MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN
NEWMAN I NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOGUE. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO
HI ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG RIGHT I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW
HIM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. GLAZER CAN LONGER I
MELINDA'S MAN. NIELSEN. MARCH
TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS REMOVING
ON THE FALL I'M SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR JONES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES. SENATOR JOHN
TOWARDS YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT DID A GREAT JOB TODAY
SHARE ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
MEMBERS THIS IS A VERY FINE
BILL BOTH FIGURATIVELY AND
ACTUALLY. SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY SEVEN CREATES A NARROWLY
TAILORED REGISTRATION PROGRAM
FOR COMPETITION OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES WITHOUT THIS BILL- HV
COMPETITIONS IN PRACTICE
WRITING WILL BE PUT TO AN END
ON CALIFORNIA LANDS AT A GREAT
COST TO LOCAL CAN- COMMUNITIES
ECONOMIES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
FUNDING. IN ORDER TO SAVE A LOT
OF SPORT WITH A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL CREATES A
REGISTRATION PROGRAM UNDER THE
PARKS DEPARTMENT. THE BILL IS
SO NARROWLY TAILORED IT WILL
ELIMINATE AN ESTIMATED 93% OF
COMPETITION VEHICLES. AND WHILE
THE OPPOSITION CLAIMS THAT THIS
BILL WILL LEAD TO AN EXPANSIVE-
REACH ME USE THIS BUILD TASKS A
CAR WITH CREATING A WRITING
SCHEDULE TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
AIR EMISSIONS GOALS ARE NOT
IMPACTED. DESPITE OPPOSITION'S
CLAIMS IT IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO IMAGINE A
SCENARIO WHERE KERR WOULD ALLOW
FOR A MORE EXPANSIVE- HV USE.
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON MULTIPLE
FACETS OF THE STATE THE BILL
ENJOYS STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
OAG COMMUNITY. BUSINESSES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS S.
P. TWO TWENTY SEVEN RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
POLICY COMMITTEES AND HAS
SEVERAL BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS
BOTH HERE IN THE SENATE AND IN
THE ASSEMBLY I ASKED HERE I
VOTE. ON TWO TWENTY SEVEN TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HOON JI NINE
MONTHS AFTER POLICE CHOLERA.
ALAN ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BAIT
I BACKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM I
COURTESY I DALLY. FIVE DOT FIVE
DURAZO NO EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROVE. HI HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. I HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER NOPE LAYERED. LLEVA
I WILL MOAN NO MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH I CAN.
BORTZ AND TINA. HI RALPH. HI
RUBIO I SCANNER NO STERN. NO
AMBERG HI BY CASTING NO WINNER
NO WILKE HI. COMMENTATOR PLEASE
CALL AFTER MEMBERS. ALAN GLAZER.
NO GONZALEZ. LAYERED MELINDA'S
NIELSEN PAN. VICE TWENTY SIX
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEMS SEVENTY EIGHT THAT
SENATOR- BERKEY IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO CIVIL ACTIONS. FOR THE
NUMBER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- BEFORE ABRAHAM LINCOLN
WAS PRESIDENT HE WAS A GREAT
TRIAL LAWYER IF YOU WALKED INTO
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S COURTROOMS
TODAY HE WOULD BE. QUITE
COMFORTABLE BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST
EXACTLY THE SAME AS IT WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS YEARS
AGO. THE BILL THAT I HAVE S. B.
TWO FOUR ONE PROVIDE SOME VERY
SIMPLE. AND SMALL CHANGES TO
COURTROOM PROCESS AND PROCEDURE
AND PRE COURTROOM PROCESS AND
PROCEDURE ONE IT. PROVIDES
SUFFICIENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH RESPECT OUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS AND TWO IF PERMITS
REMOTE WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
VIRTUALLY IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES OR DRIVE A- THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
TEAM NINE MINUTES THE ODDS
SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I RISE TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL IN OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAD-
MUCH TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC
OF FROM TRIAL COURT EMPLOYEES
CORE REPORTERS INTERPRETERS-
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFICULTIES THEY HAVE BEEN
HEARING UNDERSTANDING AND
TRANSLATING WITNESS TESTIMONY
REMOTELY DURING THE PANDEMIC-
AND AGAIN THERE WERE MANY MANY-
DIFFERENT- ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED RAISED- WE CAN'T TAKE
FOR GRANTED THAT THERE ARE
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN THE
HALLS. OF OUR COURT ROOMS OF
THE POOR PEOPLE FOR THE ELDERLY
FOR NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS AND MY
CONCERN IS THAT THESE
DISPARITIES WILL ONLY BE WORSE
AND- BY THE TECHNOLOGY IF WE
DON'T HAVE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
I HOPE THAT WE CAN TAKE THE
TIME. TO SORT THESE OUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE BEFORE MAKING
UP MORE LONG TERM AND PERMANENT
DECISIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN
CHINO AND CENTER OVER WHICH ARE
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
YET YES- COURT REPORTERS PLAYER
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
TRIAL PROCESS- THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE RECORD THAT THEY KEEP
MAINTAINING TRANSCRIBE IS
ACCURATE. THE LAWYERS ARE EVEN
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ACCURACY OF THE TRIAL RECORD AS
IS THE JUDGE. OF THIS BILL
SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR SOME
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY REMOTELY-
IT SAVES LOTS OF MONEY SAVES
LOTS OF TIME AND IT SAVES LOTS
OF FOLKS WHO WOULD HAVE TO MISS
WORK FOR EXAMPLE TO COME AND
TESTIFY ABOUT A MINISTERIAL.
ACT IT SAVES THEM THE LOST
WAGES THAT THEY MIGHT INCUR IF
THEY HAD TO COME TO COURT- IT
ALSO SPEEDS UP THE PROCESS I
UNDERSTAND THAT COURT REPORTERS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE ACTORS
SEE THE RECORD. BUT THIS BILL
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY THEY ARE PRESENT IN
THE COURT ROOM THEY NEED NOT BE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
ELIMINATED FROM THE PROCESS
ENSURES THAT THEIR PRESENT THE
COURT ROOM AND SHOULD THERE BE
IN. A MOMENT WHEN NEITHER
COUNCIL. OR THE JUDGE
RECOGNIZES THE RECORDS NOT
BEING KEPT ACCURATELY THEY CAN
AS THEY HAVE FROM TIME
IMMEMORIAL RAISE THEIR HAND AND
SAY YOUR HONOR I DIDN'T GET
THAT. AND THEN THEY CAN GO BACK
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE RECORD
IS ACCURATE- THIS BILL HAS BEEN
WHITTLED DOWN THERE'S A TWO
YEAR SUNSET ON THE BILL- I AM
CONFIDENT THAT. ANY ISSUE
CONCERNING TECHNOLOGY WILL BE
WORKED OUT IS ALL WE'VE BEEN
DOING COURT CALL NOW FOR THIRTY
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA- AND SO
IT'S TIME THAT WE PROVIDE A
SMALL CHANGE THE PROCESS TO
ALLOW FOR INCREASED EFFICIENCY
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU. MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
BATES. BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM FIVE
CORTEZ HE- FIVE DALLY I DON
FIVE TORONTO. EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES. GROVE FIVE
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES FIVE CAMEL AUGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON. HI
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
BOTH. I PAN. HI FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS. I RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG I LIKE CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL I. HOME SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BASICS I. THERE ARE SO.
GONZALEZ MELINDA'S NIELSEN.
PRICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS IT IS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES THE
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FOLLOWING UNCERTAINTY NINE BY
SENATOR PAN BENNETT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
OH SIX BY SENATOR PAM AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE CENTER.
THANK YOU MISS PRESIDENTS
SENATORS- EVEN BEFORE COVERAGE
BEGAN A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
WE WERE SEEING ELEVATED RATES
OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASES HERE UNITED STATES
AFFECTED DC ESTIMATES THAT ONE
IN FIVE AMERICANS HAVE AN STD.
IN FACT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
OVER SIXTY MILLION STD
INFECTIONS REPORTED. AND
PERHAPS MORE SHOCKINGLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
BABIES WERE BORN WITH
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS AND EASILY
TREATABLE DISEASE A 9100%
INCREASE FROM. TWENTY TWELVE.
HAPPY CAN JOSEPH WAS CASES
OCCUR DUE TO GAPS IN TESTING
AND TREATMENT DURING PRENATAL
CARE AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CLOSE THAT GAP. SP THREE A
SIXTY TWO COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S SED CRISIS FOR
EXTENDING ACCESS TO CARE AND
AFFABLE WAY. CALIFORNIA'S
LAGGED IN ENACTING SCOTT PRINCE
OF POLICIES TO INCREASE ACCESS
AT THE SCREENING AND TREATMENT.
THE PANDEMIC FORTUNATELY IS
ONLY EXACERBATED STD RATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW
IS BEFORE GETTING BACK
TOGETHER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR WARNER. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CENTER
OF SACRAMENTO FOR. ABSORBING A
PIECE OF- OR BILL THAT I HAD
ANSWERS LAST YEAR AROUND RAPID
SUPPOSED TIES. THIS BILL IS
GONNA BE A HUGE STEP FORWARD IN
OUR GOAL OF REDUCING AND
ULTIMATELY WE HOPE AND THEY STI
INFECTIONS. IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN COMBINATION WITH THE BUDGET
WORK THAT'S HAPPENING- IN THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK WE CAN MAKE
REAL STRIDES OR HER TONIGHT
BOTH. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN G.
NINE. CENTER PANEL TO LOOK
CLOSE. YES WHEN I VOTE THANK
YOU. BEN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. I
BASE NO BECKER. HI FORTUS NO
BRADFORD I COME BY A HI
PROTESTING FIVE DALLY NO DONT
HI TORONTO I EGGMAN I PLEASE
SIR I CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HER
TADO FIVE JONES NO CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED I LLEVA I KNEW MY OWN.
I REQUIRE RIGHT HI MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW
OF BOTH. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. NOW. MS
OUR THIRD PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. MELINDA'S NIELSEN.
MEMBERS EYES THIRTY ONE NOSE
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESS SHELTERS
CENTERS FOR. GRANT PROGRAM FOR
HOMELESS WITH PETS GREAT BILL
THANK YOU PLEASE VOTE I. FOUR
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL NO NO
NO. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THAT PRESENTATION.
ARE TO USE ENTER. USES A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. HEARING
SEEING NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM EIGHTY
ONE SENATOR MEN ARE YOU
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED
BY SENATOR MAN AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES THURMAN THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SP FIVE HUNDRED WHICH
REQUIRES THAT ALL NEW LIGHT
DUTY ECONOMISTS VEHICLES BE
ZERO EMISSION BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY- THIS MEASURE IS
IMPORTANT IN HELPING OUR STATE
ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS YET
NECESSARY CLEAN AIR GOALS.
ESPECIALLY AS WE KNOW VEHICLE
EXHAUSTS TO BE SOME OF THE MOST
TOXIC POLLUTANTS IN OUR
ATMOSPHERE WE KNOW AUTOMATED
VEHICLES CAN BE PART OF A CLEAN
EQUITABLE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
BUT THEY NEED SOME GUIDANCE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- AND WE
KNOW ALSO THAT IS YOUR MISSION
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT SOME CONCEPT
OF SCIENCE FICTION. BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY AHEAD OF WHERE AV
TECHNOLOGY IS MANY OF YOU DRIVE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ALREADY
AND IN NINE YEARS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE FLEET OF OFFERINGS
WILL BE VERY ROBUST- COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALREADY DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
SOFTWARE OF AV TECHNOLOGY CAN
MATCH THE HARDWARE OF ZERO
EMISSIONS- THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PRECEDENT TO SET
BEFORE WE START DEPLOYING WIDE
NUMBERS OF AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
THIS MEASURE SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
LABOR GROUPS WE KNOW THAT TIME
IS VEHICLES ARE DESIGNED TO
DRIVE THEMSELVES BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE STEER THEM IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO THANK
YOU MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE. HEARING AND SEEING ON
MADAM SECRETARY. WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ACTIONS I BASE. BECKER FIVE
FOUR JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
I COURTESY. I DALLY NO DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN. I GLAZER
FIVE TEN DOLLARS I GROW.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT FIVE WITH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES. NO
KAMMERER I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA I
THE MON. I AM A LAWYER I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN A SHOW BOTH NO PAN.
PERSON TINA. HI ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. I AM BERG HI
BY CAL SKI. WINNER I WILL LOOK
NO- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT
TO MEMBERS. FAITH NO GROVE NO
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN PAN. WHITE
HOUSE SKI. FIVE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MOVING ON TO FALL I AM
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR JONES AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I MEAN PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
JONES AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES. SENATOR JONES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SENATE
BILL FIVE TWENTY EIGHT CREATES
A HEALTH CARE PORTAL THAT WILL
ALLOW HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES TO ACCESS
THE MEDICAL INFORMATION OF A
CHILD IN FOSTER CARE. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THE CRITICAL MEDICAL RECORDS OF
FOSTER YOUTH OFTEN HAVE ERRORS
ARE INCOMPLETE OR ALTOGETHER
UNAVAILABLE TO HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THE MANY
FOSTER YOUTH THAT HAVE SEVERE
DIAGNOSIS INCLUDING MULTIPLE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION. THE LACK OF MEDICAL
HISTORY MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH TO RECEIVE THE
CONTINUITY OF HEALTH CARE THEY
DESERVE. AND TRAITS CHALLENGES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH TO RECEIVE
PRESCRIPTION RENEWALS FOR THE
MAKE IT MEDICATION AND THEY
WERE ALREADY ON. THE SYSTEM
DEVELOPED UNDER SP FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT WILL HELP FURTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND THE
RATIONALE. BEHIND EARLIER
DIAGNOSIS AND PRESCRIPTIONS TO
CONFIRM THEY ARE STILL ACCURATE
AND NECESSARY. THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT TO EITHER CREATE
A NEW SYSTEM OR ROLL IT INTO A
NEW SYSTEM ALREADY UNDER
DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THESE
VULNERABLE YOUTH GET THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED ANY WORKABLE
MANNER MEMBERS I SINCERELY ASK
YOUR I'LL VOTE ON SB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
TRENT. THANK YOU- AND PLEASE
JUST SPEAK IN FAVOR OF- SP FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SANTEE FOR BRAIN
DISORDERS A PEDIATRICIAN WHO
TAKES CARE OF CHILDREN WHO ARE.
HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES-
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT- WE HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION
ESPECIALLY- FOR FOSTER YOUTH
THAT IS SOMEONE WHO'S- CHATTED
OCCASIONALLY. BEEN CHALLENGED
WITH THAT TAKING CARE OF
SOMEONE WHO'S IN FOSTER CARE
WHERE THERE AREN'T ACCURATE
RECORDS ACCURATE INFORMATION.
ABOUT PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS
ARE IN THERE TAKING THIS
BECOMES A REAL CHALLENGE TO BE
SURE TO GET QUALITY CARE- I
EXPECT THE OSCAR NIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN ADDITION TO
DESCRIPTION OF THE RATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING GENOMES SOONER
JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
IS WISE COMMENTS IN ASPEN I
WILL THANK YOU MA'AM SECT
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION WITH USING A
UNANIMOUS THROUGHPUT ROLL CALL
YES THERE IS AN OBJECTION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON. ALL ITEMS EIGHTY TWO.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ADKINS FIVE
BASICS I BACKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM BY
PROTECTING HI DALLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO NO EGGMAN. I LASER I
CONSOLIDATE. GROVE HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE.
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN
THAT SHOW BOTH. HI PAM FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN. HI
AMBERG. THE WHITE HOUSE SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI MA'AM SIR
RICHARD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ FIVE. MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S NEWMAN I NIELSEN
AMBERG HI. ALL EYES THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOW ME THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO
AN ACT RELATING TO RESTRAINING
ORDERS CENTER REVEAL THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT FIVE THIRTY EIGHT A
CRITICAL MEASURE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS SEEKING
PROTECTION FROM THEIR ABUSERS
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW VICTIMS TO FILE
ELECTRONIC DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. AND ALLOW
ACCESS TO A REMOTE TESTIMONY
THIS WILL CREATE GREATER SAFETY
FOR VICTIMS AS THEY TRIED TO
LEAVE DANGEROUS SITUATIONS WE
HAVE WITNESSES. THAT COME
FORWARD THAT SAY THEY DON'T
WANT TO FACE HER ABUSER SO THEY
DON'T. SPEAK TRUTHFULLY AND
SAFELY. SOLD THIS WILL HELP
GIVE THEM A PIECE OF MIND THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TESTIFY IN
FRONT IN FRONT OF SOMEONE THAT
HAS HARMED THEM. ACCORDING TO
JUST ONE CITY IN MY DISTRICT WE
EXPERIENCE A 2100% INCREASE IN
THE CASE WORKLOAD FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES AND THIS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF ONE COMMUNITY.
AND I'M SURE THAT THIS NUMBER
WILL CONTINUE TO RISE AS WE
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
COMPLETELY. IT'S INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR VICTIMS SEEKING
PROTECTIONS DURING SUCH
TERRIFYING TIMES SO PLEASE JOIN
ME IN REMOVING THESE BURIALS
BARRIERS TO HELP VICTIMS. THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXPANDS CURRENT
ACCESS TO COURTS AND ENCOURAGES
VICTIMS TO COME FORWARD SO I
ASKED RESPECTFULLY TO JOIN ME
AND VOTE ON SB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT TO PROTECT VICTIMS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE. IN NINETEEN NINE MONTHS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I BASE
I BECKER. I PORCHES HI BRADFORD
HI BY ADAM HI COURTESY HI DALLY
I DON HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN.
HI GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI
GROVE BY HERTZ BERG I WAS SO.
FIVE HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA. I
THE MON. I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN A SHOW
OF VOGUE I CAN. FIVE PORTS AND
TINA. I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN. HI AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE GIG I WINNER HI
WILKE HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS IT IS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FOLLOW ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR STERN ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT I DON'T. WHICH- YES.
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY BY SENATOR STERN
AN ACT RELATING TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. IN RETURN
FOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT THE END OF
LIFE SOME ARE MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY LIVE IN
NURSING HOMES- THIS MAY BE TRUE
IN SOME OF YOUR FAMILY'S IT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE IN MIND.
UNFORTUNATELY LAST YEAR
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISTS
AUDITS AND OTHER REPORTS HAVE
BEEN COVERED HOW FOR PROFIT
NURSING HOMES ARE USING COMPLEX
OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES. TO SIPHON
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS OF MONIES
TO QUOTE UNQUOTE RELATED
PARTIES. ALLOWING CORPORATE
HOME OFFICES TO HIDE HEIR
PROFITS. AND SUPPORT FACILITIES
CLAIM FOR YET MORE PUBLIC
FUNDING. IT SEEMS FROM THESE
REPORTS IN A RECENT AUDIT DONE
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
MANY OWNERS MANAGERS AND
OPERATORS OF THOSE FACILITIES.
MAY BE MORE INTERESTED IN THEIR
BOTTOM LINE INVESTING IN
QUALITY CARE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS. COUPLES PUT ALL THIS
INTO SHARP FOCUS- FOR THE COST
OF LIVING AND WE'LL BE
PROFITEERING GO UNEXAMINED
UNCHECKED. IT'S BECOME CLEAR
THAT THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY
UTILIZES VARIOUS ENTITIES
HOLDING COMPANY'S MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES TO SUPPORT THEIR
OVERALL BUSINESS ACTIVITIES.
THE OPTIONAL TITLE OF THE
PROPERTY WHERE THE NURSING
HOMES OPERATED. IN THE CONTRACT
WITH CORPORATIONS THAT. THEY
MAY BE OVER CHARGING FOR THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NURSING HOMES WITHIN
A CORPORATE FAMILY. AND MOST OF
THESE SERVICES ARE BEING PAID
FOR AND SUBSIDIZED BY MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID. THIS MAY BE
EFFECTIVE SHIELDING REVENUE SO
THEY ARE NOT FULLY CONSIDER
WHEN STATE ASSESSES PART
PROCREATE RATING REIMBURSEMENTS
FOR CARE. AND THIS WOULD MEAN
THE RATES PAID BY THE STATEMENT
OVER BEEF WOULD BE OVERPAYING.
WE'RE STILL THE INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES WITHIN THE CORPORATE
ENTERPRISE WOULD HAVE LESS
MONEY FOR ACTUAL OPERATIONS.
FOR THEIR STAFF. THEIR WAGES
SUPPLIES CENTER. ABOUT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR MEMBERS
SPENT ON RELATED PARTY
PAYMENTS. SO RATHER THAN TRY TO
INTERVENE IN THE MARKETPLACE
AND MICROMANAGE OUR NURSING
HOME INDUSTRY. GOES ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING NURSING HOMES TO FILE
A CPA REVIEW FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS. GIVEN THE STATE AND
THE PUBLIC MORE TRANSPARENCY
ALSO REQUIRES ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF REVENUE.
FROM SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
TO SUBMIT CERTAIN CONTRACTS AND
FINALLY THAT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY MUST PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION OUTLINING THE
ORGANIZATION'S STRUCTURE
INCLUDING RELATED PARTY PARTIES
AND THOSE RECEIVING REVENUES.
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. THIS
IS BILL'S BEEN WORKED ON
EXTENSIVELY WITH THEIR HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE CHAIR FOR HIS WORK AS WELL
AS IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. TO MANAGE COSTS MAKE
THIS WORKABLE FOR THE INDUSTRY
AND HOPEFULLY GET CONSUMERS THE
TRANSPARENCY THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED. AS WELL AS
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS WE OFTEN
SAY THAT THEY SHOULD CARE MORE.
BUT WE DON'T DO OUR PART IN
TAKING CARE OF THEM. THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY ACLU CALIFORNIA
A. L. P. CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM. THE
WIDE RANGE OF ADVOCATES AND
OTHER RIGHTS GROUPS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE HEALTH
FACILITIES AND PLAN TO DO SO.
IF THIS BILL MOVES FOR THE
ASSEMBLY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM HERE IN
CHINO AND FROM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
I AT KINS I BASE HI BECKER. HI
FOR JUST. NO BRADFORD I KERR
BIO HI COURTESY HI DALLY NO DOT
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO BY HER
DAUGHTER HI JONES NO CAMCORDER
I LAYERED I LLEVA FIVE THE MON.
I ACQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
BOTH. PANNED BY FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER
I STERN. HI AMBERG I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER FIVE WELK. I'M
SECTOR POLICE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. GROVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN THAT SHOW BOTH. I WELL.
HI. ALL EYES THIRTY FOUR NOES
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES NON
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
RUBIO MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY
TWO BY SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THAT THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SP SIX EIGHTY TWO ALSO
KNOWN AS THE AND RICH
INITIATIVE AND RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN CHILDREN'S HEALTH
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IN
COLLABORATION WITH RELEVANT
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS. AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO REDUCE
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH OUTCOMES BY
AT LEAST 50% BY TWENTY THIRTY.
DATA CONTINUES TO SHOW CLEARLY
DISPARITIES EXIST AND THAT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED. IN NINETEEN IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE AND WHERE THIS
ISSUE WAS HIGHLIGHTED AND THE
DISPARITIES COULDN'T BE MORE
CLEAR. THEY HAD HIGHER RATIOS
OF THE CASES OF CULPRIT
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS
AMONG OUR LATINO BLACK ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND NATIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF ALL
CHILDREN ALREADY EXPERIENCE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
OVERALL IMPACTING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE HOWEVER FAMILIES OF
COLOR ARE TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE MOST OF THESE CHRONIC.
DISEASES IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF
THE MOST COMMON CONDITIONS
AMONG AMONG ARGUED OUR ASMAN
DIABETES DEPRESSION DENTAL
CARIES AND VAPING RELATED
DISEASES THE STATE NEEDS TO BE
MORE PROACTIVE IN ITS APPROACH.
TO TACKLE THE RACIAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND MUST ESTABLISH
CLEAR TARGETS AND STEPS TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL ENSURING
EQUITABLE AND TIMELY ACCESS TO
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES WILL LEAD
TO BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AND LEAD TO HEALTHIER
AND MORE PRODUCTIVE ADULTS THAT
THOSE CHILDREN. WILL EVENTUALLY
BECOME THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS PASSED WITH
UNANIMOUS UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AGAIN THIS BILL SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES CLEAR TARGETS AND
STEPS TO ACHIEVE GOOD HEALTH
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND THEY ARE
IMPORTANT TO CAL THE FORMULA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX. HERE
IN CHINO AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
S. V. SIX EIGHT TWO. NINETEEN
NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
ON TO FOLLOW ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR GLAZIER HE IS
PREPAREDMADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR GLAZER
AND ACTS RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE WILL
PROVIDE INSIGHT TO POLICY
MAKERS AND STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT.
ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT HOW
COUNTIES ARE USING THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDS AND HOW THESE
FUNDS ARE SERVING OUR
CONSTITUENTS. MEMBERS WE SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
AND AN EFFORT TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT WE HAVE
PRECIOUS LITTLE DATA TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHICH OF THE
PROGRAMS WE ARE FINDING OUT THE
MOST EFFECTIVE. AND WHICH OF
THEM ARE ACTUALLY HELPING THE
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED
THIS ASSISTANCE. THIS IS NOT
JUST MY OPINION IT'S THE VIEW
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
LAST SUMMER THE STATE AUDITOR
RELEASED A REPORT DETAILING THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY FOR HOW
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED. AND THE BENEFITS
FROM THESE SERVICES. BASED ON
THEIR RECOMMENDATION. THIS BILL
CREATES A STATE FRAMEWORK FOR
COLLECTING INFORMATION ON
MENTAL HEALTH SPENDING AND
OUTCOMES. THE THROUGH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO COLLABORATE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL MENTAL HALTH
AGENCIES TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE TRACKING PROGRAM
FOR COUNTY SPENDING ON MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND THE
OUTCOMES FOR FROM THAT
SPENDING. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON FROM TO HAMMER FROM
BALDWIN PARK IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHO HAVE PARTNERED WITH ME ON
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN.
ERNESTINA AND MEMBERS THIS TOO
IS A- CANDIDATE FOR YOU.
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. YOU KNOW I MISSED
ROLL CALL I'M SURE YOU KNOW I
DON'T THROW CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING YOU KNOW
THROW CALL ON. THIS ITEM. THREE
NINE. ALL EYES THIRTY EIGHT.
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
DODD I SEE HE'S REPAIRED MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL LIABILITY. A POST GRAD
PART FIRES INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. LORD
OKAY. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING AN ADAMS
WROTE CALL. YOU'RE IN SCENE III
SATURDAY NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SEE SOME FOLKS ARE
PAYING ATTENTION ALL RIGHT. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW
EIGHTY NINE. SENATOR JOE BOLD
SHE IS RUSHING TO THE PODIUM
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY REALLY.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR OCHO A BOGUS AN ACT
RELATED TO TAXATION. SENATOR
JOE BOWEN HELLO THANK YOU- MR
PRESIDENT AS B. SIX SEVENTY
FIVE WOULD SIMPLY GIVE COUNTIES
THE OPTION TO IMPLEMENT A
PROGRAM TO ALLOW TAXPAYERS FOR
SIXTY TWO YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
OR WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME TO PAY THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES IN A MONTHLY
INSTALLMENT OF RATHER THAN INTO
LUMP SUMS. THIS WOULD BE A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM FOR BOTH THE
COUNTY AND THE TALK TAXPAYER.
AS EXISTING LAW STANDS NOW
PROPERTY TAXES ARE PAID INTO
ANNUAL INSTALLMENTS EXCEPT IF
AN OWNER IS IN DEFAULT. THE
SYSTEM BECOMES A PARTICULAR
PROBLEM WHEN HOMEOWNERS OWNED
THE PROPERTY OUT RIGHT ARE NO
LONGER PAYING MONTHLY MORTGAGES
AND HAVE NO IMPOUND ACCOUNTS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
FOR TAXPAYERS WHO RELY ON FIXED
INCOME SUCH AS THOSE OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY TWO. AND TAXPAYERS
WHO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME FOR DISABILITY.
SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW
COUNTIES TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON FIXED
INCOMES TO PAY THE PRINCIPAL.
OF THE TAX STEADILY. THIS BILL
IS TIMELY GIVEN THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTY THANKS TO
THE RECENT TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES. ONE SUCH OPTION IS A
PROGRAM DEVELOPED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES FINANCE COMMITTEE
CALLED EASY SMART PAY. IN
COUNTIES THAT OFFER THE EASY
SMARTPAY SOLUTION TAXPAYERS CAN
CHOOSE TO CREATE AN EASY SMART
PAY ACCOUNT AND PAY PROPERTY
TAXES MONTHLY WITH A CREDIT OR
DEBIT CARD OR DIRECTLY FROM THE
CHECKING ACCOUNT. THERE'S NO
COST TO THE COUNTY AND NO NEED
TO DEVELOP A NEW SYSTEM OR
SOFTWARE. EASY SMART PAGAN
INTEGRATES SEAMLESSLY WITH
EXISTING SYSTEMS. EASY SMARTPAY
HAS BEEN IN A PILOT PHASE FOR
THREE YEARS BUT SEE SEX FINANCE
COMMITTEE SAY THEY PLAN TO HAVE
THIS PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO ALL
COUNTIES IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. THIS BILL PRESERVES
LOCAL CONTROL BY ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO CHOOSE WHAT WORKS
BEST FOR THEM WHILE ALSO BUT
FURTHERING CONSUMER CHOICE BY
CREATING ADDITIONAL OPTIONS.
THIS BILL HAS HAD. BIPARTISAN
AND UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING ON THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SAYING NINE OZ THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. YEAH. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ITEM NINETY
ONE SENATOR DODD HE'S UP AND
READY MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY
REALLY. SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER RESOURCES
CENTER DOG FLOOR'S YOURS MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WISH THIS
WAS A SUPPORT SUPPORT BUT S. B.
SIX TWO SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
D. W. R. TO USE DESIGN BUILD A
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR PROCUREMENT METHODS
FOR PROJECT DELIVERIES FOR
FACILITIES OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT EXCLUDING THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE D. W. OURS- STATE
WATER PROJECT S. W. P. DRIVES
OVER FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
ANNUALLY. PROVIDING WATER TO
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IN OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND THE S. W. P. IT
DEFINITELY DELIVERS EXTENSIVE
HYDROELECTRIC POWER IN FLOOD
PROTECTION MUCH OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THE- S. W. P. IS OVER SIXTY
YEARS OLD. AND ISSUES OF
SUBSIDENCE A CLIMATE CHANGE
HAVE INCREASED THE CHALLENGES
AND DEMANDS ON THE MAINTENANCE
OF THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE AUTHORITY
TO UTILIZE THESE PROCUREMENT
METHODS WILL PROVIDE D. W. R.
WITH GREATER FLEXIBILITY
EXPERTISE WITH CONSTRUCTING
CRITICAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ACCELERATE PROJECT
COMPLETION. THE C. M. G. C. THE
C. M. C. G. EXCUSE ME AND
DECIDE. EXPERTISE AND BEST
INDUSTRY BACK PRACTICES FOR
PROJECT DELIVERY OUTSIDE OF D.
W. ARTS CORE COMPETENCIES AND A
LOT OF APARTMENT TO FOCUS
INSTEAD ON CRITICAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK LAST YEAR
I BOUGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING CNN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
I BASE NO BACKER. I FOR JUST.
HI BRADFORD I COULD BUY A HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY NO DOT I THERE
ARE SO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG BY WAY SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM. FIVE FOUR TWENTY.
I ROSS. FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
I STERN HI NUMBER I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER. FIVE WILKE HI.
MARCH THIRTY SIX NOTES TOO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FALL I KNOW NINETY
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER AT
THREE TEN HE'S PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL TEN BY SENATOR WIENER AN
MANAGEMENT. SHARKS CENTER
WINNER I APOLOGIZE I HAVE NO
PROBLEM IN CALL CENTRES CAMERAS
AND I APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES
ARRIVED TODAY- TO PRESENT
CENTRAL TIME- WHICH I OR WE
THIS BODY PASSED LAST YEAR IN
THE FORM OF CENTERVILLE MINERS
TO. I WANT TO THANK- THE PRO
TIME- FOR INCLUDING A SPEED
TEN. IN HER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SENATE HOUSING PACKAGE THIS
YEAR. SEVEN M. S. P. TEND TO BE
CLEAR IS A PURELY VOLUNTARY
LOCAL CONTROL BILL. IT IS A
BILL THAT GIVES CITIES. LOCAL
CONTROL MORE THAN THEY HAVE
NOW- WITH THIS NEW VOLUNTARY
TOOL THAT THEY CAN CHOOSE TO
USE. OR NOT TO USE TO REZONE-
PORTIONS OR ALL OR WHATEVER
THEY WANT OF THEIR CITY FOR
SMALL MULTI UNIT BUILDINGS A
CITY CAN DECIDE TO IGNORE THIS
LAW AND IT WILL HAVE NO
APPLICATION. IN THE CITY. THIS
IS A BILL WE- PUT A LOT OF
MANDATES ON CITIES AROUND
HOUSING I HAVE SUPPORTED THOSE
MANDATES THE MANDATES ARE OFTEN
IMPORTANT- BUT THIS IS A BILL
TO GIVE A TOOL THAT CITIES CAN
USE. IF THEY ANT TO MAKE OUR
LIVES EASIER IN ACHIEVING A
GOAL- THAT WE ALL SHARE WHICH
IS HOW MORE HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HI SPEED
APPLY- ALLOW CITIES IN A
STREAMLINED WAY TO ZONE FOR UP
TO TEN UNIT BUILDINGS DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE TEN UNITS COULD BE
TWO OR FOUR SIX. AFTER TIME.
THIRTY CAN DO AN EXPEDITED
STREAMLINED WAY- AS LONG AS
IT'S IN A NON SPRAWL AREA AND
IN PHILLY AREA. OR A TRANSIT
RICH AREA CURRENCY LAW CAN MAKE
IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. FOR
CITIES TO A ZONE FOR SMALL
MULTI UNIT BUILDINGS. EVEN IF
IT IS IN A VERY ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE AREA. I SEE TIME AS
A POWERFUL NEW TOOL FOR CITIES-
IT WILL HELP CITIES. SIXTY
AROUND HOUSING. AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SIR. WIENER ANY
FURTHER THE- OR DEBATES ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I'VE BEEN
READING A LOT LATELY ABOUT THE
SO CALLED ACCIDENTS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH SUPPOSEDLY
HAPPENED DURING THE PANDEMIC
FROM THERE WASN'T THAT LARGE OF
AN ACCIDENT IN FACT. HOWEVER
THE NUMBER ONE REASON THAT WAS
CITED BY THOSE WHO LEFT
INCLUDING THE BUSINESSES THAT
LACK. WHAT'S NOT OUR TAXES. NO
IT WAS THE COST OF HOUSING. THE
END WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
INTEREST STATE MOVING THOSE
FOLKS WHO MAY HAVE LEFT. ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH COST HOUSING
AREAS. THOSE FOLKS HAVE ALSO
MOVED. DUE TO THE COST OF
HOUSING. THEY MOVED TO AREAS.
TWO THREE HOURS AWAY FROM WHERE
THEY WORKED BECAUSE THE COST OF
HOUSING NOW WHY DO WE HAVE SUCH
HIGH COST OF HOUSING. BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT BUILT ENOUGH. BUT I
WOULD MOST SUIT MYSELF JUST AS
SOON NOT HAVE. TO BE- THAT
HAPPENED UNDER THE STRICTURES
OF SUPPLY SIDE ECONOMICS BUT
IT'S A FACT THAT WE HAVE NOT
PRODUCED THE DISPOSSESSED. THAT
WE NEED AND UNTIL WE DO WE ARE
NOT GOING TO LOWER THE COST OF
HOUSING. THIS ONE IS AN EASY
MEASURE IT DOESN'T FORCE ANY OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO IT
BUT FOR THOSE WHO ARE WILLING.
TO ADD A LITTLE MORE DENSITY
WHERE THERE ALREADY IS HIGH
NUMBERS OF JOBS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPORT
SERVICES IT ALLOWS ME TO DO IT
MORE EASILY AND. WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SIR.
SCANNERS ROOF. I TOLD HIM I.
THINK IT WAS PRESIDENT AND I
INTO OF THIS I IT JUST ONE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS BILL IS A
SENATE- WORKING HOUSING WORKING
GROUP PRIORITY AND I WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR BECAUSE THIS
BILL. RE STARTED IN MY OPINION
A LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE AND HE
WAS EXTREMELY GRACIOUS AND
TAKING STAKEHOLDER EMPIRE. OPT
FOR SOMEONE TO ADVOCATE FOR
LOCAL CONTROL THIS IS REALLY A
BALANCED MEASURE AS ALREADY
STATED THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
MEASURE THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CAN USE IF THEY CHOOSE TO. BUT
IT'S NOT A MANDATE AND ONCE
AGAIN A LOT THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS FLEXIBILITY AND
RECONSIDERING THE INPUT OF MY
DISTRICT AND ALL THOSE THAT
WERE AT THE TABLE SO WITH THAT
I ALSO URGE AND I WILL THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRIME OF.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR PLEASE- WE
WERE YOU THE QUESTION FROM
CENTER RIDGE. IF YOU WILL- HE
WILL I HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING THE BUYER RIGHT THAT
COMES WITH A NUMBER OF THE
HOUSING BILLS THAT WE'VE SEEN
YEAH HI AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
BEING PERMISSIVE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE THEN BE
ABLE TO. IMPOSE CERTAIN
RESTRICTIONS. ON HI. WORKING
ALL OF THAT IT. THE THAT
DENSIFICATION ABOUT AMOUNTS
WOULD MAKE ON LET'S SAY
RESIDENTIAL STREET. THANKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE
CENTER- FROM- FROM- ORANGE
FRIENDS AREN'T COUNTING ON. SO
THE ANSWER IS THIS STILL DOES
NOT CONSIST. ANY OTHER RULES
ARE REQUIREMENTS THAT CITIES
HOT THIS IS- FOR CITY COUNCIL
MIGHT DECIDE IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD WE WANT TO ALLOW
THREE UNIT BUILDINGS. AND THEY
WOULD SET THE HEIGHT LIMIT THEY
WOULD SET THE SET BACKS THEY
WOULD SET THEIR IMPACT FEES
THEY WOULD SET THEIR
INCLUSIONARY THERE SET THEIR
THEIR PARKING REQUIREMENTS THIS
CALL DOESN'T CHANGE THEIR
ABILITY TO SET ANY OF THAT. ALL
THIS BUILD US. THEY SAY. USE IF
YOU DECIDE THAT YOU WANT TO
ZONE FOR THESE SMALL MULTI UNIT
BUILDINGS IF YOU DECIDE YOU
WANT TO DO THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT EASIER FASTER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE. FOR YOU TO DO THAT.
THIS IS A BENEFIT FOR CITIES
AND IT DOESN'T TAKE ANY POWER
AWAY FROM THEM. I DIDN'T THE
BILL I DID NOTICE THAT. THE
OBVIOUS DOES NOT ALLOW
COMMUNITY INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
OR HOAS WITH CCN OURS TO.
PREVENT ON THIS KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT IN A PARTICULAR.
OUR H. AWAY OR COMMUNITY
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S COMPARED TO THE
S. B. NINE. THE PRESIDENT IS
OUR FIFTH IS CONSIST WITH THE
NUMBER OTHER HOW BILL- IT DOES
NOT- EXAMS IT'S ALWAYS- CITIES
ALREADY HAVE LATITUDE THESE ARE
THE H. O. A.'S- AND THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE OUT. THERE THE
H. ALWAYS HAVE- THE TERROR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ARE WE ARE
TALKING TO THEM NOW ABOUT
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE BECAUSE THEY
RAISE THE POSSIBILITY OF AN
UNINTENDED. SIDE EFFECTS THAT
WE DON'T INTEND- AND SO WERE
ACTUALLY I THINK EVEN TODAY WAS
OUR FIRST STAKEHOLDER MEETING
WITH THEM TO TALK THROUGH THEIR
ISSUES BECAUSE WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THEM TO RESOLVE IT
OBVIOUSLY THAT WON'T HAPPEN IN
THE SENATE- BUT COMMITTED TO.
SERVE REALLY FIGURING OUT HOW-
TO COME TO A RESOLUTION WITH
THEM. THANK YOU THAT SENATOR ON
MY OWN TIME I GOING TO REMAIN A-
IN WHOLE AS IT MAKES ITS WAY
THROUGH ALL OF THE OTHER HOUSES
SOME OF THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
STILL VERY. CONCERNING TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND IN
PARTICULAR TO NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACTS AND I WILL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. OF THE STREET THAT I
LIVE ON IT'S A CUL DE SAC IN IT
IT WAS NOT DESIGNED TO THE
EXACT RIGHT AWAY TO ACCOMMODATE
THE KIND OF DEVELOPMENT THAT
WAS ON THAT BLOCK SO PUBLIC
SAFETY VIA VEHICLES. LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRE ENGINES HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING DOWN THE
STREET TURNING AROUND IN A CUL
THE SAP DEVELOPMENT. WHEN
THERE'S NO PARKING REQUIREMENTS
WHICH WE HAVE. IN OUR
DEVELOPMENT AS A MATTER OF FACT
SO THE USERS SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED FRANKLY WITH MANY OF
THE HOUSING BILLS. SO I REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR CAN HELP THOSE
WHO ARE LISTENING OF MANY OF
THE- OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE
OPPOSING THESE BILLS- THE
SENATOR HAS ACCOMMODATED MANY
OF THOSE CONCERNS BY MAKING
THIS PERMISSIVE. ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE MORE SAY
AND CONTINUES TO WORK ON IT SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT I WILL
REMAIN OPPOSED AT LEAST AT THIS
JUNCTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MISS PRESIDENT MUST
FIND THAT. LONG DAY I CALLING I
RISE TO IN SOME OF SB TEN. AND
I WOULD REALLY DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS- I HAD SOME CONCERNS
INITIALLY BUT THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH AND HOW IT APPLIES
CERTAIN CITIES IN MY DISTRICT.
I THINK OF LAGUNA BEACH A PLACE
THAT HAS A ROBUST ECONOMY BUT
NOT ENOUGH INFRASTRUCTURE OR-
THROUGH WAYS TO REALLY SUPPORT
A LOT OF INCREASED DENSITY AT
THIS TIME. I APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR FOR TAKING THE
PERMISSIVE APPROACH AND
ALLOWING SOME MEASURE OF LOCAL
CONTROL. ON AND ALSO FOR
PARTICULAR REMOVING THE JOB
SERVICE PROVISION OF THIS BILL-
WHICH ALLOWS FOR DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE TO INCREASE DENSITY IN
WAYS THAT ARE NOT. HARMFUL TO
OUR CONCERNS. AS I SAID BEFORE
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS JUST
INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC RIGHT
NOW. IT'S A MORAL CRISIS AND WE
KNOW THAT THE TOP CAUSE OF
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE RIGHT
NOW IS A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IS AN ECONOMIC CRISIS
THAT IS BREWING I WANT TO SEE
MYSELF WITH MY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY- WE
KNOW THAT THE TOP REASON THAT
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE STATE
AND OR MOVING. IS BECAUSE OF
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
TO LIVE HERE OUR SENIORS CAN'T
RETIRE WITH DIGNITY WORKING
CLASS CALIFORNIANS. CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE STATE. WE
NEED SOME MEASURE BEYOND JUST
DELEGATING THIS TO OUR
LOCALITIES- THIS IS THE TYPE OF
MEASURE THE STICKS AND CARROTS
THAT WE NEED TO START.
IMPLEMENTING TO TRY TO REALLY
RESOLVE THIS HOUSING CRISIS SO
I COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND I URGE
YOU ALL TO VOTE HI. THINK YOU
SOONER OR LATER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT- I FELT LIKE
I WANTED TO COMMENT BECAUSE I
WAS WATCHING BILLS LIKE THIS.
WHILE I WAS RUNNING AND THIS IS
THE FIRST REAL ONE THAT HAS
COME UP. SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
AND- I WAS ELECTED TO REPRESENT
A DISTRICT THAT HAS TWENTY ONE
CITIES. AND IN THE LAST EIGHT
OR RATIONS OVER STRONG BILL.
FROM THE AUTHOR- TWENTY CITIES
OPPOSE IT THE ONE BIGGEST SANTA.
FOR IT WAS A GOOD I. IN THIS
THE CONCERN. OBVIOUSLY
OVERRIDING LOCAL LAND USE. BUT
THE ISSUED IT TO GO WITH THE
SENATOR FROM BERKLEY SAID. HE
HE IF OUR IDEA OF CREATING
AFFORDABILITY IS CLOSING THE
THREE MILLION. UNITS GAP OF
HOUSING. WHAT IS NOT GOING TO
GET THERE. IN A DECADE OR TWO
DECADES. AND SO TO DO BILLS
LIKE THIS AND NOT HAVE SOME
MEASURE OF AFFORDABILITY AND
THEM. IS CHALLENGING A. N. D.
THERE ARE DESERT LEAST ONE
BUILDER TO DISPUTE GOING ON IN
MY DISTRICT. WHERE IT EXPEDITED
THE PROCESS WITH THE
REQUIREMENT OF A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF AFFORDABLE. AND
YET THE LOCAL CITIES ALREADY
HAVE THAT AFFORDABLE. ENDED
OVER ROAD THAT SO WAS EXPLORING
THE PROCESS WITH NO INCREASE IN
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND SO I THINK
THE CHALLENGES. IS HOW TO
PRESENT THESE BILLS WITH SOME
PERCENTAGE FOR MEASURE OF
AFFORDABILITY AND- BECAUSE OF
ITS GONNA TAKE US TWENTY OR
THIRTY YEARS. TO GET ENOUGH
UNITS TO AFFECT THE MARKET. THE
CRISIS THAT EVERYBODY DESCRIBED
IS NOT GOING TO BE AFFECTED BY
THESE BILLS AND SO I THINK IT'S
OUR CHALLENGE. TO FIGURE OUT
HOWTHERE IS A PERCENTAGE OF
AFFORDABILITY IN EACH OF THESE
AS THEY COME BY US. AND IN THIS
ONE I GIVE CREDIT TO THE OFFER.
BECAUSE HE MOVED HE MADE IT
VOLUNTARY. BECAUSE IT'S
VOLUNTARY. R. WILL LIKELY VOTE
FOR. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT THERE. SOMETHING A AND-
FOR A RECALLDENSITY BONE AT A
CERTAIN LEVEL. OR SOME THAT
GIVE US A- THAT THERE SO MAJOR
OF BEFORE. ONE WE TAKE A STEP
THE STRONG ENOUGH TO OVERRIDE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO I JUST
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
MAKE THAT POINT GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS THE AUTHOR IS TAKEN
ALL VOTE FOR THE BILL. BUT IT'S
A FUTURE ONCE COMMA I THINK
I'LL BE LOOKING TO SEE IF
THERE'S AFFORDABLE BUILDING IN
THEM THAT'S SORT OF HOW I WILL
JUDGE WHETHER TO LOOK AT THE-
CAR AND I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS WORK. THANK YOU SENATOR
DELHI. THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT AS WE
ALL HEARD THIS IS A GREAT
ATTEMPT TO- TRY TO GET THE
DENSITIES WERE COMMUNITIES WANT
TO DO IT AND THEY HAVE THE
POWERTO DO IT. AS WE SHOULD
BUT I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY DID BRING UP A
GREAT POINT ABOUT PEOPLE
EXITING CALIFORNIA. AND
BASICALLY THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IS A SOMETHING THAT.
BUT I THINK IT IS AND SHE NOTED
THAT. TAXES AREN'T THE REASON
THAT PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. BUT I WOULD SHARE
WITH YOU REGULATIONS ARE THE
REASON PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA WHAT DRIVES UP THE
COST OF HOUSING. IS SICK WHAT
AND LOCAL TAXES FOR SCHOOLS AND
ROADS AND YOU NAME IT IT'S ALL
PILED ONTO. THE DEVELOPER AND
THAT DRIVES THE COST OF
HOUSING- IF WE REALLY TRULY
WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
FACE CALIFORNIA AND THE COST OF
HOUSING. WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE'RE IN AND FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO DRIVE THE COST OF BUILDING
THOSE HOUSES DOWN. TO GET TO
THE NUMBERS THAT WE NEED TO GET
TO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT. TO DO.
AND FILL PROJECTS WHERE WE
SHOULD WE'RE WE HAVE TRANCE
TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALL GOING
TO BE POSITIVE. TO DRIVE THAT
COSTS DOWN BUT IF WE REALLY
WANT TO TACKLE- THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO. GROW MORE HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA AT A RATE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN AFFECT THEM WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT THE COST OF
LIVING. AND THE COST OF LIVING
IS NOT JUST THE HOUSE. IT'S THE
COST OF LIVING FOR FUEL THE
COST OF LIVING FOR THE LECTURE
CITY THE COST OF LIVING FOR ALL
THOSE THINGS ARE ADDED INTO.
WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT STATES TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN BECAUSE THE
COST OF LIVING ACROSS THE
BOARD. IS HIGHER THAN OTHER
PLACES AND WE NEED TO BE
COMPETITIVE. AT SOME POINT. YOU
CAN'T JUST CONTINUE TO. ADD
THOSE COST ON AND EXPECT PEOPLE
NOT TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
LIVE HERE AND MOVE OUT. AT THE
SAME TIME WE TALK ABOUT DRIVING
UP. THINGS LIKE THE MINIMUM
WAGE AND TRY TO GET UP THEIR-WAGES. BUT WE STILL HAVE TO BE
IN A COMPETITIVE MARKET. THE
COMMODITIES IN THE THINGS THAT
WE- HAVE TO OFFER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- HAVE TO COMPETE
WITH OTHER STATES AND OTHER
NATIONS SO THAT'S THE CHALLENGE
FACED WITH. THIS BILL IS A
STREAMLINING PROCESS AND ALLOWS
THE LOCALS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING I THINK THIS IS STEP IN
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT IF WE
REALLY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT.
THE OVERALL CHALLENGE THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH WE HAVE TO
DRIVE THE COST OF BUILDING
THESE HOUSES DOWN. SO I URGE
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU HE FOR
THE DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THIS
ITEM. SCENE KNOWN SORRY.
SENATOR GLAZIER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ATTACKED
OFTEN THAT I WOULD JOIN WITH MY
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO- AND-
HOUSING BILL ON THIS FLOOR- BUT
I'M PLEASED TO DO SO HERE
TODAY- I'VE FOURTEEN SMALL
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT AND THERE
IS BEEN A LOT OF. SKEPTICISM TO
SAY THE LEAST FOR A TOP DOWN
APPROACH FROM THE LEGISLATURE
ON HOW WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
WHAT IS CLEARLY A HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE. BUT I
THINK THE AUTHOR FROM FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IS DONE A TERRIFIC
JOB IN TRYING TO FIND THOSE
RIGHT NOW IT'S- THAT CERTAINLY
BRING ME TO THE PODIUM TODAY TO
SAY THAT THIS IS A- A
THOUGHTFUL BILL THAT DOES
PROVIDE LOCAL CONTROL. AND IT'S
ONE THAT I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE. ON THIS
ITEM AT THREE TUNE. GOING ONCE.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR WINNER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT BECAUSE
AGAIN I DO REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL- DISCUSSION- TO
THE SENATOR FROM BEAVER- I
AGREE THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO THIS IS ONE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE ZONING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY- THE IT'S ABOUT
MATH IT'S ABOUT HOW MUCH.
NUMERICALLY HOW MANY HOMES ARE
LEGAL TO BUILD IN A PARTICULAR
AREA AND THIS WILL ALLOW CITIES
TO HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BUILD MORE- AND TO ITS OWN FOR
MORE AN EASIER WAY. I DO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
THE SENATOR FROM FROM SANTA
CRUZ AND AS SOMEONE ALL ON ALL
OF THE MANDATORY HOUSING BILLS
I'VE AUTHORED SB FIFTY SP
THIRTY FIVE TO GO ALL HAVE
BASELINE INCLUSIONARY
REQUIREMENTS UNLESS THE CITY
GOES HIGHER. ON THE NOT SO I'M
A BELIEVER- INCLUSIONARY AND
AFFORDABILITY HERE IN ADDITION
TO A CITY COURT ALL THIS ZONING
COULD BE FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
BUT ANY LOCAL INCLUSIONARY THAT
THE CITY HAS- WILL APPLY TO
THIS BILL OTHER CITIES
TYPICALLY DON'T START THEIR
INCLUSION ORIENTAL TEN UNITS SO
I THINK THIS BILL WILL HAVE
BENEFITS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT MORE WORK THAT
WE HAVE TO DO AND I AGREE IT
MIGHT TAKE US A FEW DECADES OF
FOR DILIGENT THE CLEAR THAT
MULTI MILLION HOME SHORTAGE-
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY THAT
THE BEST TIME TO PLANT A TREE
WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO THE SECOND
BEST TIME IS TODAY- WE WANT TO
FIX IT. HELP PEOPLE NOW INVEST
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME BUT IF WE'RE IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM FOR OUR KIDS AND
OUR GRANDKIDS AND OURGREAT
GRANDKIDS SO THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY WITH PEOPLE LIVING IN
CARS. AND PEOPLE HAVING TO MOVE
AWAY IF WE WANT THEM TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE THAN THE TIME TO
PLANT THE SEEDS IS NOW S. B.
TEN IS ONE OF THOSE SEEDS AND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR I
NINE FIVE. ALAN ARCHULETA HI
ATTENDEES I FACE NO BACKER.
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD HI BYRON
HI CORTESE HI DALLY I DONT HI
TORONTO. HI EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH I
HURTS BERG NO WAY SO HIGH FOR
TADO. HI JONES I CAN WATER.
LAYERED I LLEVA HI RAMON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN BUT SHOW BOTH
NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN.
NUMBER FIVE BY CAL SKI FIVE
WINNER I WELK NO. BUT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THAT TO MEMBERS.
ALAN NO. BECKER CAN LONGER. THE
MON. MELINDA'S NEWMAN. NIELSEN.
FOUR TWENTY NOW NO. STERN NO.
PRICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBER SELLS
OUR FINAL ITEM OF THE DAY NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO LIFTING
THE CALLS WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON
CALL. SO WE'RE GONNA START
WOULD FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE LOOK TO
CALL HOME FOLLOWING SIXTY SEVEN
S. B. SEVEN FOUR FOUR. FOR
JUST. I CABRERA. HI DODD. I THE
MON. I MELINDA'S. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I
HEAR SKINNER. ALONG SKINNER HI
KIM I DON'T KNOW I'D I'D KNOW.
PRICE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE LOOK TO
CALL AND FOLLOW HIM SIXTY EIGHT
OH THREE SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. POURTANT
TINO. I SCANNER. HI. HI
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE- HI
JONES NOTED I. WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE GOT THAT. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. OKAYWE'RE
GOING NOW TO FALL ITEM SIXTY
NINE S. P. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO WE
WILL LOOK TO CALL. JONES.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. FORTUNE TINO
I SKINNER. HI. WELK YEAH. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FOLLOW
HIM SEVENTY AS P. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
LOOK TO CALL. CABRERO I. DALLY
GROVE. MELINDA'S NIELSEN. FOUR
TWENTY NOW I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
HI. GROVE NO. DALLY NO. BARIS
THIRTY NOTES EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES OUR FINAL PHONE CALL I
DON'T MEMBERS IS FOLLOWING HIM
SEVENTY TWO S. B. SEVEN NINE
ONE AND SECRETARY PLEASE LOOK
TO CALL. ALAN. THE BASICS. FOR
JUST. DALLY DODD. I GLAZER.
GROVE JONES. MELINDA'S MEN.
NIELSEN SKINNER. HI. THIS IS. A
TROUBLED. I DON'T KNOW. MARCH
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS ARE
RATHER CLOSE RESOLUTIONS NOW'S
THE TIME TO REMOVE THE ITEM OR-
SENATOR WIENER. BUT. HI THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I BROUGHT FOR TWO
ITEMS I RISE TO- SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE SENATE JOURNAL-
THIS LETTER CLARIFIES MY INTENT
REGARDING RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
SENATE BILL TEN THE LETTER HAS
BEEN CLEARED BY BOTH CAUCUSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO ORDERED HI
IN A- THE PRESIDENT- I'D
REQUEST TO MOVE. REQUEST TO
MOVE FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE
TO AN ACTIVE FILLING OUT. ANY
OTHER MOTIONS RELISH CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THE MOVE PLEASE FOLLOW ITEM
THE INACTIVE FILE. S. V. THREE
HUNDRED. NINE FOR FIVE THREE
HUNDRED TEN AN ACTIVE FILE
CENTER CORTEZ IS ASKING FOR
THAT TO BE MOVED IN AN ACTIVE
FILE. SIX CENTRE COVER YOUR-
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I HAVE
FIVE BILLS TO MOVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE FILE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE SP FOUR NINETY.
FILE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR SP FIVE
THIRTY TWO. FILE NUMBER FORTY
NINE S. B. THREE EIGHTY TWO.
FILE NUMBER FIFTY SIX FIVE SP
FIVE FIVE EIGHT. AND FILE
NUMBER ONE OH TWO SP SIX
SEVENTY. THE KIDS UNDER COVER
JARLS US FOR FIVE MEASURES TO
BE MOVED TO AN ACTIVE FILE AS
BEEF FOR NINETY AS THREE FIVE
THREE TWO AS P. THREE EIGHT TWO
THREE FIVE FIVE EIGHT AND S. B.
SIX SEVENTY. SO NOTED. ANY
OTHER ACTIONS MOTIONS AT THIS
TIME. GOING ONCE. GOING TWICE
ANYBODY ELSE IN A WINNER YOU'RE
TAKING CARE OF. OUR MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE TOO
MANY ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS TIME
SENATOR SKINNER. SORRY ALL
RIGHT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT THREE FIFTEEN HERE ON
THE FLOOR. THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL MEET IN SENATE CHAMBERS AT
THREE FIFTEEN. THE CHAMP. THANK
YOU.
THIRTY SIX. SINNERS GONNA
GIVING REFERENCE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I WANT TO MAKE A
CORRECTION IN ORDER TO GIVE THE
FLOOR STAFF ENOUGH TIME TO BOTH
CLEAN AND- DO WHATEVER PROPER
PREPARATIONS WERE GOING TO HAVE
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AT THREE
THIRTY THREE THIRTY HERE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL MEET HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER. AT THREE
THIRTY. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS THE
DEATHS IS CLEAR. MR PRESS THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR THE INCREDIBLE WORK
TODAY- OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
WILL BE SCHEDULED FOR TOMORROW
THURSDAY JUNE THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM THANK
YOU. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
BE AN ADJOURNED WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE A.
M.